MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN.
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THE RHIZOME.
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE WHITE HOUSE STEVE
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WELL.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WHAT THE MEMBERS AND OUR GAS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LEAD
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
CHOPPER MACHIKO?
ORMAN AFTER WHICH WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY
SENATOR WHITE COLLAR SKI.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
OUR PRAYER TODAY'S FROM A BOOK
CALLED PRAYERS TO AN
EVOLUTIONARY GODS.
HOLY MYSTERY BEYOND OUR KNOWING.
WE SENSE YOUR SPIRITS IN THE
EVOLUTIONARY PROCESS.
AS THE DRIVING FORCE BUT URGES
UNFOLDING COMPLEX OF VACATION
AND CHANGE.
AND ALSO AS THE UNIMAGINABLE
MAGNETISM CALLING US TO FUTURE
WONDERFUL BEYOND OUR DREAMS.
YOU ARE LIFE ENERGY BEAUTY.
WISDOM IMPENETRABLE MYSTERY.
IN HUMILITY.
WE PRAISE THE WONDERS OF YOUR
CREATION.
AND SICK ONLY TO PLAY ARE
NATURAL AND LOVE DESIGNS ROLE.
HERE IN REFERENCE AND GRATITUDE
A MAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG --
FOR ALL
.
MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGE FROM THE ASSEMBLY SO
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
MISTER PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTED
TO INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ON THIS DAY
RESPECTFULLY REFUSED TO TO
CONQUER AND SENATE AMENDMENTS TO
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTY FOUR EAT DOTSON WILSON
CHIEF CLERK OF THE ASSEMBLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
MOVING NOW TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE SECOND READING WE
HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR FIVE EIGHTY AND
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
SIX NINETY FIVE OKAY.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
BE MOVED TO FILE THE FOLLOWING
THREE MEASURES OUT OF WARNER BY
SENATOR MITCHELL.
CENTER MEASURE YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP YOUR ITEMS.
WILL BE DEALING WITH ITEM
SEVENTY THREE MADAM.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING
TO JUVENILES.
DINNER MITCHELL.
BETTER TO SEE YOU WITH MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
A GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES ARE
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL SEVEN SIXTEEN IT WILL
ENSURE THAT INCARCERATED YOU
WITH HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS HAVE
ACCESS. TO A COLLEGE EDUCATION
AND CAREER VOCATIONAL TRAINING.
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS UNDER THIS
BILL WILL NOW BE REQUIRED TO
COLLABORATE WITH PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS AND
CAREER TECH TRAINING ENTITIES IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
EDUCATIONAL EDUCATION INVOKE
TRAINING DEVELOPED AN
OCCUPATIONAL SKILL AT LEAST
PRODUCTIVE CAREER PATH WHICH IN
TURN REDUCES RECIDIVISM AND
FUTURE INVOLVED WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
RECENT AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE
COST OF THE BILL AND CLARIFY THE
ARRAY OF SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED FOR THESE FOSTER YOU
AGAIN WE'RE TARGETING YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
WHO WERE IN JUVENILE FACILITIES
WHO HAVE NOTHING TO DO BECAUSE
THE FOCUS OF THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT IS TO GET A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA THIS WILL ALLOW
THEM TO CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION
AND WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE?
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
TURNING TINA AND MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ART I HAVE A YELLOW
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS -- I GALGIANI
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WITH SO.
I TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
I LIVE UP.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOT [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I REVIEW [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SOONER MITCHELL MOVES A CALL
NEXT UP IS ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT
CENTER MATURE YOU PREPARE.
HER MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING
TO DETENTION FACILITIES SENATE
MITCHELL.
MISTER PRESIDENT ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL
FIVE FIVE FIVE WILL REDUCE THE
COST OF COMMUNICATION SERVICES
AND COMMISSARY ITEMS.
SOLD IN COUNTY JAILS IN STORES
BORNE BY THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ENSURE.
THE IN THIS IS CRITICAL BUT ANY
FUNDS COLLECTED FROM THESE FEES
ARE SOLELY USE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE REHABILITATION OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE THIS BILL
DOES NOT ELIMINATE THE WELFARE
IN MAY FOR THE INMATE WELFARE
FUN.
IT SIMPLY RESTATES WHAT CURRENT
LAW HAS ALREADY STATED THAT THE
FUNDS MUST BE USED ON BEHALF OF
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED.
FUNDS COLLECTED FROM
COMMUNICATION SERVICES FEES AND
COUNTY JAIL STORE ITEMS ARE
DEPOSITED INTO THE INMATE
WELFARE FUND FOR THE INTENDED
BENEFIT OF INMATES.
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THESE
FUNDS HAD BEEN MISUSED FOR
PURPOSES THAT DO NOT DIRECTLY
BENEFIT THE REHABILITATION OF
INMATES AND I'VE BEEN INSTEAD
USE THE SERVICES.
THEIR PROBATION DEPARTMENTS AND
COUNTY JAIL SHOULD ALREADY BE
PROVIDING FOR EXAMPLE PAYING FOR
SALARIES PURCHASING SECURITY
CAMERAS.
IN FOR AN INMATE TRANSPORTATION
VANS.
RECENT AMENDMENTSREQUIRE
COUNTIES TO MAKE THESE CHANGES
WHEN RENEWING OR ESTABLISHING
NEW CONTRACTS WITH
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS.
AGAIN I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING HER NINE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI I HAVE A ADAM
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I DRAWS -- I GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO -- DATO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible] FIVE
MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MARROW [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible] FIVE STONE
[inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
HI WHAT CASKEY.
I WIENER.
I WILL.
I DEAR MR MOVES A CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED
BY SENATOR MITCHELL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ONE
ARE YOU [inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING
TO MEDI CAL.
THERE MITCHELL MISTER PRESIDENT
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WE AUTHORED
AB THREE SIX ONE WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE CREATION OF
HEALTH HOMES PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS AFTER THE
PASSAGE.
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THIS
WAS SHORTLY AFTER THE RECESSION
THERE FOR THE BILL ALLOW THE
PROGRAM TO END AFTER TWO YEARS
ABOUT A SUNSET.
I'M GUARANTEED LONG TERM STATE
FUNDING BECAUSE HEALTH PLANS TO
DROP OUT OF THE PROGRAM AND
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION ACROSS
THE STATE.
NOW THAT OUR ECONOMY IS IN A
MUCH BETTER POSITION SENATE BILL
THREE SIX ONE WILL ENSURE THAT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HEALTH
HOMES PROGRAM IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE INTENT OF THE ORIGINAL LAW
PASSED IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN THE GOAL OF THE
HEALTH HOMES PROGRAM IS TO HELP
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIS WHO ARE
HOMELESS AND OR LIVE WITH
MULTIPLE CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS OR SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESSES.
WITH THAT HERE AND THE
MEDICATION LINK THEM TO PEER
FAMILY SUPPORT SYSTEMS AND
PROVIDE HOUSING TRANSITION
SERVICES AMONG OTHER SERVICES.
HELP HOME PROGRAMS ARE A A
STAPLE.
IN MANY STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
OTHER STATES INCLUDING MISSOURI
IOWA ALABAMA AND WISCONSIN HAVE
SEEN COSTA THEIR MEDI CAL
PROGRAM REDUCED AFTER
IMPLEMENTING A HEALTH HOMES
PROGRAM.
HAD OBEYED IMPROVEMENTS MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO THE CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS OF THE MEDI
CAL POPULATION.
RECENT AMENDMENTS MAKE THE BILL
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION. FOUR
TIERED PROVIDER RATE WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ISLAND.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BY ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible] FIVE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible] FIVE LEYVA
[inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LIKE [inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH. FIVE RUBIO [inaudible]
FIVE SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I LIKE HOW SKI [inaudible] FIVE
WIENER.
BY WELL.
HI.
MA'AM SECURE PLACE CALLED UP TO
MEMBER [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY SEVEN YEAR YES IS
ZERO KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES
NEXT UP WERE RETURNING BACK TO
FOLLOW ORDER AND WE'RE MOVING TO
A FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TEN ARE YOU READY SENATOR
MCGUIRE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE.
SENATE FELL THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES.
MISTER MCGUIRE HEY WHAT'S GOING
ON MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND MEMBERS THE STATE IT'S
GUARDIAN TO APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH.
I AND HOLD THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
INSURE THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
THIS EXTENDS THIS BILL EXTENDS A
MONITORING THE MINISTRATION OF
MIND NUMBING PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS THAT CAN LEAD TO
IRREVERSIBLE.
IN LIFELONG HEALTH IMPACTS IT
NOT PRESCRIBED APPROPRIATELY.
IN AN EFFORT TO CRACK DOWN ON
EXCESSIVE AND UNNECESSARY
PSYCHOTROPIC PRESCRIBING TO PASS
YOU.
THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
PASSED A SERIES OF BILLS AND
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN INCLUDING SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WHICH WAS
INTENDED TO GIVE THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD DATA. TO
INVESTIGATE POTENTIAL CASES OF
INAPPROPRIATE PRESCRIBING.
ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BUILT OFF OF
AN EXISTING DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT AND ESTABLISH A FORMAL
ONGOING PROCESS FOR THE MEDICAL
BOARD REVIEW AND CONFIDENTIALLY
INVESTIGATE PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATION PRESCRIPTION PATTERNS.
WELL ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WAS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS
SINCE INDICATED THAT THE DATA
SHARED DOES NOT PROVIDE ENOUGH
INFORMATION FOR THEM TO
INVESTIGATE PRESCRIBING PATTERNS
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS.
TO CRITICAL MEDICAL INFORMATION
SUCH AS SYMPTOMS AND DIAGNOSIS
FOR THE PSYCH MEDS PRESCRIPTION
SB THREE SEVEN SEVEN WILL CUT
THROUGH THE RED TAPE AND FINALLY
ALLOW FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD. TO
GET ACCESS THAT IN INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO TO CONFIDENTIALLY
INVESTIGATE BY GRANTING
AUTHORIZATION WHEN THE
MEDICATION IS AUTHORIZED BY THE
COURTS CURRENTLY ALL
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION FOR
MINORS AND FOUGHT THE FOSTER
YOUTH.
MUST BE APPROVED BY JUVENILE
COURT JUDGE THREE SEVEN SEVEN OH
CREATE A PROCESS THAT
ESTABLISHED AT THE TIME OF
APPROVAL OF A SITE MADE A
JUVENILE COURT JUDGE WILL
AUTHORIZE MEDICAL BOARD TO
REVIEW THE MEDICAL INFORMATION.
FOR THE PRESCRIPTION SHOULD THE
MEDICAL BOARD NEED TO
INVESTIGATE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK.
FOR NINETY THANK YOU IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
SHE THIS IS SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING -- COLLEAGUES -- I
CERTAINLY -- APPLAUD THE AUTHOR.
FOR HI HIS CONCERN ABOUT THE
UTILIZATION OF PSYCHOTROPIC
DRUGS -- AND OUR OUR JUVENILES
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT -- ARE
UNDER THE CARE OF ADULTS AND THE
COURTS.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD DOES NOT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE. TO GET INTO THE
PATIENT DOCTOR RELATIONSHIP WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE WE HAVE
SOME VERY COMPLEX CASES THAT
REQUIRE PSYCHIATRIC INTERVENTION.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD
[inaudible]
QUESTION.
OF THE PSYCHIATRISTS
[inaudible]
THAT.
ARE DOING THEIR BEST.
WITH THEIR YEARS OF KNOWLEDGE
FOUR YEARS OF MEDICAL SCHOOL --
MANY YEARS OF GOING INTO
PSYCHIATRY.
AND AND STARTING A VERY NARROW --
GROUP OF THE DRUGS UNDERSTANDING
THEIR PHARMACOLOGY UNDERSTANDING
THEIR THEIR THERAPEUTIC
APPLICATION [inaudible]
AND AND I THINK THIS COULD BE
LATE TREATMENT TO KIDS ARE
REALLY NEED IT SO.
I THINK THE AUTHOR IS IS
CERTAINLY ON ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
TO REVIEW -- THE OVER
UTILIZATION IN CASES MAYBE BY
NON PSYCHIATRISTS BUT I'M
CONCERNED THAT.
HOPEFULLY A MAJORITY THESE KIDS
ARE BEING SEEN BY MEDICAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
AND I THINK WERE OPENING UP
PANDORA'S BOX IF WE'RE GONNA
START HAVING THE MEDICAL BOARD
QUESTIONING THE EFFICACY OF THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE.
AND I THINK THAT THIS WILL OPEN
THE DOOR TO THAT HAPPENING AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I'LL HAVE
TO OPPOSE SB.
THREE SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DESCRIPTION -- GREAT.
SENATE MCGUIRE TO A CLOSE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT SO
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE.
THE MEDICAL BOARD HAS BEEN GIVEN
OVERSEE SCRIPT OVERSEE MEDIC
PROFESSIONAL PSYCHIATRIST
SYCHOLOGIST DOCTORS IN THIS
STATE FOR DECADES. FOR DECADES
THIS ISN'T WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT IN THE MEDICAL BOARD
ALREADY HAS FULL AUTHORITY TO BE
ABLE TO INVESTIGATE.
AND WHEN IT COMES TO DELAYING
ANY POTENTIAL PRESCRIPTION THE
COURTS TO IT.
SO WHEN A FOSTER YOUTH GOES INTO
THE COURT. TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON CUSTODY IN MEDICAL
PRESCRIBING PATTERNS.
THE JUDGE.
WITH THE CAN A CONSULTATION OF A
PSYCHIATRIST.
BRINGS FORD THAT PRESCRIPTION
PATTERN.
IF WE WANT TO QUESTION THOSE
PROFESSIONALS I WANT TO GIVE YOU
SOME STATISTICS.
WHEN THIS BILL WAS A RATE WHEN
THE ELEVEN SEVENTY FOUR WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ONE IN FOUR TEENS IN FOSTER CARE
HAD BEEN PRESCRIBED PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS IN THIRTY SIX OF
THOSE YOUTH WE'RE TAKING
MULTIPLE PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS? 56% OF CHILDREN
FOSTER CARE RESIDING IN GROUP
HOMES WERE BEING PRESCRIBED.
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION THERE
WAS MULTIPLE INVESTIGATIONS DONE
BY NEWSPAPERS UP AND DOWN THIS
STATE SHOWING THAT THESE
PSYCHOTROPIC EDICATIONS.
WERE BEING PRESCRIBED
INAPPROPRIATELY TO FOSTER USE
MIND NUMBING DRUGS AND FOR THE
NAME OF FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
PROTECTION WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD ART HI CABALLERO
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DON [inaudible]
I RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
I TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible] FIVE WELL
[inaudible]
HI.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
MEASURE PROCESS NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM TN SOONER WAYS OR YOU
PREPARED FOR FALLEN.
I'M SORRY THIRTEEN AMPS ARE
FALLING.
THIRTEEN I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH SIX BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY.
THROUGH A SO.
THANK YOU MUST PRESIDENT
SENATORS IF YOU THOUGHT THE
ENERGY CRISIS OF TWO THOUSAND
TWO THOUSAND TWO IS A DISTANT
MEMORY WELL THINK AGAIN WE'RE
STILL FIGHTING LITIGATION HAVING
TO DO WITH THAT AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS BEEN A REPRESENTING
THE STATE.
IN A A HAS REPRESENTING HAS BEEN
REPRESENTING CONSUMERS.
IN IN LITIGATION DATING BACK
FROM THAT TIME -- THERE WAS AN
ORGANISM -- ON AN ACTUAL BOARD
THE ELECTRIC OVERSIGHT BOARD HAT
WHICH IS.
IS IS NO LONGER IN EXISTENCE BUT
IT'S STILL A PARTY TO THIS LOSS
TO THIS BILL SIMPLY.
A REINSTATE SEE ATTORNEYS
GENERALS AUTHORITY TO CONTINUE
TO REPRESENT REPAIR INTEREST IN
EXISTING LITIGATION CASES.
STEMMING FROM THE ENERGY CRISIS.
AND THIS COULD POTENTIALLY
RESULT IN THE RECOVERY OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR REPAIRS I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE --
ON BEHALF OF REPAIRS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR SB FIVE OH SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING TINA AND THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF
USER UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
MEASURE. THIRTY SEVEN ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR GLAZER
CENTER GLAZER YOU.
READY.
FOR TWENTY THREE PASS
TEMPORARILY NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY BY CENTER WHY KASKI
SOONER ACOSTA ARE YOU READY.
YES MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC RECORDS.
WHY BECAUSE YOU?
MISTER PRESIDENT SENATE BILL
FIVE EIGHTEEN CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW.
IN THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT THAT THE COURT SHALL NOT.
AWARD COURT COSTS AND REASONABLE
ATTORNEY FEES TO REQUEST --
SHOULD THE REQUESTER PREVAIL
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A FEW
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT ARE FOUND
THE WAY. TO CIRCUMVENT THIS
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT LAW BY USING --
NINE NINE EIGHT OFFERS THESE
OFFERS PREVENT THE RELEASE OF
THIS CLOSABLE DOCUMENTS AND
SHIFT ALL THE POST OFFER COSTS
ONTO THE RECORDS REQUEST --
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN
INSURES THAT OUR PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT IS BEING USED AS IT WAS
INTENDED AS A WAY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO GET INFORMATION
FROM THE GOVERNMENT WITHOUT FEAR
OF BEING BURDENED BY THE
GOVERNMENT COSTS AND WITH THAT.
I'D ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE ON SCENE.
NINE MANSERVANT OR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudibe]
I HILL.
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible] FIVE JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible] FIVE
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I WANNA LOCK [inaudible]
NO BROWN [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible] FIVE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE E..
I WIENER.
I WILK.
HI.
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
MACINNES [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO GROWTH [inaudible]
NOW.
MARCH TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE AND
THE MEASURE PROCESS NEXT RETURN
DOCTOR FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
SENATOR GLAZER YOU PREPARE TO
TAKE UP THE SIDE ON SCENE THAT
YOU ARE MEANT SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT BY SENATOR
GLAZER AN ACT RELATING TO PARKS.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS AT THOSE WHO ARE
HISTORIANS AND I KNOW THERE ARE
A FEW HERE ON THE FLOOR -- YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GO TOO FAR BACK IN
HISTORY TO REMEMBER CENTER BLOCK
FROM SAN DIEGO WHO CARRIED.
SIMILAR LEGISLATION TO WHAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY REGARDING
SMOKING BANNING SMOKING IN PARKS
AND AND STATE BEACHES HE WORKED
ON THIS ISSUE. FOR FOR MANY
YEARS AND I HAD TOOK UP THE THE
EFFORT -- WITH HIS DEPARTURE.
AND WE PASS THIS LEGISLATION TO
BAN SMOKING AT STATE PARKS AND
BEACHES THROUGH THE SENATE HERE
A NUMBER OF TIMES INCLUDING THE
PAST YEAR [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY THAT.
THE PAST GOVERNOR I'VE MADE A
CHOICE IT WAS INTO READY FOR HIM.
SO WE'RE COMING BACK IT'S MORE
THAN THE THIRD TIME BUT
HOPEFULLY FOR WITH ME AT LEAST
THIRD TIME WILL BE THE CHARM.
BUT THIS BILL WOULD -- PROHIBITS
SMOKING AT A STATE PARK MAKE IT
INFRACTION PUNISHABLE BY A FINE
OF UP TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
THE SMOKING PROHIBITION.
CONTAINED IN THE BILL WOULD BE
ENFORCED ONLY AFTER SIGNS HAVE
BEEN POSTED.
THE BILL AUTHORIZES THE DIRECTOR
OF PARKS AND REC TO DESIGNATE
AREAS AS EXEMPTS.
FROM THE SMOKING PROHIBITION.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION TOBACCO KILLS OVER
FORTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EVERY YEAR.
SECONDS THOUSANDS MORE AND COST
THE STATE MORE THAN TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION IN HEALTH CARE.
MEDICAID IN LOST PRODUCTIVITY.
ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
SMOKING AND HEALTH CARE COSTS OF
THE STATE.
ARE VERY WELL KNOWN.
A RECENT STATEWIDE POLL
CONDUCTED BY THE LUNG
ASSOCIATION.
SHOW THAT 71% OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORTED POLICIES THAT PROHIBIT.
EXPOSURE TO SECONDHAND SMOKE IN
AREAS FREQUENTED BY THE PUBLIC
CONSERVING THAT'S THE CASE WITH
OUR BEACHES AND OUR PARKS.
AND IT'S MORE THAN JUST A
PERSONAL HEALTH AND PUBLIC
HEALTH SMOKING ALSO HARMS THE
ENVIRONMENT.
CIGARETTE **** ARE A MAJOR
SOURCE OF WASTE AND LITTER.
CIGARETTES ALSO BECAUSE WILD
FIRES ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FIRES HAVE
BEEN CAUSED BY SMOKING SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN BANNING
SMOKING AT STATE PARKS AND AS
THE NEXT STEP IN ADDRESSING
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SERIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES THAT ARE ALSO
ASSOCIATED WITH SMOKING WITH
THAT I ASKED RESPECTFULLY FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR BORDERS.
JUST A QUICK QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR IF I MAY MISTER PRESIDENT
WE TO QUESTION FOR YES SIR.
SERVICES PRIMARILY AN ANTI
SMOKING -- BILL OR IS IT A
POLLUTION -- BILL.
I IT'S BOTH OF THOSE AND I WOULD
SAY IT'S ALSO ALLOWED FIRE --
BILL BECAUSE SO MANY OF THE
FIRES THAT IN COST INTERSTATE OF
COME FROM SMOKING SO I'D SAY
IT'S ALL.
THREE THANK YOU.
OZ CENTER STERN FAMOUS PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE -- THIRD TIME
HOPEFULLY IS A CHARM I DID WANT
TO GET -- A QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR THOUGH WE WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH COMMITTEE WE KNOW OUR
STATE PARK RANGERS ARE
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED
OPERATION MAINTENANCE FUNDS ARE
HARD TO COME BY WE WONDER GLAZER
WERE YOU TAKE A COURSE FORCIBLE
SO THAT STERN -- CAN YOU UPDATE
US ON YOUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE PARK RANGERS AND WHAT YOU
SEE FOR IS AT THAT. TO MAKE THIS
A TRULY ENFORCEABLE FRAMEWORK.
THANK YOU TO THIS THE SENATOR
FROM VENTURA FOR THE QUESTION
THAT THE ISSUE HERE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT -- IS THERE
CONCERN ABOUT ENFORCEMENT THAT
WERE SOMEBODY TO MAKE A CLAIM
THAT.
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN SMOKING FOR
RELIGIOUS REASONS THAT IT WOULD
MAKE AT ENFORCEMENT DECISION BY
THE RANGER MORE DIFFICULT IS
THAT THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GOING
HERE.
SO -- IN CONSULTATION WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS ON
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE.
THE CONCERN IS THAT -- OUR
ABILITY TO LIMIT SMOKING AS
RELATES TO RELIGIOUS ACTIVITIES
CREATES A FIRST AMENDMENT
CONCERNS.
AND SO IT'S DIVERT TO BE
DEPENDENT UPON THE RANGER TO
MAKE THE BEST CHOICE THAT THEY
CAN MAKE HERE SHE CAN MAKE IN
THE FIELD.
AND THAT THE COURT SYSTEM WOULD
YOU QUE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
JUDGMENT WAS APPROPRIATE GIVEN
THAT CLAIM OF A RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTION.
AND SO THAT IS A A EXEMPTION IN
THE BILL.
IT WAS CAREFULLY THOUGHT THROUGH
BECAUSE OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
ISSUES I'M SENSITIVE TO THE
ENFORCEMENT CHOICE THAT.
RANGERS WOULD NEED TO MAKE UNDER
IT AND I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM AND I'M CERTAINLY OPEN
TO CONTINUING THAT.
THAT CONVERSATION IN TRYING TO
BALANCE -- THEIR ABILITY TO DO
THEIR JOB WELL WHICH THEY'RE
VERY WELL EQUIPPED TO DO AND DO
SO WELL.
AS WELL AS THE PROTECTIONS FOR A
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM THAT REMAINS --
CHALLENGE.
THANK YOU. TO THE TO THE SENATOR
FROM CONTRA COSTA I WOULD I
WOULD JUST URGE GOING FOR TO
MAKE THIS BILL WORK.
WE NEED TO SOLVE A CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING OF OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE AND OUR STATE PARK
SYSTEM SO LOOK FOR TO PARTNERING
WITH YOU ON THAT EFFORT TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THE RANGERS
HAVE THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO GO.
TO THEIR JOBS THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENIOR NINE
CENTER GLAZER WHICH ELECT KLAUS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AND I CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THAT.
COMMENTS FROM THE SENATOR FROM
MENTOR AND THAT -- APPROPRIATELY
FUNDING OUR PARKS DEPARTMENT I
ARE RANGERS -- AND THAT IT WAS
JUST BAD AND BEYOND THAT SIGN
AGE -- PROTECTION TO OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT THAT -- WE'RE SHORT
CHANGING WITH OUR MAINTENANCE
PROBLEMS ARE PARKS THERE'S LOTS
OF ISSUES THERE THAT ARE ON US
TO TRY TO WORK ON AND I LOOK FOR
TO WORKING WITH HIM AND OTHERS
ON THAT WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGHT OF MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE AYE ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS. FIVE BATES.
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD. FIVE THEY'RE AWESOME
[inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
HI -- TADA.
I AYE JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO GROW [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
NO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD HI I TWENTY EIGHT I
MEAN I'M SORRY AGE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS TEN MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP WE HAVE FILE FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR CAFIERO
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS
ITEM.
YES MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO CANNABIS
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB.
FIVE EIGHTY ONE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE.
THE DEPARTMENT THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE TO POST ON THEIR
INTERNET WEBSITE.
OR ON THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
PORTAL INFORMATION ABOUT AN
APPLICANT AT LICENSEE THAT IS IN
THE RESPECTIVE AGENCIES
POSSESSION AND CONTROL WHICH IS
ALSO A PUBLIC IN WHICH IS ALSO
PUBLIC INFORMATION UNDER THE PUB
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
THIS BILL WOULD BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO THIS NEWLY
LEGALIZED INDUSTRY AND PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC AND INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS WITH A CENTRALIZED
LIST OF WHO IS APPLYING. FOR THE
LICENSES AND WHO IS LICENSED IN
THE STATE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
POLICY COMMITTEES AND RECEIVED
ZERO NO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENIOR NINE MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS.
I BATES I'M SORRY THIS IS.
UP OKAY FIVE WELL.
WELL I'D FOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THE RHIZOME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible] FIVE
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible] FIVE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I BROUGHT [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WHITE HOUSE HE HI WIENER
[inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI -- SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
WIENER.
OKAY ALL ICE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE SENATOR GALGIANI.
PREPARE TOOK UP THE SIDE ON YES
YOU ARE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AN ACT RELATING
TO CANNABIS.
DINNER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN
PROVIDES VETERINARIANS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOMMEND THE USE
OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS FOR
MEDICINAL USE ON THEIR ANIMAL
PATIENTS.
PASS OUR FURRY FRIENDS SUFFER
FROM MANY OF THE SAME IF NOT
SIMILAR AILMENTS THAT HUMANS DO
AND WHICH MEDI MEDICINAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO HAVE.
A THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT.
SINCE VETERINARIANS ARE
CURRENTLY LIMITED ON HOW THEY
CAN DISCUSS THE USE OF MEDICINAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
PET OWNERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TREAT THEIR ANIMALS OFTEN TURN
TO THE INTERNET OR ADVICE OR
SIMPLY SEEK THE COUNSEL OF THE
RETAIL CANNABIS CLERK.
BEHIND THE COUNTER FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS PUTTING THE
SAFETY OF THEIR PAT IN JEOPARDY.
RATHER THAN GETTING THE ADVICE
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
MOST QUALIFIED INDIVIDUAL THEIR
LOCAL VETERINARIAN PET OWNERS
ARE UNINTENTIONALLY PUTTING
THEIR PETS HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
DANGER.
ANIMAL CAN OF CANNABINOID
RECEPTOR SYSTEMS ARE DIFFERENT
FROM HUMANS SO DOSAGES MUST BE
ADJUSTED FOR THE TYPE OF ANIMAL
ITS WEIGHT AND OBVIOUSLY THE
CONDITION YOU'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS.
LET ME EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
MEASURE SIMPLY PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK FOR THOSE
VETERINARIANS WHO CHOOSE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE US OF
CANNABIS WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SO.
I RECOGNIZE THAT NOT ALL
VETERINARIANS WILL WANT TO DO SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO COMMEND MY MY FRIEND
FROM STOCKTON FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
THE OF THE PHARMACOLOGY OF OF
ANIMALS IS NOT THAT MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN THAN HUMANS -- WE
HAVE DOGS AND CATS THAT -- GET
CANCER AS WE ALL KNOW AND THEY
NEED SOMETIMES THE
PHARMACOLOGICAL BENEFITS -- OF
CANNABIS TO EASE SUFFERING.
AND THIS IS NOT A A MANDATE
THAT'S PLACED UPON VETERINARIANS
THIS IS AN OPTIONAL -- MODALITY
FOR THEM IT'S JUST ANOTHER TOOL
IN THE TOOL CHEST TO EASE THE
SUFFERING.
OF OUR BELOVED PET SAID GIVE
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE TO US.
AND LASTLY IT'S A GROOVY BILL
AND THAT'S WHY YOU SHOULD VOTE
FOR IT.
HI RJ AYE YES VOTE IN SB.
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SEEN ON CENTER
GALGIANI WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
SCOOBY DOO BE DOO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD WHY HI CABALLERO
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible] FIVE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible] FIVE JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK.
I MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible] FIVE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible] FIVE WILK
[inaudible]
HI.
MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
BROWN.
ICE THIRTY THREE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR ROTH HE'S PASSING ON
FILE.
NEXT IS FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE
SENATOR CAFIERO YOU PREPARED TO
TAKE UP THAT MEASURE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO.
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
CENTER WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRO TEM
SENATORS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB SIX NINETY SEVEN WHICH WILL
MODERNIZE THE PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT PRACTICE TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA IS EXPECTED TO FACE A
SHORTFALL OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS WITH ACUTE SHORTAGES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY CENTRAL COAST
AND SOUTHERN BORDER AREAS.
THIS IS DUE TO THE UNEVEN
DISTRIBUTION OF CARE ACROSS THE
STATE AS WELL AS A LACK OF
SUPPLY OF CLINICIANS. TO COMBAT
THE SHORTAGE SB SIX NINETY SEVEN
FOCUSES ON EXPANDING.
POSITION UTILIZATION PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS OR PDAS.
REGULATIONS PA'S ARE SUBJECT TO
WERE WRITTEN DECADES AGO AND
HAVE NOT PROGRESSED WITH
PRACTICING MEDICINE MEDICINE
TODAY.
MAY IMPOSE A BURDEN UPON BOTH
THE PA AND THE POSITION.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS CREATED A
DISINCENTIVE TO HIGHER PH WHICH
LIMITS ACCESS TO MEDICAL
SERVICES AND PARTICULARLY HURT
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
BY MODERNIZING THE OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES OF P. A.'S AND
CREATING A MORE FLEXIBLE WORK
ARRANGEMENTS THIS BILL WILL
INCENTIVIZE POSITIONS TO UTILIZE
PA'S TO THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
WHICH HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND HEALTH CARE ACCESS IN AND
AND AND UNDERSERVED AREAS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS I DON'T.
SEE ANY HEARING NONE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SITE
MEASURE [inaudible]
THERE IS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHIE LETTER [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible] FIVE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible] FIVE
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I LIKE OWSKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
HI.
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
PAN. THIRTY SEVEN ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR STERN YOU'RE
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRICITY.
CENTER STERN.
FAMOUS PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
AS WE NOTE WILDFIRE SEASON IS NO
LONGER SEASON.
IT IS YEAR ROUND THIS THREAD IS
INCREASING.
AND WITH THAT INCREASING THREAT
WE WILL SEE MORE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF AND OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO COME.
WE NEED TO GET AHEAD OF THIS
PROBLEM.
THAT THERE IS NOT RETICENCE
AMONG OUR UTILITIES TO UTILIZE
THIS IMPORTANT FRAMEWORK.
BUT ALSO NOT LEAVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE DARK.
THERE ARE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
FOLKS ON MEDICAL BASELINE FIRE
STATIONS WATER PUMPING STATIONS
TRAFFIC LIGHTS AND OTHER
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND
THE STATE.
THAT WE DESPRATELY NEED TO BE
ONLINE AND POWERED [inaudible]
DURING FIRES.
WE SEEN THE TRAGEDIES ASSOCIATED
WITH FAILURE TO THOSE SYSTEMS.
THIS BILL WOULD PUT ONE MORE
PIECE IN THE PUZZLE.
IN A WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
OF OUR UTILITIES TO ASK THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO
CONSIDER THE USE OF MICROGRAMS
ANOTHER DISTRIBUTED TECHNOLOGY
AT OUR CRITICAL SWITCHES.
WHERE ARE UTILITIES ARE MOST
VULNERABLE AT SUBSTATIONS
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITIES?
BUT THE BILL ALSO TOUCHES ON THE
END USERS AS WELL AND WE'VE
HEARD.
THE CONCERNS FROM THE
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCE
COMMUNITY -- AS WELL AS FROM C.
C. A.'S AND OTHER CRITICAL
STAKEHOLDERS OF THE PAST FEW
MONTHS SINCE THIS BILL MOVED
THEIR ENERGY -- WE ARE COMMITTED
TO ADDRESSING NOT JUST
ADDRESSING THOSE CONCERNS BUT
MEETING HIM EXPANDING UPON THEM.
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
CURRENTLY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET TO ADDRESS THE RISKS OF
BACK UP POWER AND PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS.
WE THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP.
BUT WE DON'T THINK MONEY'S GONNA
SOLVE THIS WE THINK IS GOING TO
TAKE WORK IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. TO ADDRESS
OUR MOST CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT MAY HAVE TO DO WITH UNDER
GROUNDING THAT MAYBE ABOUT
GETTING MORE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES AT PUMPING STATIONS.
AT THIS POINT THE BILL IS IS A
MODEST FRAMEWORK THAT IS
PERMISSIVE IT STILL ALLOWS THE
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO REJECT
AN APPLICATION FOR MIKE REGRADE
OR OTHER UPGRADES TO CRITICAL
CIRCUITS BUT WE NEED TO MOVE
THIS YEAR.
MEMBERS AND WE HOPE THAT THIS
BILL CAN BE A VEHICLE FOR SOME
PROGRESSIVE CHANGE IN THAT
REGARD.
AND MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON DESPITE THE
LOOMING RISK THAT FACE THEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
SCENE NINE MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD ART I HAVE I ADAM
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THE RESIDENT [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HEARD HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I THOUGHT OF I JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MERLE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible] FIVE WILK
[inaudible]
I MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH.
NO MORE LOCK.
OUR EYES TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS MEASURE.
PASS ON FILE.
BUT PASS TEMPORARILY.
NEXT UP IS ITEM.
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR JACKSON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT RELATING
TO FIREARMS INNER JACKSON.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUESI RISE TODAY.
AS TODAY IS THE FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE ISLA VISTA MASSACRE.
WE'RE SIX STUDENTS WERE KILLED
BY A YOUNG MAN WHO WENT TOTALLY
OFF THE RAILS AND HAVE
POSSESSION OF A NUMBER OF
FIREARMS.
HE DROVE THROUGH THE CITY
STREETS OF ISLA VISTA CAUGHT OFF.
OVER SEVENTY FIVE ROUNDS
FORTUNATELY WAS NOT.
ABLE.
TO CALVET CUT ALL SEVENTY FIVE
VICTIMS WHO MIGHT OTHERWISE HAVE
BEEN.
KILLED OR INJURED BUT HE DID
KILLED SIX PEOPLE.
AND WOUNDED A NUMBER OF OTHERS
FIVE YEARS AGO TODAY.
AND IT WAS AFTER THAT
[inaudible]
HORRIFIC EVENT.
THAT ONE OF THE FATHERS OF A
VICTIM WHO WOULD ACTUALLY GONE
INTO A GROCERY STORE TO BUY SOME
FOOD FOR DINNER.
RICHARD MARTINEZ.
WHO MADE A RALLYING CRY THAT
SAID NOT? ONE MORE.
BUT IN THAT FIVE YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN DOZENS MORE [inaudible]
FAMILIES.
WHO HAVE LOST THEIR CHILDREN?
IN SCHOOL RELATED VIOLENCE IN ST
RELATED VIOLENCE VIOLENCE.
WITH THE USE OF FIREARMS BY
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE HAD
THEM IN THEIR POSSESSION.
IT IS IN THE SPIRIT OF NOT ONE
MORE THAT I BRING FORWARD TODAY
SB.
FIFTY FIVE COLLEGE BACK IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE.
CREATED A CENTER. FOR RESEARCH
INTO FIREARM RELATED VIOLENCE.
THIS WAS DONE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AT DAVIS AND IT
WAS A BILL THAT WAS BROUGHT BY
THEN SENATOR LOIS WALK.
AND DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME
WE HAVE SEEN EXTRAORDINARY
RESEARCH DONE TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND.
MORE ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE WHO
COMMITTED WHY WHAT CAN WE DO TO
PREVENT IT WHAT CAN WE DO TO
DISTRACT PEOPLE WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE USE GUNS.
AS A WAY TO EITHER RESOLVE HEIR
DIFFERENCES EXPRESS THEIR ANGER
OR OTHERWISE DO DAMAGE INJURY
AND EVEN DEATH [inaudible] TO
OTHERS.
DRAWING ON THAT RESEARCH PUBLIC
RESEARCH EXCUSE ME PUBLISHED
RESEARCH FINDINGS.
SHOW A STRONG CORRELATION.
BETWEEN CERTAIN ALCOHOL AND DRUG
RELATED CONVICTIONS AND FUTURE
GUN VIOLENCE.
THIS HERE TODAY IS A BILL BASED
UPON DATA BASED UPON SCIENCE
BASED UPON UNCONTROVERTED
RESEARCH [inaudible]
THIS MEASURE.
IDENTIFIES THAT ALCOHOL AND DRUG
RELATED CONVICTIONS.
CREATE A GREATER LIKELIHOOD THAT
THOSE VERY PEOPLE WILL USE FIRE
ARMS IN FUTURE CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
IN FACT OUR UP TO FIVE TIMES.
LIKELIER TO USE A FIREARM.
THEN THOSE WHO HAVE NOT.
EXPERIENCED THOSE CONVICTIONS
THIS MEASURE WILL PROHIBIT
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKELY TO ABUSE
FIREARMS FROM POSSESSING THEM.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN THREE D. WIDE DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE CONVICTIONS
WITHIN A TEN YEAR PERIOD. TO
BRING ABOUT THIS PROHIBITION.
OTHER CRIMES IN THE BILL INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE BUT HE KILLER
MANSLAUGHTER.
WHILE INTOXICATED AND CERTAIN
INTENT TO SELL DRUG CRIMES WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE ONLY TWO
CONVICTIONS WITHIN A THREE YEAR
PERIOD WHY BECAUSE THE RESEARCH
IN THE DATA SHOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
FIVE TIMES LIKELIER. TO ENGAGE
IN FUTURE CRIMINAL CONDUCT AND
WITH A FIREARM THAT IS THE DATA
THAT IS THE SCIENCE.
NO THIS BILL IS SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR TO A BILL THAT SENATOR
WALL BROCK.
SB FIFTY FIVE WHICH PASSED
THROUGH BOTH HOUSES IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WITH THE SUPPORT OF A
NUMBER OF THE MEMBERS HERE ON
THIS FLOOR TODAY.
AGAIN.
WE HAVE THE DATA WE HAVE THE
SCIENCE IT IS CLEAR WE CAN DO
SOMETHING TO PREVENT THIS
VIOLENCE AND WHILE WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO MEET.
THE WHOLE OF NOT ONE MORE WE CAN
CERTAINLY WITH THE HELP AND
PASSAGE OF THIS LEGISLATION
REDUCE.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF FIREARMS
RELATED FATALITIES GOING FORWARD
AND WITHOUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR NELSON.
THIS PAGE LADIES DOWN THE SENATE.
I'M STRUCK BY THE IRONY.
THE GREAT MOVE IN CALIFORNIA NOW
IS TO DECLARE.
CRIMINALIZE DRUGS.
THERE NO PROBLEM.
WE DO NOT WANT TO FILL OUR
PRISONS AND JAILS WAS DRUG.
OFFENDERS.
EVEN THOSE WHO SELL.
WE'RE GONNA GO EASY ON SAYS SAYS
PROP FORTY SEVEN EVEN THE PEOPLE
WERE DUPED.
INTO THAT MEASURE.
THIS IS A HARD PULL WEIGHT. TO
DISARM MORE CALIFORNIANS.
NOW THERE ARE CERTAIN DRUGS THAT
ARE PARTICULARLY DANGEROUS.
I DON'T HEAR THAT TALKED ABOUT
MUCH AROUND HERE METHAMPHETAMINE.
THAT'S THE MEAN DRUG.
THE WOMAN WHO TAKES
METHAMPHETAMINE IS A ONE WOULD
BE SURE CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR THE FATHER'S
METHAMPHETAMINE.
DOES THAT ABSOLUTELY MEAN THEN
WE ARE GOING TO GO AFTER.
A WEAPON.
WELL THAT MAKES ALL KINDS OF
SENSE ENHANCE A BIT OF LOGIC IN
THIS [inaudible]
EXCEPT THAT. FOUR EIGHTY OF THIS
DRUG OFFENDERS OF WHICH THERE
ARE FEWER NOW ANYWAY. TO ASSUME
THAT THEY THEN SHOULD HAVE A TEN
YEAR.
MORATORIUM ON HAVING A FIREARM
[inaudible]
NOW.
THEY'VE DONE NOTHING RIGHT NOW
BUT THE DRUGS.
HOWEVER IN LEGISLATION.
THAT HAS PASSED.
WE ARE FORGIVING.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ACTUALLY USED A
GUN.
FROM HAVING AN ENHANCED SENTENCE.
NOW IF YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING.
REPEAL THAT BILL AT WELL ARE YOU
THINK IT'S NOT ALWAYS THROUGH
YET BUT THAT'S WHERE WE SHOULD
BE GOING NOT.
MAKING IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE.
IF YOU USE A GUN THEN.
YES YOU PAY A GREATER PENALTY.
ALL NO NO YOU DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT.
NO NO WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANYMORE ENHANCEMENTS.
ENHANCEMENTS FOR THE USE OF A
FIREARM USE A GUN G TO PRISON
WAS VOTED ON TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I GUESS THEY WERE SMART ENOUGH
TO FIGURE OUT.
THERE'S A CONSEQUENCE FOR USING
A GUN.
LET'S ADDRESS THE INDIVIDUAL.
AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL'S BEHAVIOR OR MAKE A
PRESUMPTION [inaudible]
THE DRUGS.
HAVE A GUN [inaudible]
THE DANGERS.
I KIND OF AGREE WITH THAT BUT I
DON'T AGREE WITH THE PERVERSE
LOGIC.
THIS IS SIMPLY ANOTHER WAY. TO
DISARM.
CALIFORNIANS I REGION OVER.
THE KEYS SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THE
AND COLLEAGUES YOU DON'T.
WE AGREE ON PROBABLY 90% OF THE
ISSUES THAT HIT THE FLOOR WE USE
OUR UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO A LOT
TEN THERE ARE.
A FEW ISSUES.
A FEW ISSUES THAT.
THAT DIVIDE US [inaudible]
AND WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL I
THINK THAT WE WE DON'T BE
HYPOCRITICAL -- AS WE DISCUSS
THESE VERY SENSITIVE ISSUES.
OF COURSE I I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB.
FIFTY FIVE AND I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT.
I THINK I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF ALL
REPUBLICANS IN THIS COUNTRY
INCLUDING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE DEPLORE.
THE VIOLENCE THAT WE SEE BEING
USE WITH GUNS ESPECIALLY IN OUR
SCHOOLS [inaudible]
AND IT'S A SYMPTOM OF OUR LACK
OF PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
TO OUR YOUNGSTERS IT FIND
THEMSELVES MORNING NEED A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND I WOULD.
SAY THAT A BIG FACTOR IN THAT
REQUIREMENT IS BECAUSE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA [inaudible]
SO.
THIS BILL WILL PLACE A TEN YEAR.
FIRE ARM PROHIBITION ON
INDIVIDUALS AND NON VIOLENT DRUG.
OR SUBSTANCE USE BEHAVIOR.
USING A MISDEMEANOR.
I FIND IT VERY IRONIC.
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THE CAUSE OF
DEATH IN PEOPLE THAT USE OPIATES.
IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S UP AND DOWN MAKE WE'VE LOST
MORE PEOPLE TO OVERDOSES OF
NARCOTICS THEN WE LOST IN THE
VIETNAM WAR.
AND A BIG CULPRIT.
IN THESE DEATHS [inaudible]
IS.
THE IMPORTATION THE ILLICIT
IMPORTATION OF FAT KNOWN TO THIS
COUNTRY.
AND I PARK WITH.
MANY OF YOU INCLUDING OUR OUR
BUDGET CHAIR ABOUT MY CONCERNS
ABOUT.
NOT ALLOWING BILLS TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THAT DON'T GO AFTER THE USER
[inaudible]
AS AS AGGRESSIVELY AS I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE BUT TO GO AFTER THE
DISTRIBUTORS OF THESE POISONS.
BETTER MARKETING THESE POISONS
AS THOUGH THEY ARE.
ANOTHER NARCOTIC AS AN EXAMPLE
FENTANYL. FIFTY TIMES STRONGER
THAN HEROIN.
BUT BE MARKETED AS HEROIN.
SO IN SOME.
UNBEKNOWNST ABUSER IS INJECTING
HEROIN THEY THINK THEY'RE
INJECTING HEROIN.
THEY ARE DYING OF RESPIRATORY
DEPRESSION WHILE THE NEEDLE IS
IN THEIR ARMEN STILL PUMPING THE
PLUNGER OF THAT POISON INTO
THEIR VEINS.
YEAH WHEN MY COLLEAGUES. FOR
MORE AS COUNTY BRINGS BILLS FOR
TO STOP THIS AND TO REALLY PUT
SOME TEETH INTO THE LAWS TO STOP
THE THE NEEDLESS LOSS OF LIFE OF
THOUSANDS.
NOT A FEW BUT THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
THIS LEGISLATOR WON'T EVEN LET
THOSE BILLS.
AT A COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YOU DON'T.
I KNOW MANY OF YOU DON'T LIKE
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE SECOND
AMENDMENT THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
DIDN'T PUT A BILL FORWARD.
AND SAY YOU WANT ABOLISHED
SECOND AMENDMENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE GOING TO
DISREGARD FEDERAL LAW LIKE WE WE
DO OFTEN HERE.
THANK HEAVENS FOR THE CORE LAW.
BECAUSE MANY TIMES WHEN WE HAVE.
NOT GREAT BILLS IKE THIS THAT.
CHALLENGE OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
THE COURTS HAVE TO INTERVENE AND
FIVE OPINED THAT THIS WILL
PROBABLY GET OFF THE FLORIDA
POLY MAKE IT TO THE ASSEMBLY A
PROBLEM MAKE THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
AND THAT WE GOT A WASTE TAXPAYER
MONEY ON DEFENDING THE PORTAL
LAW AND ULTIMATELY THE GUN
RIGHTS GROUPS ARE GOING TO SHOW
THAT -- IT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
[inaudible]
SO.
IF YOU HAVE A MINOR MISDEMEANOR.
INVOLVING SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
HE WON'T BE ABLE TO GET A
FIREARM FOR TEN YEARS BUT THIS
IS CRAZY.
BUT IF YOU'RE TWENTY FOUR YEARS
OLD AND YOU RAPE A TEENAGER
YOU'LL BE OUT OF PRISON WITH A
CLEAN RECORD WHEN YOU'RE TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE.
I'M SORRY BUT THIS JUST DOESN'T
SEEM TO MAKE SENSE TO ME IF
YOU'RE REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT.
SO CALLED MASS INCARCERATION AND
THE LESS DESIRE TO EMPTY OUR
PRISONS AND MAKING OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES LESS SAFE WHICH IS
ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
ARE WE NOT GOING TO BE TO
PASSING BILLS A DEPRIVE
INDIVIDUALS OF THE RIGHT SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A HIGHER
STATISTICAL PROBABILITY.
THAT THEY MAY ENGAGE IN VIOLENT
GUN RELATED CRIMES.
YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD OFTEN ON THE
FLOOR THE SENATE THAT.
YOUNG PEOPLE'S BRAINS DON'T
MATURE UNTIL THEIR UNTIL TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OLD.
I THINK MANY OF YOU.
I'VE EVEN MENTIONED ON THE FLOOR
THE SENATE WELL.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE A MATURE
BRAIN OF WHY ARE WE TRYING TO
LET SIXTEEN YEAR OLDS VOTE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT CONCEPT
[inaudible]
HOUSES FAIR.
HOW DOES THIS BILL EVEN MAKES
SENSE AND SHORT?
PASSING LAWS TO TAKE AWAY THE
RIGHTS OR IMPOSE PUNISHMENTS
BASED ON INDIVIDUALS HIGHER
STATISTICAL PROBABILITY.
IS NOT A PATH.
BUT LAWMAKERS SHOULD BE MAKING
IN THE STATE.
THIS IS A BAD BILL.
THIS IS AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
BILL IF IT BECOMES LAW AND FOR
THOSE REASONS.
STAND UP FOR SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS AND SAY NOTE SB.
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU SENATOR
CAFIERO.
I LOVE IT THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
YOU TAKE QUESTIONS ABOUT
OBJECTION OF COURSE.
THE READING A MATCH -- SENATOR
I'M I'M REALLY IMPRESSED WITH
THE RESEARCH THAT YOU CITED --
IT IS AT NEW INFORMATION FOR ME
AND AND AND ANY TIME WE CAN USE
GOOD SCIENCE TO ADVANCE GOOD
POLICIES ON THEIR ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WAS RAISED BY PAR
ACT WAS THE WHOLE ISSUE OF THE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BACKLOG.
OF UPDATE IN THEIR LISTS OF WHO
CAN AND CANNOT OWN WEAPONS NO
IT'S WONDER IF YOU COULD ADDRESS
THAT THAT BE HAPPY -- TO THERE
WAS A CONCERN THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BURDEN THE COURTS AND OTHERS
WITH HAVING TO GO BACK AND
IDENTIFY HOW MANY DO YOU AYE
SOMEONE'S HAD.
SO THE BILL ACTUALLY -- AS IT'S
PRESENTLY CONSTITUTED IDENTIFIES
THAT IT IS ONLY A FUTURE DO YOU
WHY SOMEONE OTHER WORDS IF YOU
HAVE TO DRUNK DRIVING
CONVICTIONS IN THESE OUR
CONVICTIONS -- WITHIN THE PAST
TEN YEARS AND YOU GET A THIRD
ARREST AND CONVICTION SUBSEQUENT
TO THAT SO IF THIS BILL BECOMES
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST.
IF YOU GET A DRUNK DRIVING
ARREST ON JANUARY SECOND AND A
CONVICTION IN.
MAY AND THE COURT THEN WE'LL
LOOK BACK EACH RAP SHEET BECAUSE
THAT TAKES ABOUT TEN SECONDS.
AND IF THEY SEE THAT YOU'VE HAD
TWO PRIOR DO YOU Y. CONVICTIONS
AND NOW A THIRD CONVICTION.
THAT INFORMATION WILL THEN GO
IMMEDIATELY TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO BE PLACED ON
THE PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST IT
SHOULD TAKE A TOTAL OF MAYBE
FIVE MINUTES.
AND HOPEFULLY OF COURSE THERE IS
MORE MONEY BEING -- GIVEN A TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE PROHIBITED PERSONS
AS THE GREAT IRONY THERE BY THE
WAY.
IS THAT BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE
STARTED BUYING GUNS WE GOT.
WE GOT BEHIND IN PUTTING PEOPLE
ON THAT LIST WE ARE PUTTING MORE
MONEY INTO CORRECTING THAT A
PROBLEM AND AGAIN IF WE CAN SAVE
THE LIVES.
OF YOUNG PEOPLE OR ANY INNOCENT
PERSON.
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE BE THE
VICTIM OF SOMEONE WHO WAS KNOWN
TO BE FIVE TIMES LIKELIER TO USE
A FIREARM IN THE FUTURE?
THEN IT IS WORTH THAT COST SO --
I APPRECIATE IN YOUR OF
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT THE
SCIENCE IS THERE SOMETIMES IN
THIS WORLD WE REALLY NEED TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE IN FACT WE
SHOULD BE FOLLOWING SCIENCE
THAT'S WHY THIS -- ENTITY WAS
CREATED WHY THIS RESEARCH
INSTITUTE WAS CREATED THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS -- FOCUSED ON THE
SPECIFIC SIGNS UP RATHER THAN
PERHAPS IF WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
OF METHAMPHETAMINES IN THE
FUTURE I'D BE DELIGHTED TO DO
THAT IF THE RESEARCH SHOWS A
SIMILAR PROPENSITY.
THEN WE WOULD INCLUDE IT RIGHT
NOW THE RESEARCH DEALS WITH THE
ISSUES THAT ARE THE SUBJECT
MATTER THIS BILL.
AND IT IS BECAUSE OF THAT I
BROUGHT IT FORWARD.
IT IS CLEARLY CONSTITUTIONAL I
WILL ADDRESS SAID IN MY CLOTHES
BUT THAT IS THE THINKING BEHIND.
THE USE OF THAT TIME FRAME.
THE SCIENTIST ABLUTIONS CONFIRM
SAID AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS AND PUT THOSE PEOPLE
ON THE PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M ON MY OWN
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ANSWERING THAT QUESTION NIGHT
YOU KNOW I'M I'M ALWAYS VERY
CAREFUL -- I A COME FROM A RURAL
DISTRICT WHERE HUNTING IS IS
STILL VERY POPULAR AND FROM A
FAMILY OF HUNTERS AS WELL AND
SOME ALWAYS -- VERY AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
REALLY ENJOY THEIR GUNS THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HUNT THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO CARRY THEIR
GUNS WITH THEM -- AND AND THEY
SAID THEY WANT TO SAFELY STORE
THEM UP THIS WAY THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY DIFFERENT
AND I I WANTED -- TO RISE AND
SPEAK TO IT BECAUSE THAT YOU
KNOW THE AND THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT THE GUN VIOLENCE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES IS THE
HIGHEST IN ANY OTHER NATION IN
IN YOUR AND IN ANY OTHER
INDUSTRIALIZED NATION.
AND AND IF WE CAN HAVE
PRODUCTIVE FEATURES IT'LL TELL
US WHO'S MORE LIKELY. TO BE ABLE
TO OR WHO IS MORE LIKELY TO BE A
DANGER -- IN IN IN THEIR
AVAILABILITY OF GUNS I I WANT TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY BASED
ON THE RESEARCH AND AND REALLY
IF IF WE HAVE AN ISSUE WITH --
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THEIR BACKLOG WE OUGHT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO BRING IT UP TO DATE
NETTLE RESOLVE THAT THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE SO I THINK YOU.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR FOR THIS
BILL AND I THINK YOU -- FOR FOR
BEING THE CHAMPION OF FAMILIES
THAT ARE ARE ARE REALLY LOOKING
FOR SOLUTIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE YOU GUYS
TO CONSIDER THE FACT THAT -- A
LOT OF THE GUN VIOLENCE THAT IS
CREATED OR A PERPETRATED ANOTHER
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IS BECAUSE OF ILLEGAL POSSESSION
OF FIREARMS.
WE GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE THERE IS
A BILL THAT WENT TROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN I WAS HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE.
AND IT REQUIRED ALL FIREARMS TO
BE REGISTERED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BY SERIAL
NUMBER.
NOW LAW ABIDING CITIZENS GOT IN
THERE SAVE ZERO DOWN THE SERIAL
NUMBERS AND THEY TOOK THE MODEL
NUMBER AND THEY SUBMITTED IT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO WE
CAN BE RECORDED.
BUT THE ILLEGAL POSSESSORS OF
FIREARMS I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO ILLEGALLY POSSESS
FIREARMS FOR PURPOSES THAT ARE
EITHER GANG RELATED.
DRUG DEALING ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE THAT ILLEGALLY POSSESS
FIREARMS.
THEY DON'T THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
FOLLOW THAT LAW THEY'RE NOT
GOING.
TO TAKE THEIR ILLEGAL POSSESSED
FIRE ARM GET THE SERIAL NUMBER
TURN IT INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND COMPLY WITHOUT LAW.
DISLIKE THIS LAW THIS LAW WILL
IF IT PASSES WILL GET PEOPLE WHO
ARE LEGALLY POSSESS HAVE LEGALLY
POSSESSION OF FIREARMS.
IF THEY GET A D. WIRE THREE D.
WISE THEN THEY WILL YOU LOSE
THEIR LEGAL RIGHT TO POSSESS
THESE GUNS.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING TO PREVENT PEOPLE LIKE
GUSTAVO ERIOGONUM.
ESTADO AIR IAGO WAS DRIVING
DRUNK IN NEWMAN CALIFORNIA.
AND GUSTAVO AIR IAGO WAS -- ON
THE FREEWAY DRIVING ERRATICALLY
HE GOT PULLED OVER BY A NEWMAN
POLICE OFFICER HE WAS BREAKING
THE LAW FOR DRIVING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A VALID
DRIVER'S LICENSE HE WAS BREAKING
THE LAW BECAUSE HE HAD HE WAS IN
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM WHICH
WAS HE IS NOT.
AUTHORIZED TO HAVE ANY BROKE THE
LAW WHEN HE OPENED FIRE ON A
THIRTY PLUS YEAR OLD POLICE
OFFICER NAMED RAY NIELSEN.
THIS BILL AND THE BILLS THAT GO
THROUGH THIS BUILDING ARE NOT
GOING TO STOP PEOPLE LIKE
GUSTAVO.
JAGA FROM COMMITTING CRIMES WITH
FIREARMS IT'S NOT IF WE'RE GOING
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED WITHOUT LIMITING
THE RIGHTS OF I WANT TO SAY LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS CAN'T GET A D.
Y..
I GET IT I THINK THE NUMBER WILL
BE THE MINIMUS WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE NUMBER ONE IF YOU ARE IN
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM AND YOU
HAVE A C. C. W. YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE ALCOHOL.
YOU CAN'T YOU HAVE TO KERRY
LIABILITY INSURANCE THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF TRAINING THAT YOU
HAVE TO GO.
TO BUT TO BE IN POSSESSION OF A
CCW THIS BILL JUST ARREST
FIREARMS IN YOUR HOME FIREARMS
THAT HAVE TO BE LOCKED UP AT
NIGHT THE REASON WHY YOU HAVE
FIREARMS IN YOUR HOME IS TO
PROTECT YOU FROM A PERPETRATOR
BECAUSE IT TAKES TEN MINUTES FOR
POLICE TO GET.
THERE SO WE HAVE A FIRE IN YOUR
HOME FOR EXCUSE ME MR BURGLAR
LET ME READ TO MY SAFE IN OPEN
IT BECAUSE HAS TO BE LEGALLY
LOCKED UP AT NIGHT.
AND YOU GO THIRTY TO THE RIGHT
FORTY SIX TO THE LEFT AND
CONTINUE TURN THE DIAL AND
HOPEFULLY YOU DON'T GET SHOT BY
THE TIME.
THAT YOU OPEN YOUR SAFETY GEAR
FIREARM OUT TO PROTECT YOU SOME
OF THE LAWS THAT GO THROUGH THIS
BUILDING -- ALMOST TO THE POINT
ABSURD AND ALL THAT DOES
RESTRICT THE RIGHTS OF LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS.
I ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE FACT
THAT ANY BILL THAT GOES THIS
BUILDING IS NOT GOING TO STOP.
THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIKE
GUSTAVO AIRY AGA FROM POSSESSING
A FIREARM BECAUSE HAD HE
FOLLOWED THE LAWS OF THE STATE
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
HE WOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN ON OUR
ROADS HE WOULD NEVER BEEN
DRIVING WITHOUT A DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND HE WOULD NEVER BEEN
IN POSSESSION OF AN ILLEGAL
FIREARM THAT KILLED ONE OF OUR
OWN.
SO I ASK YOU FOR NOVEMBER.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
JACKSON SELECT CLOTHES THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU KNOW MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS RIGHT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO STOP EVERYONE
WHO WANTS TO USE A FIREARM BUT
WE ARE GOING TO STOP THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MORE LIKELY TO USE THOSE
FIREARMS.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL TRIES TO DO ARGUABLY THE
ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM USING FIREARMS IS TO
GET RID OF FIREARMS AND THERE'S
A SECOND MEMBER WE KEEP HEARING.
ABOUT WHICH OF COURSE STARTS
WITH THE A WELL REGULATED
MILITIA BUT IRRESPECTIVE OF THAT
FACT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS THE SCIENCE.
THE SCIENCE THAT SHOWS THAT
THESE PEOPLE AND BY THE WAY
THESE ARE NOT NECESSARILY LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO'VE HAD THREE DRUNK
DRIVING CONVICTIONS OR ABUSES.
OF ALCOHOL LEADING TO CONVICTION
WHICH THE SCIENCE SHOWS.
CREATES A GREATER PROPENSITY BY
FIVE TIMES.
ON THE USE OF FIREARMS IN THE
COMMISSION OF A FAN AN OFFENSE
GOING FORWARD.
ADD TO MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
TEMECULA WHO I KNOW IS A FORMER.
A FORMER SUIT THE PHARMACIST BUT
NOT AN ATTORNEY -- THIS FLOOR IS
CLEARLY CONSTITUTIONAL IN FACT
THERE ARE MANY OTHER.
LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT EXIST
TODAY WHICH CREATE FIREARMS
PROHIBITIONS LIKE CONVICTION FOR
A FELONY.
ADDICTION TO A NARCOTIC DRUG
ILLEGAL POSSESSION OF A FIREARM
ASSAULT WITH A FIREARM IF YOU
ARE THE VICTIM OR IF YOU ARE
SUBJECT TO A PROTECTIVE ORDER --
IF YOU ARE FOUND NOT GUILTY BY
REASON OF INSANITY SO THIS
NOTION THAT IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IS JUST.
NOT ACCURATE.
BUT WHAT IS ACCURATE IS THE
RESEARCH AND THE DATA AND THE
FACT THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING TO PREVENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ENHANCING SENTENCES AFTER
PEOPLE KILL PEOPLE DOESN'T HELP
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DEAD.
BUT IF WE CAN PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING THEN WE WILL HAVE DONE
SOMETHING MEANINGFUL FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THIS STATE AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible] FIVE JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
RUBIO.
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I'VE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL [inaudible]
NO.
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I ROTH.
ICE TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PROCESS.
WE'RE RETURNING TO PRIVILEGES
UNDER FLOOR MEMBERS FROM
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE'RE BEING VISITED AND THE
GALLERY TODAY SO PLEASE GIVE A
WARM WOW ROUND OF APPLAUSE I
WOULD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
ART ITEM.
FORTY THREE SENATOR WINNER ARE
YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO TRANSPORTATION.
CENTER WIENER I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES SB -- ONE TWENTY
SEVEN WILL FINALLY INSURER --
AND REQUIRE CALTRANS TO CONSIDER
FIFTH ENTERS SECTION SAID
CROSSWALKS AND PROTECTED BIKE
LANES ON PARTS OF OUR STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM -- THAT ARE USED
AS LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS --
THIS BILL ISN'T ABOUT WHAT WE
WOULD CONSIDER CLASSICS STATE
HIGHWAYS IT'S ABOUT THE QUOTE ON
QUOTE STATE HIGHWAYS THAT ARE
OWNED BY CALTRANS ARE
TECHNICALLY PART OF THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
BUT THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THEM
OR ACTUALLY SURFACE STREETS THAT
RUN THROUGH CITIES. FOR EXAMPLE
PARTS OF SANTA MONICA BOULEVARD
IN LOS ANGELES -- SAN PABLO
AVENUE IN THE EAST BAY.
AND BAD NASA NINETEENTH AVENUES
IN SAN FRANCISCO THESE ARE
TECHNICALLY STATE HIGHWAYS --
BUT THEY ARE CITY STREETS THAT
PEOPLE ARE USING AND ALL SORTS
OF WAYS OTHER THAN DRIVING A CAR
ENDS FOR CYCLISTS. FOR PEOPLE
WHO WERE WAITING FOR TRANSIT.
IN ADDITION AND MANY RURAL
COMMUNITIES A STATE HIGHWAY
OFTEN FUNCTIONS AS THE
COMMUNITIES ONLY MAIN STREET.
UNFORTUNATELY CALTRANS HAS A
HISTORY WHEN THEY ARE DOING WORK
ON THE STREETS. TO SIMPLY --
TREAT THEM AS IF THEY WERE
EFFECTIVELY YOUR CLASSIC STATE
HIGHWAY AND NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE SAFETY NEEDS OF
PEDESTRIANS CYCLISTS AND TRANSIT
RIDERS.
AS A RESULT FOR TOO MANY PEOPLE
IT IS UNSAFE TO CROSS THE STREET
TO WALK.
ALONG THE STREETS OR TO RIDE
BIKES OR WAIT FOR THE BUS ON THE
STREETS.
HI SO SB ONE TWENTY SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE -- THEY CALTRANS
HIGHWAYS RUNNING THROUGH
URBANIZED AREAS BE SAFE FOR ALL
ROAD USERS.
NOT JUST VEHICLES AND DESIGNED
WITH THE NEEDS OF PEDESTRIANS
CYCLISTS AND TRANSIT RIDERS IN
MIND.
WHILE ALLOWING FLEXIBILITY IN
SITUATIONS WHERE IT'S NOT
FEASIBLE TO MAKE THESE CHANGES.
THE BILL ALSO CREATE A BRANCH OF
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION WITHIN
CALTRANS TO OVERSEE AND
COORDINATE EFFORTS ON ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND COMPLETE
STREETS.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THESE
PROJECTS MOVE FORWARD -- DIED
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY BEING
IMPLEMENTED I WANT TO THANK THE
TERRIBLE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF PAID
ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NONE MEANT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THERE ARE OTHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN.
I PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I LIKE OWSKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible] FIVE WILK
[inaudible]
NO -- SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS.
ALL EYES TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE
THE MEASURE PROCESS.
EXCEPT MEMBERS IS ITEM FORTY
FOUR SENATOR DODD ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE THIS ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
SENATE BILL TWO OH FOUR BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
WATER.
THIRD FLOOR JURORS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB TOOL FOR REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES D.
W. R.. TO INFORM LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES OF PENDING STATE
WATER PROJECT CONTRACTS AND
AMENDMENTS.
WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA WATER
FIXES A PROPOSAL TO BUILD A
CONVEYANCE UNDER THE DELTA TO
ROUTE TO DIRECTLY SHIP WATER.
THE STATE WATER PROJECT POTS THE
CONVENIENCE OF CONSTRUCTED WOULD
BE PART OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT.
DEVELOPMENT OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE PROJECT IS
CARRIED OUT -- BY D. W. R.
PURSUANT TO CONTRACTS BETWEEN
THE D. W. R. ITS STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS. TO THE BEST OF MY
KNOWLEDGE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE KNOWS VERY LITTLE
ABOUT THESE CONTRACTS.
AND HOW THEY RELATE TO THE WATER
FIX PROJECT.
FUNDING FOR WATER FIX IS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
THEREFORE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
THAT IS TYPICALLY PERFORMED BY
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE SIMPLY
DOESN'T OCCUR.
THE APPLICATION IMPACTS OF THE
WATER FIX ARE ENORMOUS SB TO
AFFORD ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
INSURING THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
MADE AWARE OF ANY CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS.
A D. W. R. IN WATER CONTRACTORS
IN -- INTO BEFORE THEY HAPPEN I
APPRECIATE GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
WATER FIX PROJECT RESET AND
DOUBTS COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
NOW THE D. W. R. WILL BEGIN A
NEW ASSESSMENT OF THE PROJECT IT
IS ESSENTIAL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE JUST BE INFORMED A
PROJECT PLANTS AND CHANGES. TO
THAT END THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
IT WILL BE WITH ANNUALLY REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE WATER FIX
DESIGN CONSTRUCTION AND
FINANCING PROGRESS.
LET ME CALL TO YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE FACT THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS MADE BY THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALL OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
IN TWO NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD HI HI CABALLERO
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible] FIVE LEYVA
[inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORALE [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
HI I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
FIVE WIENER.
I WILK.
HI.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT
TO MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
I JUST.
THIRTY SIX KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
SOONER WORKER YOU PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETEEN BY
SENATOR WELK AN ACT RELATING TO
FOSTER YOUTH.
CENTER WILK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT DOING
A GREAT JOB TODAY.
MEMBERS LIKE TO PRESENT TO YOU
SB.
TWO NINETEEN CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A
TRAILBLAZER IN ALIGNING POLICY
WITH THE NEEDS OF FOSTER YOUTH
SPECIFICALLY IN THE AREA OF
RECOGNIZING THE NEED AND OVERALL
MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH.
OVER A DECADE AGO THE
LEGISLATURE IN ENACTED THE
FOSTER CARE BILL OF RIGHTS WHICH
ESTABLISHED A RITE OF FOSTER
YOUTH TO PARTICIPATE IN
EXTRACURRICULAR IN IN RICHMOND
ACTIVITIES.
WHILE THE STATE HAS CLEARLY
RECOGNIZED IMPORTANCE OF THESE
ACTIVITIES IT HAS YET TO FULLY
EQUIPPED FOSTER AGENCIES IN
FOSTER PARENTS WITH THE
RESOURCES TO MEET.
THOSE NEEDS.
SB TWO NINETEEN SIX TO RECTIFY
THE LACK OF FUNDING FOR THIS
EXTRA CURRICULAR. FOR
EXTRACURRICULAR AND ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES THE BILL ESTABLISHES
THE CALIFORNIA FOSTER YOUTH IT
IN HAND IN RICHMOND GRANT.
PILOT PROGRAM IN FOUR COUNTIES
WHICH WILL PROVIDE UP TO GRANTS
UP TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
PER YEAR FOR A FOSTER YOUTH SB
TWO NINETEEN WOULD ALLOW FOR
FOSTER YOU TO ENGAGE IN
ACTIVITIES WHERE THE SCHOOL OR
FOSTER PARENT.
COULD NOT FULLY PAY FOR
EQUIPMENT INTEREST FEES FOR THE
ENTIRE COST OF ACTIVITY THIS
BILL WILL ALLEVIATE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN THAT CAN HOLD
FOSS YOUTH BACK FROM
PARTICIPATING.
IN IT TAKES AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS MAKING FOSTER USE RIGHT
TO PARTICIPATE A REALITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR NY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
KERN CHAIN NINE THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION OF USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SHE NINE MEASURE PASSES. THIRTY
FIVE SEVEN ZERO NEXT UP ITEM.
FORTY SIX BY SENATOR WIENER
YOU'RE PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRICITY CENTER WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SB TWO ADA
WILL DIRECT UTILITIES TO
STREAMLINE THE INTERCONNECTION
PROCESS. FOR DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES SUCH AS ROOFTOP SOLAR
AN ON SITE ENERGY STORAGE --
DISTRIBUTOR RESOURCES BENEFIT
ALL CUSTOMERS NOT JUST THEIR
OWNERS BY CLEANING THE AIR
ENSURING THE JOB STATE LOCAL AND
PROVIDING ELECTRICITY DURING
EMERGENCIES AS WELL AS REDUCING
THE NEED FOR COSTLY GREAT
REPAIRS.
IN FACT THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR RECENTLY ESTIMATED THAT
CALIFORNIA REPAIRS SAVED OVER
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS ON
CANCEL TRANSMISSION UPGRADES
LARGELY BECAUSE OF DISTRIBUTED
RESOURCES PAID FOR WITH PRIVATE
DOLLARS.
WERE ALREADY PROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES UNFORTUNATELY AND
ESPECIALLY THE COMMERCIAL LEVEL
A UTILITY CAN DELAY CONNECTION
OF A DISTRIBUTED RESOURCE TO THE
GRID FOR MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS.
COST TO THE CUSTOMERS
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY AND
WASTING TIME.
BUT WITH THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE LAST COMMITTEE MOST
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL -- HAS
WITHDRAWN AND WE EXPECT THE
OTHER OPPONENTS TO BECOME
NEUTRAL SHORTLY -- PASSING THIS
MEASURE WILL HELP KEEP THESE
PROMISING NEW TECHNOLOGIES ON
TRACK.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OF IT ON THE SIDE ON INCHING
UNANSWERED.
YES I'M SORRY CENTER CAVIAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
PRESIDENT I AM I AM RISING IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT AND I'M GONNA BE
CONTRITE.
I DIDN'T -- PARTICULARLY SUPPORT
THE DECISION TO REQUIRE SOLAR ON
ALL SINGLE FAMILY HOMES MOSTLY
BECAUSE OF THE PROJECTION WAS
THAT IT WAS GONNA COST BETWEEN
EIGHT TO TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ON THE OF THE COST OF A NEW HOME
AND SO FOR MORE PEOPLE MOST OF
THE PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITIES
HOMEOWNERSHIP PRICES AND WAGES
ARE SUCH THEY'RE SUCH A GREAT
DISPARITY.
THAT -- THE NEW COST OF OF HOMES
WELL SIGNIFICANTLY BE A DRY
DRIVEN UP BECAUSE OF THIS AND
YOU KNOW.
I THINK THAT THIS PARTICULAR
BIGGER BELLAS IS REALLY SMART
BECAUSE IT IGNORE ALL AGES --
THAT -- THE TOOTHPASTE IS OUT OF
THE TUBE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
GENERATION AND DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY STORAGE ARE HAPPENING AND
WE NEED TO BE WIDE OPEN ABOUT IT
AND INTEGRATE THESE RESOURCES
INTO THE GRID IN THE SMARTEST
WAY POSSIBLE.
IN FACT I THINK THE BILL SHOULD
GO EVEN FURTHER AND IT SHOULD
INCLUDE IN THE OUR PS ALL
ROOFTOP SOLAR AN IN HOME IT.
HOME ENERGY STORAGE THE COMES
BACK ONTO THE GRID.
OR THAT OFFSETS THE LOCAL PO
USER I. O. U.'S RENEWABLE ENERGY
PROCUREMENT REQUIREMENTS IF
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS WANT TO PAY
THE COSTS FOR HARDWARE AND
SOFTWARE TO LAUNCH.
A DISTRIBUTED ENERGY NETWORK
THEN LET'S AT LEAST LEVERAGE
THAT CONSUMER INVESTMENT BY
TREATING SOLAR AND SOLAR WEATHER
FROM FARMLAND CONVERTED TO A
MORASS OF SOLAR PANELS OF OR
FROM MY NEIGHBOR.
NEIGHBORS ROUGH BOTH LEAD TO THE
THE MARKET OUT OF THE CAR BUT
EVEN FASTER AND I REALLY THINK
WE HAVE TO HAVE ERNEST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS IN THE
FUTURE AS WE LOOK AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF BLACKOUTS AND
BROWN OUTS AND SO -- I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SAN FRANCISCO FOR
THIS BILL AND I REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
GREAT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF
THE RATE.
HEARING NONE CENTER WINNER WHICH
OUGHT TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ALL RIGHT HI
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I RATHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible] FIVE GROWTH
[inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible] FIVE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible] FIVE JACKSON
[inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MARROW [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible] FIVE
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I START STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible] FIVE NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible] FIVE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP SENATOR WILL ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN PASS ON FILE SOONER
MONSIGNOR.
ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT PASS ON FILE.
A SOONER CHIANG.
ITEM FORTY NINE YOU'RE PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR CHIANG AN ACT RELATING
TO STATE GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
CHRISTINE COLLEAGUES ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPROVE THE WAY THE STATE
OPERATES IN INCREDIBLE WAYS.
IT CAN ALSO COME WITH SERIES
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHICH IS
WHY WE NEED TO BE IN FRONT OF
THE ISSUE IS LAWMAKERS.
SB THREE FORTY EIGHT IS INSPIRED
BY RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION EARLIER
THIS YEAR.
THROUGH DILIGENT WORK WITH THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IT HAS
BEEN NARROWED TO TWO PILOT
DEPARTMENTS SB THREE FORTY WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC PLAN. TO IMPROVE STATE
SERVICES WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE THIS WILL ENSURE
KEY STATE DEPARTMENTS RECOGNIZE
A I AS AS A POTENTIAL SOLUTION
TO IMPROVING AUGMENT INTERNAL
AND EXTERNAL OPERATIONS.
AS WELL AS CALL ATTENTION TO
POTENTIAL CHALLENGES RAISED BY A
AYE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
ENCOURAGES CERTAIN HE STATE
OFFICES TO DESIGNATED CHIEF A I
OFFICER TO WORK TOGETHER ON
DEVELOPING A STRATEGY IN WITH
THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM HEARING CHAIN ON THIS IS
ALL DOUBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE SIDE OF SENIOR HEARING ON
MEASURE PASSES. THIRTY EIGHT
ZERO THIRTY SEVEN ZERO I'M SORRY.
THIRTY SEVEN CENTER WORK YOU
PREPARED.
ABOUT SOME FILES OKAY THANK YOU.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
SENATOR ON BURKE ARE YOU
PREPARED.
I AM AS PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY BY
SENATOR UMBERG AN ACT RELATING
TO SCHOOL SAFETY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS -- SB THREE NINE THE
SIMPLY ENSURES THAT ALL SCHOOL
SECURITY GUARDS INCLUDING PART
TIME SECURITY GUARDS RECEIVE
BASIC SCHOOL SAFETY TRAINING.
IN THE EVENT OF ANY EMERGENCY --
THAT EVERYONE INCLUDING PART
TIME SECURITY OFFICERS ARE WELL
TRAINED TO PROVIDE FOR STUDENTS
SAFETY AND SECURITY URGENT AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OF IT ON THE SIDE OF HEARING
SEEN ON THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION ABUSING YOU NATURAL
CALL.
SEEING HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GOING BACK TO ITEM FIFTY
FOR CENTER MCGUIRE ARE YOU
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND AFTER
LEADING TO TRANSPORTATION SENATE
MCGUIRE.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR WE'VE
ENERGY SIXTY THREE FIFTY SIX TO
CONTINUE THE IN C. R. A. SHUT
DOWN THE NORTH NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY BY
TRANSFERRING TWENTY POINT SEVEN
EIGHT MILES OF RAIL ASSETS.
FROM HILLS PER TO CLOVERDALE
WITHIN CINEMA COUNTY TO THE
CINEMA MARIN RAIL TRANSIT
DISTRICT.
THE THE LANGUAGE IN FRONT OF YOU
IS NEARLY IDENTICAL TO LANGUAGE
THAT PASSED THE FULL SENATE
UNANIMOUSLY LAST YEAR IN SB --
TEN TWENTY NINE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BIPARTISAN BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF A HEARING CHAIN
NINE MINUTES SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I HAVE A
ADAM.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THEY'RE ALSO.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
I GROSS.
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
I MONEY.
I MORE LONG [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKIING
[inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible] FIVE PAN
[inaudible]
HI. THIRTY SEVEN ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
FIFTY TWO SEN.
OUR WE DO WE DON'T WHAT I'M
SORRY.
THEN FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE
SENATOR CAFIEROYOU PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO SMALL SO THE SYSTEM
WATER AUTHORITIES SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB.
FOUR ONE FOUR THE SMALL SYSTEM
WATER THIRTY ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD HAS
IDENTIFIED NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
WATER SYSTEM STATEWIDE.
THAT CHRONICALLY SERVE
CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER OR
AND AND RELIABLE WATER SERVICE.
IT IS AN ACCEPTABLE FOR ANY
RESIDENTS IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD TO BE
SERVED CONTAMINATED DRINKING
WATER. ONE PART OF THE PUZZLE IS
TO ADDRESS GOVERNANCE ISSUES AT
THE FAILING SYSTEMS AND TO ALLOW
THEM TO CONSOLIDATE IN A NEW WAY.
TRADITIONAL CONSOLIDATIONS OFTEN
RELY ON CONTIGUOUS LARGE LARGER
WATER AGENCIES TO FACILITATE A
CONSOLIDATION.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL SOLUTION CRAFTED WITH
VIGOROUS STAKEHOLDER OUT REACH
THAT ALLOWS SMALL NON COMPLIANT
WATER SYSTEMS EMERGE INTO A
LARGER MORE ROBUST PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEM.
THEY CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IMPROVED EC AKON AMIS OF SCALE
STREAMLINED MANAGERIAL FUNCTIONS
AND ENHANCE FINANCIAL CAPACITY.
THE MERGE SYSTEMS WILL BE FORMED
AS AN INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICT AND BE PROVIDED WITH
NEW INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY INCLUDING
AN ELECTED BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
AND THE NEW SPECIAL DISTRICTS
WILL BE SCALED TO SIZE TO
SUBSTANTIALLY DEVELOP COORDINATE
OUR CONTRACT FOR THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO TREAT THEIR
CONTAMINATION ISSUES.
THIS WILL LEAD TO VIABLE WATER
SYSTEMS THAT CAN EFFECTIVELY
DELIVER SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR ESTABLISHES A
ROAD MAP FOR CONSOLIDATION OF
MULTIPLE SYSTEMS WITH A DEFINED
TIMELINE TO FACILITATE A
CONSOLIDATION THAT BRITAIN DOES
NOT RELYON IT OUR D. J. SENT
LARGER WATER SYSTEMS.
THE ROAD MAP UTILIZES THE
EXISTING STATUTORY PROVISIONS
FOR MERGERS THE SOLUTIONS AND
CONSOLIDATIONS IN THE LAUGH
COLESLAW.
AND IT REQUIRES AN OPEN PUBLIC
PROCESS WHICH GIVES THE AFFECTED
PARTIES AN OPPORTUNITY PART TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THE CREATION AND GOVERNANCE
OF THEIR NEW WATER SYSTEMS.
SB FOUR ONE FOUR IS THE ONLY
BILL THAT DIRECTS THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF FORCING
THESE TROUBLED SYSTEMS. TO SELF
CORRECT OR TO MERGE THE BILL HAS
ZERO NO VOTE AND UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE POLICY
COMMITTEE COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR NEED FOR THE
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE ON
HEARING SEEN ON THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL DURING
THE OBJECTION VIEWS.
WE AVE AN OBJECTION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WAS SO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOT
[inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I LIKE HOW SKI.
I WIENER.
I WILK.
HI.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI.
MEASURE PASSES THIRTY SEVEN FIVE
ZERO KNOWS.
NEXT UP IS ITEM FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR RAFI PREPARED YES SHE IS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR ROTH AN ACT RELATING TO
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
SKINNER OFF THING THIS PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SEE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDES OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES.
WITH MUCH NEEDED FINANCIAL AID
HOWEVER THE STATUTORY LIMITATION
OF FOUR ACADEMIC YEARS OF FULL
TIME ATTENDANCE.
CREATES A LARGE BARRIER FOR
STUDENTS WHO SEEK TO GRADUATE IN
A FOUR YEAR TIME FRAME.
SOMETIMES FRANKLY IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO SIGN UP FOR
NECESSARY COURSES DURING THE
REGULAR ACADEMIC YEAR.
AND SUMMER SCHOOL BECOMES A
NECESSITY RATHER THAN AN OPTION.
UNFORTUNATELY CAL GRANT DOES NOT
PROVIDE ANY DEDICATED FINANCIAL
AID FOR SUMMER COURSES AND
DRAWING DOWN AID.
DIMINISHES OVERALL ELIGIBILITY.
THIS BILL SENATE BILL FOUR SIX
ONE WOULD FIX THIS DEMONSTRATED
NEED BY EXPANDING THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM. TO ALLOW CAL GRANT A OR
B. STUDENTS TO RECEIVE AN
ADDITIONAL SUMMER CAL GRANT
AWARD FOR UP TO TWO SUMMER TERMS
CAPTAIN NINE UNITS FOR PURPOSES
OF TIMELY COMPLETION.
OF A BACCALAUREATE DEGREE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OR AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
EXPANDING CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
TO SUMMER SESSIONS WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS TO AFFORD SUMMER
COURSES REDUCE THEIR FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
AND GRADUATE IN A FASTER TIME
FRAME WITHOUT INCURRING
ADDITIONAL DEBT.
WE'RE WORKING TO SECURE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM IN THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
OUR STUDENTS CANNOT BE PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM IF THEY
CANNOT GET ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE.
WE MUST PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO GET THERE
IF CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE OUR FUTURE.
AND WE KNOW THEY ARE WE OWE THIS
TO THEM I RESPECTFULLY AS FOR
NOW VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
ATTILA.
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR I THINK THAT --
HE MUST'VE GOTTEN TO CAL STATE
LA IN LOS ANGELES AND TALK TO
SOME OF THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
THERE.
AND SOME OF THE MINORITY
STUDENTS THAT ARE FROM THE LA
COUNTY AREA THAT FIND IT SO
DIFFICULT TO FINISH THOSE FOUR
YEARS WITHIN THE SPECIFIED TIME.
AND MATHEMATICALLY FINANCIALLY
THE BURDEN THAT THEY HAVE TO
CARRY SOME WITH TWO OR THREE
PART TIME JOB JUST TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
THIS BILL WILL A SYSTEM ENABLES.
ACTUALLY OPEN DOOR SHOOTS TO
SUCCESS AND I APPLAUD YOU AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITION
DESCRIPTION OF THE DEBATE ON THE
SIDE ON HEARING CHAIN ON THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
OF USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THE SITE ON SENATE HEARING.
NINE MEASURE PASS.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT UP CENTER
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
ITEM.
FIFTY SIX MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
A MEMBERS.
BY A FLYING FICKLE FINGER OF
FATE OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOW
ALLOWS RECIPIENTS OF FOOD
BENEFITS -- TO ORDER THEIR FOOD
ONLINE SO IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WOULD HAVE SISTER ARE FOLKS WHO
HAVE CAL FRESH -- IF CALIFORNIA
DECIDES TO ALLOW.
THE USE OF YOU BE T<c.cyan>OR</c>
ONLINE PURCHASES WHAT SB FOUR
SEVENTY DOES IS HELP CREATE SOME
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THROUGH IT
ESTABLISHES QUALIFICATIONS IN A
PROCESS FOR APPROVING THE SAFE
ONLINE RETAILERS.
SO THAT OUR RECIPIENTS OF
CALIBRATION ARE PROTECTED IF
THEY USE THEIR BENEFITS ONLINE
AND WITH THAT AYE ASPIRATES.
BY BOAT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITION
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
WONDERFUL FIGURE LIVE MY AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- THIS IS
GOING TO EASE SOME OF THE FOOD
SECURITY ISSUES THAT -- MANY OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE I WOULD
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE BE
THERE OR BE SQUARE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNITED'S
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
OF USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THE SIDE ON HEARING SEEN --
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR PORTANTINO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR PORTANTINO THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND SENATORS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB FORTY
FOUR WHICH SIGNIFICANTLY
SIMPLIFIES THE TRANSFER PROCESS
FROM A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. TO U. C. OR C. S. U.
FOR STUDENTS SO WHETHER THOSE
STUDENTS USE THEIR THING OR
THEIR PACER.
WHEN THEY TRANSFER FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO UC OR CAL
STATE -- THIS BILL WILL SIMPLIFY
THAT PROCESS AND REQUIRES
COLLEGES TO GIVE THEIR ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER UPON
COMPLETING THAT -- THOSE
REQUIREMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FOR THE DESCRIPTION OF IT ON
THE SIDE OF SIX HEARING SEE NINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible] FIVE
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible] FIVE JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PART.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
I SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE. ONE MORE TIME MR.
MA'AM SECTOR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE.
OUR EYES THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR BREAUX MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BELL AN ACT RELATING TO
DRIVING PRIVILEGE.
RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL SB FORTY FIVE
PROHIBITS THE SUSPENSION OF A
DRIVER'S LICENSE. FOR NON
VEHICLE RELATED CRIMES
SUSPENDING A DRIVER'S LICENSE
BECAME A POPULAR METHOD OF
PUNISHMENT IN THE NINETIES
WHETHER OR NOT A CRIME HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH OPERATING A
VEHICLE.
THIS DOES NOT INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ONLY DETERS A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN.
MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT AND PAY
RESTITUTION.
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS DEPEND ON
ABOUT HAVING A VALID DRIVER'S
LICENSE. 78% OF CALIFORNIANS
DRIVE TO WORK.
OVER FIVE MILLION JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA REQUIRE A VALID
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
SUSPENSION FOR NON VEHICLE
RELATED CRIMES LEADS TO
INCARCERATION FINES.
FEES IMPOUNDING VEHICLES ALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
AND COMMUNITY CALLER -- I ALSO
WANT TO MENTION WOMEN.
BECAUSE WHEN I VISITED THE
WOMEN'S SHELTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO -- THE WOMEN HAD
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENDED --
UNDER THESE CODES THAT WE HAVE.
FLORIDA PASSED A BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION TO END THE
SUSPENSIONS FOR NON VEHICLE
RELATED CRIMES.
I URGE CALIFORNIA DO THE SAME --
THIS ELIMINATES AN INEFFICIENT
UNNECESSARY WORKLOAD.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES THEY HAVE OTHER THINGS
TO DO -- LIKE OUR REAL ID
PROCESSING.
AND THE ELIMINATION OF THE LINES
AT THE DMV.
THIS WILL HELP THAT THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY HOUSE FOR
A VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU SENATOR
BELL MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
THIRD OR GROWTH THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL ALTHOUGH I THINK WE
SHOULD LEAVE IT IN A JUDGE'S
DISCRETION SO THAT IF THERE IS
SOMEONE WHO NEEDS. TO BE ABLE TO
GET BACK AND FORTH TO WORK THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT IF
IT'S A OF A SINGLE MOM THAT
NEEDS TO GO BACK TO WORK THAT
HAD AN INFRACTION THAT WASN'T A
DRIVER'S LICENSE BUT PASSING
THIS BILL IS GOING TO LIMóN.
EIGHT THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION TO
REMOVE SOMEONE'S DRIVER'S
LICENSE FOR PURCHASING A HUMAN
BEING FOR SEX -- IT'S GOING TO
ADDRESS HUMAN TRAFFICKING A
JUDGE IS NOT GOING TO HAVE
DISCRETION TO BE ABLE TO REMOVE
THAT PERSON'S DRIVER'S LICENSE.
SOMEBODY WHO IS -- LIKE I SAID
EARLIER PURCHASING A FEMALE FOR
SEX WILL NOT HAVE THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE BE ABLE TO BE REMOVED.
THERE ARE A LOT OF INSTANCES IN
CODE SECTIONS WERE JUDGES WILL
PUTATIVELY PUNISH SOMEONE THAT
IS NOT NECESSARILY A VIOLATION
FOR THE MOTOR VEHICLE CODE BUT
IT ALSO DOES DO TOUR PEOPLE FROM
BEING ABLE TO DO THINGS THAT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO.
ACCORDING TO THE LAW SO I WOULD
ASK FEAR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING ANSWER BILL
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH THANK
YOU -- I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT --
ELIMINATE ANY PENAL CODE SO A
JUDGE AT THE DISCRETION UNDER
ANY -- CRIME CAN AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE JUDGE.
IN THAT INDIVIDUAL CASE REMOVE
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
SUSPENDED -- AS PART OF THAT --
CRIMINAL ACTION THIS IS WHAT
THIS DOES IS TO PREPARE IT
PREVENTS THE AUTOMATIC
SUSPENSION OF VEHICLE CODE.
SECTIONS NOT PENAL CODE SECTIONS
ARJUN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
I THEIR OTHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible] FIVE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE VIEW [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILL.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO.
SIZE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE ARE GOING TO ALLOW
OUR PRESIDING OFFICER TO PRESENT
HIS BILLS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE MAC IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR
SENATOR BRADFORD MR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO THE FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT
FUND AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE.
EFFORT THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SP FOUR FIVE FIVE DIRECTION
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
TO ADMINISTER.
A GRANT PROGRAM WHICH WILL AWARD
GRANTS STOPPED A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
FINANCIAL EDUCATION.
AND FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THE
UNBANKED AND UNDER BANKED
CALIFORNIANS MONEY A TO THIS
FUND.
THE MONEY TO FUND THIS GRANT
PROGRAM WILL COME FROM THE FINES
AND PENALTIES THE D. V. O.
COLLECTS.
FROM ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS TAKEN
AGAINST PAYDAY LENDERS AN
INSTALLMENT LINERS SB FOUR FIVE
FIVE DIRECT UP TO ONE MILLION
ANNUALLY FROM THE REVENUE STREAM
TO GRANT TO THIS GRANT PROGRAM
THERE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL WILL HELP BRIDGE
INFORMATION GAP THAT MANY
UNDERSERVED CALIFORNIANS FACE IT
CAN BE HARD TO MAKE THE BEST
FINANCIAL DECISIONS IF YOU DON'T
HAVE ACESS TO ALL THE
INFORMATION RESOURCES THAT ARE
NECESSARY.
SB FOUR FIVE FIVE SUPPORTED BY
MISSION ASSET FUND.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY A VARIETY OF
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION THE
MONARCH TO ASK FOR YOUR HIGH
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM
ONE TEN SENATOR BRADFORD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO CANNABIS CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU SB FIVE NINE FIVE
WHICH WILL ENABLE INDIVIDUALS
FROM.
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGALIZE CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
SB S. SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE NINE
FIVE WILL HELP ACHIEVE THE GOAL
OF CREATING A EQUITABLE INDUSTRY
BY REQUIRING THE THREE STATE
LICENSE THE TORIES TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM TO BROAD
FEEDER FOR ALL.
IN A WAVE THE FEES TO OBTAIN AND
READ NEW STATE LICENSES FOR
LOCAL EQUITY APPLICANTS AND
LICENSEES LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED SB TWELVE
NINETY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS EQUITY ACT.
WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE ADOPTED
AND IMPLEMENTED A LOCAL EQUITY
pUPON THE WORK OF LAST YEAR TO
PROVIDE DIRECT SUPPORT. FOR
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE STATE
FACING THE TOUGH AS BARRIERS TO
ENTRY.
ULTIMATELY THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP GROW AND DIVERSIFY
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS INDUSTRY
IN SUPPORT DEVELOP SMALL
BUSINESSES AND BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE DEVASTATED
BY THE PROHIBITION IN A WARRANT
DRUGS OVER THE YEARS.
AND INCREASED PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY BY ENCOURAGING
INDIVIDUALS TO OBTAIN LEGAL
LICENSE IN OPERATE ABOVE LAW SB
FIVE NINE FIVE IS RISKY
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
GALGIANI.
THAT'S REALLY GROOVY DUDE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE CENTER BRADFORD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
RIGHT ON MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
I RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
HI HELLO.
AYE HUESO.
I TANTO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL.
I GET IT NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I BROUGHT [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN.
I DON'T.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RUBIO.
WELL HI HI.
I TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM.
FIFTY ONE SENATOR PORTANTINO.
I AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO FIREARMS SOONER
PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS -- SB THREE SEVENTY SIX
WOULD REDEFINE INFREQUENT TO
MEAN LESS THAN SIX FIREARMS
TRANSACTIONS PER CALENDAR YEAR
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF FIRE
ARM FOR INDIVIDUALS TO SELL
LEASE OR TRANSFER.
FIREARMS WITH THE AL LEGALLY
BEING REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A
LICENSE SO HERE COMES THE JUDGE.
THERE IS A DISPARITY IN THE
PENAL CODES DEFINITION OF THE
TERM INFREQUENT WHICH RESULTS IN
THE DISPARITY IN A WAY IN WHICH
I'M LICENSED SELLERS OF FIREARMS
ARE TREATED UNDER THE LAW.
INDIVIDUALS MAY OR MAY NOT BE
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A LICENSE TO
SELL FIREARMS DEPENDING ON THE
TYPE OF FIREARM BEING TRANSACTED
IN SOME INSTANCES THIS MAY
EXEMPT FOR EXAMPLE NON PROFITS.
FROM HAVING TO GO THROUGH A
LICENSED DEALER ONE RAFFLE YOUR
AUCTIONING OFF A FIREARM THIS
DISPARATE TREATMENT CAUSES
CONFUSION AND MAKES UNCLEAR IF
AND WHEN SELLERS ARE REQUIRED.
TO AND SHOULD OBTAIN A LICENSE
TO ENGAGE IN THE BUSINESS F
TRANSACTION FIREARMS THIS IS A
PROBLEM BOTH FOR THE PUBLIC AS
WELL FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE THERE'S A BLACK OF A
BRIGHT LINE THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO STANDARDIZE THE
DEFINITION OF THE TERM
INFREQUENT IT IS ALSO INTENDED
TO REDUCE THE FREQUENCY.
AND NUMBER OF FIREARMS AN
INDIVIDUAL IS ALLOWED TO SELL OR
MANUFACTURE ANNUALLY WITHOUT A
LICENSE THE BILL CREATES A
SINGLE LIMIT FOR THE NUMBER OF
TRANSACTIONS ON ON LICENSE
INDIVIDUAL IS AFFORDED IN A YEAR
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
FIREARM BEING TRANSACTED.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION WHERE TRANSACTIONS
MAY BE A MIXTURE OF VARIOUS
TYPES OF FIREARMS THE BILL ALSO
LIMITS THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
FIREARMS INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO
SELL LEASE OR TRANSFER TO NO
MORE THAN.
FIFTY PER YEAR WITHOUT HAVING TO
OBTAIN A LICENSE THAT JUST SEEMS
COMMONSENSE YOU'RE GONNA BE
DOING MASS -- FIREARM
TRANSACTION SHE SHOULD HAVE A
LICENSE AT MINIMUM AND WITH ONLY
UP TO FIVE SEPARATE TRAY THIS
ACTION INDIVIDUALS REQUIRED TO
ATTAIN THIS LICENSE IF THEY ARE
SELLING LEASING TRANSFERRING OUR
MANUFACTURING MORE THAN FIFTY
FIREARMS A YEAR.
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE THE
FIRST STATE TO INSTITUTE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
THESE CONNECTICUT REQUIRES
INDIVIDUAL SELLING MORE THAN TEN
HAND GUNS TO GET A LICENSE
MASSACHUSETTS GENERALLY REQUIRES
ANY INDIVIDUAL SELLING OR
LEASING A FIREARM. TO OBTAIN A
LICENSE PROVIDING FOR SOME
EXPECT EXCEPTIONS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF HERE
NINETY NINE MEN SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
WELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD BY I CABALLERO
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
GROVE NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.FIVE HUESO.
HI -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK.
NO.
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES.
NO CUT BY ERA [inaudible]
I CHIANG -- TADA [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I ROTH.
ICE TWENTY SIX KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS REMOVING BACK ON THE FOR
OUR MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATED TO HEALTH AND CARE
FACILITIES CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- TODAY AND PRESENTING
SB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE HOSPITALS THAT OF A
BUILDING THAT IS NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE JANUARY ONE
TWO THOUSAND THIRTY SEISMIC
SAFETY STANDARD. TO REPORT TO
THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT WHAT
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED IN EACH
BUILDING OF THAT HOSPITAL -- BOB
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR A WHILE SO MANY OF
YOU KNOW OUR HOSPITAL SO SPENT
SIGNIFICANTLY TO CARRY OUT
SEISMIC SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
WHICH ARE VERY IMPORTANT. FOR
THE SAFETY OF THE WORK FORCE --
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE HOSPITALS -- CAN MEET
THAT REQUIREMENT -- AS OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ALL OF THE HOSPITALS --
ON THAT LIST HAVE MET THE
REQUIREMENTS -- NOW THEIR
HOSPITALS MUST NOW TURN TO THE
TWENTY THIRTY OR REQUIREMENT
WHICH REQUIRES THEM TO ENSURE
THEIR ENTIRE FACILITY IS FULLY
OPERATIONAL AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE.
SO ACCORDING THE RAND
CORPORATION THIS WOULD COST
HOSPITAL SIGNIFICANTLY AND SO
THIS SIGNIFICANT COSTS REQUIRES
THAT WE HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS ISSUE SO SB.
FIVE SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT CURRENTLY
REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO REPORT THE
LOCATION OF THOSE SERVICES TO
THE OFFICE AND THIS INFORMATION
WILL BE HELPFUL AS WE FOCUS ON
THE TWENTY THIRTY MANDATE.
HOWEVER WE'VE ENGAGED.
WE HAVE ENGAGE THOSE WHO WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPRESS CONCERNS.
RELATED TO THIS ISSUE AND WITH
38% OF OUR HOSPITAL'S OPERATING
IN THE RED WE MUST LOOK AT HOW
WE CAN SOLVE THIS SITUATION
EQUITABLY AND O I THINK THIS
BILL HELPS MOVE THAT
CONVERSATION FORWARD.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
ON SEEN ON THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF APPLYING TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEE NINE THIRTY EIGHT OUR EYES
ZERO KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
ATTY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OUR MEMBERS REMOVING BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND WE
WANT TO RECOGNIZE TO STUDENTS
FROM ST JEAN'S DELLA Là TO
KNOCK.
KNOCK SCHOOL WELCOME TO YOUR
CAPITAL THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
NOW MOTIONS WROTE RESOLUTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATOR HILL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I'D LIKE -- TO MOVE I FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SB THIRTY EIGHT TO
THE INACTIVE FILE.
DO WE KNOW IT [inaudible]
IT'S JUST
.
OUR NEXT STEP IS ITEM FIFTY NINE
SIR MCGUIRE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO SCHOOL MEALS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT MR
PRESIDENT STUDENTS ARE
CHALLENGED TO THRIVE IN THE
CLASSROOM THE RUNNING ON AN
EMPTY STOMACH CHILDHOOD HUNGER
IS AN EPIDEMIC IN THE GOLDEN
STATE WITH NEARLY TWO MILLION
KIDS.
WHO ARE FOOD INSECURE THROUGH
TEN CENTER PRACTICE
REIMBURSEMENT SP FOUR NINETY
NINE IS A WIN WIN WIN?
IT INCENTIVIZE SCHOOLS WERE BY
UNIVERSAL MEALS AND PURCHASE
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA GROWN FRUITS
AND VEGGIES THAT SUPPORTS LOCAL
FARMERS.
BASED OFF OF THE SUCCESSFUL
FRESH START BY THE PROGRAM
DURING GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER'S --
SP FOUR NINETY NINE UPDATED THE
MODEL TO INCENTIVIZE YOU KNOW
UNIVERSAL MEALS FOR STUDENTS AND
PAIRED IT PAIRED IT WITH
FEDERALLY FUNDED COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY PROVISIONS TO NOTE
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL.
MEALS THIS EXTRA DIME WORKS FOR
THE HIGHEST LEADER URBAN AND
RURAL COMMUNITIES WHO OFTEN
STRUGGLE TO COME.
IN GRANT BASED PROGRAMS WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS SIZE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND I THINK THAT ONCE.
IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED INTO LAW.
OUR STUDENTS THAT ARE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS WILL BE SAYING I CAN'T
BELIEVE I ATE THE WHOLE THING.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE [inaudible]
GOOD
SKIP IS A MOMENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THE OTHER [inaudible]
YEAH -- ON AGAIN
.
THANK YOU YEAH ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
USE IN A UNION ASTRO CALL ON
THIS ITEM.
IN NINETEEN NINE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FIFTEEN MINUTE
RECESS FOR LUNCH WORRY WILL
START BACK PROMPTLY AT TWELVE
THIRTY SO WE'LL BE IN RECESS FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES THANK YOU
FILE ITEM SIXTY BY CENTER MARIE
MORALE.
CINNAMON ROLL YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT YOUR ITEM.
YES HE IS A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL I MEAN UP PLEASE
READ [inaudible]
THE BILL.
SENATE BILL FIVE HUNDRED BY
SENATOR MORALE AN ACT RELATING
TO VETERANS.
THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS TODAY I IN PRESENTING SP
SENATE BILL FIVE HUNDRED WHICH
WILL DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
TWO COURAGEOUS A TUITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SIMILAR TO
THAT OF THE GI BILL TO OUR STATE
THIS ABLE VETERANS UNDER THIS
BILL CALVET WILL HAVE ONE YEAR
TO ESTABLISH THE PROGRAM.
AND SET THE APPROPRIATE
GUIDELINES BEFORE SEEKING THE
FULL APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE
PROGRAM.
MANY VETERANS ARE RETURNING A
CALIFORNIA UNABLE TO PERFORM THE
JOB THEY DID.
IN ARM SERVICES DUE TO THEIR
DISABILITIES THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THEY ARE ABLE TO STAND
OUT IN A COMPETITIVE WORKFORCE.
THIS HAT IS A BIPARTISAN BILL
AND FORTUNATELY IT HAS NOT HAVE
ONE SINGLE NO VOTE.
I ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL TODAY IN
SUPPORT SB.
FIVE HUNDRED DO YOU GET MY DRIFT.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
THE NINE MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD.
I CABRERA [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
I DON.
THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible] FIVE
MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I ROOM [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE YOU [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I WELL [inaudible]
DODD.
I THERE EITHER -- TADO
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
STERN.
TOMORROW MOVES A CALL NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE SINNER HER
TODD -- SHE'S.
ARE YOU RICH YOU'RE PREPARED
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR HURTADO AN ACT RELATING
TO WATER.
THE FOR YOUR SON OR DAUGHTER
THANK YOU MISTER HASN'T.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB FIVE ONE
THREE SB FIVE WILL ONE THREE
WILL HELP INSURE EMERGENCY WATER
TANKS REMAIN AVAILABLE TO HOMES.
WHO ARE WITHOUT DRINKING WATER?
IN CALIFORNIA OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED FAMILIES HAVE NEEDED
EMERGENCY WATER TAX AS A RESULT
OF CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC DROUGHT.
ALTHOUGH THE DROUGHT WAS
DECLARED OVER IN APRIL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WATER SHORTAGE IS A
CHRONIC SYMPTOMS IN MY DISTRICT
AND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
GROUNDWATER MOVED MUCH MORE
SLOWLY AND SURFACE WATER AND IT
TAKES TIME FOR GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE OF WELLS TOOK HER.
THIS MEANS THAT MANY FAMILIES IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO RELY ON
WELLS FOR THEIR DRINKING WATER
ARE STILL IN NEED OF
INTERMONTANE X..
EVEN THOUGH THE DROUGHT HAS BEEN
DECLARED OVER.
WELL ALL E. S. HAS COMMITTED TO
DISBURSING FUNDS TRADITIONAL
FAMILIES THERE IS A LACK OF
CLARITY REGARDING WHAT WILL
HAPPEN TO THE PROGRAM ONCE THE
INITIAL FUNDING RUNS OUT.
SB FIVE WHAT THREE CODIFIES THE
FUNDING FOR INTRA WATTER TANKS
ARE AVAILABLE FOR ANY HOME
IMPACTED BY CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORIC DROUGHT AND CLARIFIES
AT THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
MAY ASSUME PROVIDE DOING
LEGISLATIVE MAKE FUNDING FOR
WATER TANKS OUTSIDE OF AN
EMERGENCY DOT DECLARATION.
WITHOUT CLARITY IN THE LAW.
THAT ALLOWS US PROGRAM TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS TO HOMES OUTSIDE
OF EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WILL REMAIN UNABLE TO OFFER
FAMILIES.
THE COMFORT OF INTRA WATER TANKS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN VOTING I FOR
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
CENTER WALK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
STAND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE
ONE THREE WATER SHOULD ALWAYS BE
GOOD TO THE LAST DROP.
IN CENTER OF TODD A WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I'M SORRY SAID SOONER CAVIAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
HER -- HER WORK ON THIS BILL I
HAD THE DISTINCT UNPLEASANT LESS
DURING DURING THE DROUGHT. TO
VISIT EACH PART OF EL WHERE
THERE WERE THE LACK OF WATER WAS
SIGNIFICANT -- AND REALLY
DEVASTATED THE COMMUNITY AND
THEN WATER TANKS WERE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
RESUME MY MY MORE NORMAL WAY OF
LIFE AND WE GAVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY ME THE THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO SPENT A YEAR WITH NO
FLUSHING TOILETS.
THEY TOOK THEIR CHILDREN DOWN TO
THE LOCAL CHURCH TO TAKE SHOWERS
AND THESE TANKS PROVIDED AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM.
TO JUST LIVE THEIR NORMAL THEY
DAILY LIFE AND SO I WANNA WANNA
COMMAND ON THE GOOD SENATOR FROM --
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND AND
ASPIRIN I AM THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- BE
TOTALLY GNARLY IFYOU GAVE THIS
VALLEY GIRL A WIN ON THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION [inaudible]
HI.
IN THE ADDITION -- DEBATE ON THE
SITE ON YOUR INSANE NONE SKINNER
ATOP A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
J. THIS MEASURE IS ELIGIBLE FOR
WELL NO WE HAVE TO DO ROCK
[inaudible]
USER.
ALL RIGHT THE MEASURE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU NOW IS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS WROCLAW.
JEANNIE HEARING NINE THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS.
ITEM SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR BATES.
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR BATES AN ACT RELATING TO
SCHOOL SAFETY.
SENATOR BATES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB FIVE FORTY
ONE REQUIRES ALL KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE.
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS WITH
AN ENROLLMENT OF FIFTY OR MORE
STUDENTS TO CONDUCT ONE LOCKDOWN
DRILL PER SCHOOL YEAR.
GIVEN THE UNFORTUNATE THREATS TO
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS TODAY
STUDENTS VOLUNTEERS STAFF
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
CANNOT BE PREPARED ENOUGH FOR
THE UNKNOWN.
FROM DEVASTATING WILDFIRES TO
ACTIVE SHOOTERS ON CAMPUS WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT ALL PEOPLE
ON OUR CAMPUSES ARE PREPARED TO
ACT IMMEDIATELY WITH CHILDREN'S
OUT MOST SAFETY IN MIND.
EXISTING EDUCATION CODE DOES
REQUIRE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS TO
CONDUCT FIRE DRILLS REGULARLY.
AND INTERMEDIATE LEVEL IN
SECONDARY SCHOOLS AT LEAST TWICE
A YEAR.
BUT EX EXISTING STATUTE DOES NOT
REQUIRE TRAINING FOR ANY OR
TYPES OF THREATS.
THAT MAY OCCUR ON CAMPUS THAT ME
JEOPARDIZE THE SAFETY OF ALL ON
CAMPUS SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE TAKEN IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
PROVIDE THIS TRAINING.
BUT IT IS CRITICAL FOR ALL OF
OUR SCHOOLS AND CHILDREN TO BE
PREPARED FOR EVERY SITUATION.
LAST YEAR TREMENDOUS STRIDES
WERE MADE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS SCHOOL SAFETY.
MEASURES LACKED A REQUIREMENT TO
CONDUCT LOCKDOWN DRILLS FIVE
TAKEN RECENT AMENDMENTS
CLARIFYING THAT DRILLS SHOULD BE
AGE APPROPRIATE.
IN THAT SCHOOL OFFICIALS SHOULD
CONSIDER THE EMOTIONAL IMPACT OF
THE DRILLS WHEN PLANNING AND
CONDUCTING THEM.
I DO INTEND TO TAKE AN
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY THAT WOULD INCREASE
SCHOOL OFFICIALS TO REVIEW THE
ARTICLE MITIGATING PSYCHOLOGICAL
EFFECTS OF LOCKDOWNS.
HAS PREPARED BY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND THIS WAS
RECOMMENDED BOB BY THE CHAIRMAN
OF OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE.
I AND SO WE DO.
INTEND TO GO FORWARD IN THE
ASSEMBLY WITH ANOTHER MAN AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR BAM.
THANK YOU.
I WAS PRESIDENTE SENATORS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
I THINK -- A GOOD FRIEND -- FOR
WORKING WITH ME IN TERMS OF
BEING SURE THAT -- WHEN WE HAVE
THE LOCKDOWN DRILLS THAT WE DO
IT IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T --
TRAUMATIZED THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
DOING THE DRILL AND APPRECIATE --
HER -- NOT JUST WILLINGNESS BUT
EAGERNESS IN TRYING TO BE SURE
WE CORPORATE DOES ONE CORPORATE
GUY LICENSES COLLEGES.
AND I REALLY I AND I I THINK
THAT THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENTS SAFETY AND SO I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF MY AGAIN THANK.
MY GOOD FRIENDS IN LAGUNA MIGUEL
FOR FOR FOR BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
UNDER HERTZBERG.
THE COMMISSION PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO KINDLY I I JUST SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THE FORM REPUBLICAN
LEADERS WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS AND TAKE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND ALL I CAN SAY IS I CAN
REALLY DIG IT [inaudible]
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU I ALSO JUST WANT TO
COMMEND YOU I AM AS YOU KNOW AN
EDUCATOR AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW SERIOUS THE
SITUATION IS WHEN IT HAPPENS.
EVEN WITH WE HAD.
A LOCKDOWN DRILLS SOMETIMES OUR
STAFF OUTSIDE IS CAUGHT OFF
GUARD AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO WITH OUR KIDS AND AND WE
HAVE FIGURE THOSE THINGS OUT.
AS THINGS HAPPEN SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT IS NECESSARY AND I
SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF IT
ON THE SIDE ON HEARING AND
SEEING NONE SENATOR BATES SELECT
CLOSE YES RIGHT ON FOR THOSE
COMMENTS I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THE SIDE OF SCENE. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE
SENATOR JEFF [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible] SIXTY FIVE
BYE BYE ITEM SIXTY FIVE SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS -- SB.
S. STARRED WHICH ARE.
SENATOR PORTANTINO MISS SECTOR
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT
RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION SIR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB SIX
BUCKS THREE FIVE SIX EIGHT WHICH
WOULD ADDRESS THE MOUNTING
CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS.
AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS BY
ESTABLISHING HOUSING RESOURCES
WITH THE COMMUNITY CAUGHT WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE -- CSU AND
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF THE UC
OFFICE THE USE CSU TRANCERS
OFFICE AND WITHIN THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
REQUIRING CAMPUSES THAT RECEIVE
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT MEASURES TO
MAXIMIZE THE FINANCIAL AID
RECEIVED BY HOMELESS STUDENTS.
AND TO INSURE LINKAGES TO
COMMUNITY BASED HOUSING
RESOURCES CALIFORNIA'S HAVING A
CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS AMONGST
ITS COLLEGE STUDENTS ACCORDING
220-001-82000 NINETEEN REPORT.
BY THE LOS ANGELES COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT FROM THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE TRANCERS
OFFICE A FULL ONE IN FIVE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE AN EPISODE
OF HOMELESSNESS.
WITHIN THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS A
STUDY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY I STUDENTS FOUND THAT
11% OF STUDENTS REPORTED BEING
HOMELESS ONE OR MORE TIMES IN
THE LAST YEAR.
AND 5% OF UNIVERSITY A
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ALSO.
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS NOT
SURPRISINGLY HOMELESSNESS
SERIOUSLY AFFECTS OUR STUDENTS
ABILITY TO REMAIN IN SCHOOL AND
BE SUCCESSFUL -- THIS IS
PARTICULARLY ACUTE AMONG
STUDENTS ATTENDING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WERE DORM ACCESS IS
LIMITED OF THE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN CALIFORNIA
JUST ELEVEN HAVE DORMS.
SB FIVE SIX EIGHT WILL AUTHORIZE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO
COLLABORATE WITH LOCAL HOMELESS
COLLEGE FOCUS RAPID RE HOUSING
PROGRAM I WANT TO COMPLIMENT OUR
BUDGET CHAIR AND OUR BUDGET SUB
CHAIR. FOR ALSO -- WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SENATE VERSION OF THE BUDGET
INCLUDES MANY OF THESE
PROVISIONS.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE AND THIS
EFFORT THAT REPRESENTS OR THIS
BILL REPRESENTS AN EFFORT TO
ADDRESS IT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF HEARING AND SEEING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI I HAVE A A I CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I BROWSER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I BROUGHT [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE YOU.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
I'M SICK TO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE.
ICE THIRTY KNOWS TO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX
SENATOR RUBIO YOUR PREPARE
TICKED ASYLUM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY FOUR BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT TODAY AYE AYE
PRINCE I PRESENT SB FIVE NINETY
FOUR WHICH IS DOUBTLESS IS THE
INDUSTRY ON A ROAD MAP
INITIATIVE AND MINISTER BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
AND IT'S A LOT YOU KNOW CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL.
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR WOULD
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE TO
OUR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
REGARDING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE E. L. LANGUAGE.
ROAD MAP INITIATIVE THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE INTENT BEHIND THE ROADMAP
INITIATIVE IS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATIONAL
POLICIES.
PROGRAMS PRACTICES FOR E. L..
N. K. THROUGH TWELVE WHILE
EXPLICITLY FOCUSING ON EMAILS IN
THE CONTENT OF THE CONTEXT OF
THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
QUALITY OF TEACHING AND LEARNING
AS WLL AS PEOPLE EDUCATIONAL
TRAJECTORIES CALIFORNIA HAS
ABOUT ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
STUDENTS ONE IN FOUR PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS STATEWIDE ARE
CLASSIFIED AS E. L..
REPRESENTING OVER SIXTY
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES FURTHERMORE
60% OF CHILDREN ZERO FIVE COMING
INTO PUBLIC EDUCATION LIVE IN
HOMES WHERE ENGLISH IS NOT.
OUT SPOKEN IN THE HOME.
THAT'S WHY THERE IS AN ABSOLUTE
NEED TO PROVIDE MORE SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS.
ACCORDING TO THE C. D. E. THE
OVERALL -- TWENTY THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN FOR YOUR CALL
HARD GRADUATION WAS 91% WHILE
THE RATE FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS
WAS 65% THE LOSS OF ANY SUBGROUP
ASIDE STUDENTS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
IN ADDITION THE DROPOUT RATE FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS IS 21%.
AGAIN THE HIGHEST OF ANY
SUBGROUP THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT THE CD IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE.
WILL IMPLEMENT AN ILL ROADMAP
THAT WOULD FURTHER SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS OUR TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS PROVIDING A
BETTER EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL --
DEBATER COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE.
CENA NONE.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL -- JOURNEY OBJECTION
OF USING YOU KNOW UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THE SIDE OF WHEN I CLOSE
PLEASE.
WELL YES YOU'RE ALLOWED TO CLOSE
I THINK I JUST WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES AND I JUST WANNA
REMIND MY COLLEAGUES THERE
REMEMBER DIFFERENT STROKES FOR
DIFFERENT FOLKS EVERY CHILD IS
DIFFERENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING A YOU
KNOW THROW CALL ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE. THIRTY EIGHT ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
BURKE MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO ITEM.
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR HOW TADO
YOU'RE PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS
ITEM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR TADO AN ACT RELATING TO
WATER [inaudible]
DINNER TACO.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SB.
FIVE FIVE NINE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS BOTH IN CRITICAL NEED
OF WATER AND IN NEED OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADEQUATELY
DELIVER IT TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
AND THE LOCAL ECONOMY IN MY
DISTRICT.
SB FIVE FIVE NINE IS A DISTRICT
BILL WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WHICH AIMS TO RESTORE LOST
CONVEYANCE CAPACITY.
AND GET RID OF ALL THE BOOGIE
OKIE'S OUT OF OUR WATER.
AMENDMENTS AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MAKE THE FUNDING FOR
THE BILL UPON APPROPRIATIONS.
ALTHOUGH THE FRANK KERN CANAL IS
FEDERALLY OWNED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LONG AGO
HANDED OFF ALL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE CANAL TO LOCAL WATER
USERS WHO HAVE PAID THE FULL
COST OF CONSTRUCTION --
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE
OVER THE PAST SEVENTY YEARS.
THE BILL AUTHORIZES REPAIRS TO
THE CANAL PENDING APPROPRIATION
OF FUNDS CREATING A STATE
INVESTMENT IN A CONVEYANCE
PROJECT THAT FORMS PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BACKBONE.
AND WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO MEETING STATE
GROUNDWATER.
SUSTAINABILITY MANDATES AND
CLEAN DRINKING WATER GOALS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SENATOR BORDERS OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
THIS IS A PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT --
BILL NOT ONLY FOR ALL OF US
CALIFORNIANS BUT CERTAINLY --
FOR THOSE OF US WHO REPRESENT --
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE HAVE TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT
THE THE NEED FOR CLEAN DRINKING
WATER.
THE NEED FOR US TO INVEST IN --
SOUND INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT -- WE FOLLOW THE
PRIORITIES THAT I THINK WE ALL
HAVE AS BEEN -- EXPLAINED BY --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME THAT -- THIS
AREA.
OF CALIFORNIA I HAS CERTAIN
DISADVANTAGES THAT WE NEED TO
PUT.
OUR AND MAKE IT A PRIORITY.
CLEAN DRINKING WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE MAKING CERTAIN
THAT THIS IN -- UNDERPERFORMING
COMMUNITIES ARE BROUGHT UP TO
PAR THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HELP NOT ONLY ARE A CREEK
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CREATE SAFE
DRINKING WATER. TO IMPROVE OUR
OUR AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES BUT
ALSO IN IMPROVE OUR SCHOOLS AND
OUR HOMES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
IT IS THE I WANT TO COMMEND --
CENTER TAUGHT -- FOR HER A
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE -- I'M
CERTAINLY -- PROUD -- TO TO BE A
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR WITH HER
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT AND
I GOT TO SAY THIS IS WHEN WE DO
STUFF LIKE THIS IT REALLY BRINGS
THE BEST OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND OF COURSE -- THE CALIFORNIA
POLITICAL PROCESS ODD OF FOLKS --
I DON'T WANT TO BE A SPAZ.
THAT I'VE DONE.
THAT'S MY WORD OF THE DAY.
BUT I WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE I
WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE IN AYE
VOTE -- FOR THIS MATTER THANK
YOU.
AT THIS POINT THANK YOU.
SENATOR NELSON.
THE SPECIALIST USER OF THE
SENATE I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
HAVING BEEN RAISED DOWN THERE
AND FARM WHO SOME OF THAT WATER
I'M VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
THERE IS A FUNDAMENTAL POINT.
WITH OUR WATER DELIVERY.
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND OUR STORAGE INFRASTRUCTURE
WAS BROUGHT TO OUR MINDS.
NEARLY TWO AND A HALF YEARS AGO
WHEN THEY WERE WILL SPILL WAY
FAIL.
A PRODUCT OF YEARS OF NEGLECT.
THE CHECKING IN TESTING AND
MAINTENANCE.
SAME THINGS HAPPEN WITH OUR
CONVEYANCE SYSTEM. FOR WATER IN
CALIFORNIA.
PRIDE KERN CANALS DELIVERS WATER
FROM THE EASTERN WATERSHED.
INTO THE VALLEY.
IN THE CONVEYANCE SYSTEMS ALSO
DETERIORATE.
THE CONVEYANCE OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT.
HAS HAD PROBLEMS [inaudible]
WITH SUBSIDENCE [inaudible]
WITH CRACKS.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
WE DO NEED TO MAINTAIN OUR DAM
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND KEEP IT SURE IF IT WERE
MONITORING IT AND ASSEMBLYMAN
GALLAGHER I INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TOWARDS THAT END.
AND THEN EVEN ONCE YOU HAVE
SECURED.
AND MAINTAIN YOUR STORAGE
FACILITIES.
YOU HAVE GOT TO HAVE YOUR
CONVEYANCE.
AND THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
CANAL.
IN THIS MONEY IS NEEDED. TO
ENSURE CONTINUED DELIVERY.
OF THAT NECESSARY STORED WATER I
REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THINK THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SINGER -- FOR
PROPOSING THIS BILL THIS IS A AN
EXISTING FACILITY THAT IT REALLY
HAS BECOME DETERIORATED OVER THE
YEARS.
BECAUSE OF SUBSIDENCE WHICH IS
CREATED WHEN -- WHEN WATER IS
EXTRACTED FROM -- UNDERNEATH THE
SOIL.
AND THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT IF
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO FARM AND
TO PROVIDE WATER FOR THE FARM
WORKER FAMILIES THAT LIVE.
IN THIS REGION THAT WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING THAT TO BE ABLE TO
FIX THIS -- THIS PARTICULAR CAN
NOW AND THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE STATE GOVERNMENT TO STEP
UP AND SAY WE NEED A PARTNRSHIP.
WE NEED A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH THE
STATE GOVERNMENT AND WITH THE
LOCAL LAND OWNERS BECAUSE THE
THE ENTIRE REGION IS AFFECTED BY
THE SUBSIDENCE OF THIS
PARTICULAR FACILITY AND SO I
WANT.
TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF A BEST
AND AND AND URGED OF THE SENATE
TODAY TO PASS THIS OFF SO WE CAN
GET IT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROW.
THINKING THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT IS AN HONOR TO BE A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE ON JUST BECAUSE OF
ECHOING THE COMMENTS THAT ALL OF
THE VALLEY PEOPLE AND
INDIVIDUALS HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT.
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
THE CONSTITUENTS IN THE AREA.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SINGER HAD A
BILL EARLIER ABOUT WATER TANKS
IN BRINGING A SAFE QUALITY
DRINKING WATER IN SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE JUST LIVING
LIKE THEY'RE IN A THIRD WORLD
COUNTRY AND THIS.
THIS CANAL -- WITH THE
SUBSIDENCE HAS BEEN DAMAGED FOR
A LONG TIME AND TO HAVE THIS
FIXED AND REPAIRED WILL DELIVER
THAT WATER QUALITY THAT WE NEED
FOR CONSTITUENTS SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
A BETTER LIFE.
I'M HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO I
THINK THAT THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD VITALLY
IMPORTANT AND I'M HONORED TO BE
A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU MISTER RESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
NINE YOU KNOW SOMETIMES A LITTLE
THAT WILL DO YEAR.
BUT IN THIS CASE A BIG GAP IS
NECESSARY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT JUST
A YOU KNOW AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
HERE ON THE LEGISLATURE WE'VE
BEEN WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
THIS CANAL ON HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS. TO THE WATER CONVEYANCE
SYSTEM SO THIS IS NOT JUST A
LOCAL DISTRICT ISSUE THIS IS A
STATE WIDE.
ISSUE AND HOW WE MOVE WATER
RESOURCES AROUND THE STATE THIS
NEEDS TO BE FIXED WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING OF ABOUT THIS IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T.
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME THE
STATE HAS TAKEN RESPONSIBILITY
FOR FREIGHT FEDERAL ISSUES AS
WE'RE DOING AND SO MANY AREAS OF
THE STATE THIS IS SOMETHING
NEEDS TO GET FIXED.
SO I SUPPORT -- MOVING FORWARD
WITH A SOLUTION TO THIS THIS
ENORMOUS PROBLEM.
IN THE HEART OF OUR STATE.
OF MEMBERS I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
IN A CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- I
RISE TODAY WITH RELUCTANT
CONCERNS.
AS CHAIR THE WATER COMMITTEE I I
THOUGHT THE SENATOR FROM SAYING --
MADE INCREDIBLY COMPELLING CASE
FOR COMMUNITY AND IS.
COMPELLED UPON MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. TO TO KEEP THIS
MEASURE MOVING ALONG AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT IN THE ABSENCE OF
FEDERAL ACTION IN FACT.
IN MY VIEW A DERELICTION OF DUTY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO
MAINTAIN THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
WE'RE SITTING HERE TODAY TALKING
ABOUT SUBSIDIZING THEIR BOTTOM
LINE.
WE GIVE A LOT OF MONEY TO THE
FEDS AS TAXPAYERS IN THIS STATE --
AND YOU KNOW I WASN'T GOING TO
RISE AND SPEAK TODAY BUT I'M I'M
COMPELLED TO RAISE THAT ISSUE
BECAUSE THERE IS A FARM BILL
MOVING THROUGH CONGRESS.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF RESOURCES
FEDERALLY THAT WE'VE ALREADY
GIVEN THEM FROM OUR TAX DOLLARS.
SO I STILL REMAIN CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP HI I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE DO NEED A
PARTNERSHIP AND I THINK THAT
PARTNERSHIP GOING TO BE KEY BUT
SO FAR I HAVEN'T SEEN MUCH FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WILLING TO PARTNER WITH
CALIFORNIA.
ON MUCH OF ANYTHING BUT I WILL
SAY I'M GONNA BE LAYING OFF AND
NOT VOTING NO TODAY OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THE CENTER FOR
SANGER AND THE IMPORTANCE OF OF
MOVING THE ISSUE FORWARD SO --
THANK YOU.
IS SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- IN
IN IN LIGHT OF THE REMARKS --
MADE BY THE LAST SPEAKER I DO
HAVE.
A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WERE YOU ARE WILLING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
ALREADY HAD CENTER [inaudible]
WORK.
I'M CURIOUS -- GIVEN GIVEN THE
NATURE OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
JUST MADE AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
WE DO INDEED HAVE A JOB TURKEY
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
I'M WONDERING IF -- IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES TAKE
ACTION AND STEP UP IN TERMS OF
WHAT IS THEIR ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY -- IF THERE IS
YOU KNOW A CAMBIADO SOMETHING IN
YOUR BILL THAT WOULD STOP OUR
PROCESS IF INDEED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WERE TO STEP UP.
AND TAKE RESPONSIBILITY IN
KEEPING WITH THE COMMENTS FROM.
THE MEMBER FROM -- WEST LA.
ENTER A TOUGH THANK YOU.
SO THIS BILL IS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION AND SO.
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT WILL BE I ASSUME
IT WILL BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION.
IF THERE IS ANY MONEY ALLOCATED
AT LEVEL PERFECT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
GENERAL TODD -- TO LOOK TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOYS
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNITS
WERE.
AND WE NEED -- COUGH OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALEX GET ALAN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD.
I ABOUT YETTER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
BROWN'S [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I LIKE OWSKI [inaudible]
NO WIENER [inaudible]
NO WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
JACKSON.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I STERN.
ICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS.
ITEM SIXTY SEVEN CENTER MORE LOG
YOU PREPARE TO TAKE THAT ITEM.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE
.
THE HI I MISS THAT SO DO WE NEED
TO DO WEAKENED.
WERE YOU KNOW VOTE [inaudible]
PART.
SO NO STERN NO STERN NOW.
OZ THIRTY FOUR KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR MORLOCK --
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE READ I'D
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SEVEN SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR MORE
LOCK AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
AGENCY FINANCIAL REPORTING.
CENTER MORLOCK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA HAS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THE NATION.
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT WOULD
ESTABLISH THE OPEN FINANCIAL
STATEMENT COMMISSION. TO REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE REGARDING HOW
TO TRANSITION STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES.
IN PRESENTING THEIR FINANCIAL
REPORTS IN THE MACHINE READABLE
FORMAT.
IN LINE EXTENSIBLE BUSINESS
REPORTING LANGUAGE OR I. X. B.
R. L. IS BEING USED
INTERNATIONALLY FOR MANY YEARS
NOW AS AN OPEN SOURCE FINANCIAL
DATA STANDARD.
IT REDUCES TIME IN MULTIPLE
WROTE REPORT PREPARATION YOU DO
IT ONCE IN A FLOWS AND ALL THE
OTHER REPORTS YOU HAVE TO
PREPARE.
PREVENTS TYPOS ETCETERA.
IT PROVIDES TAGGING LIKE
INTERNET WEBSITES ALLOWING
IMMEDIATE SEARCH RESULTS.
IT REPLACES PDF TECHNOLOGY.
IT IS CURRENTLY USED BY THE SIX
THOUSAND PUBLICLY TRADED
CORPORATIONS THAT REPORT. TO THE
SEC.
IT IS USED BY THE FDIC AND IT'S
EIGHT THOUSAND BANK MEMBERS.
IT WILL BE GREATLY APPRECIATED
BY CREDIT RATING AGENCIES BOND
ANALYSTS INVESTMENT BROKER
DEALERS.
THIS BILL HAS ALREADY GROWN
GARNERED NATIONAL ATTENTION
RECEIVING A GOOD ARTICLE IN THE
BOND BUYER WHICH IS A NEWSPAPER
USED TO READ WHEN I WAS
TREASURER -- WHICH IS FOR THE
MUNICIPAL FIXED INCOME MARKET.
CAN YOU DIG IT [inaudible]
CONSEQUENTLY SB FIVE NINE EIGHT
WAS RECENTLY AMENDED TO MOVE THE
PROPOSED COMMISSION UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DEBTS AND INVESTMENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE CD ACT WITHIN
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
CITY ACT HAS A FUNDING SOURCE.
IT IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FINANCING AND
COINCIDENTLY OUR RULES COMMITTEE
RECENTLY MEET RECENTLY APPOINTED
ME TO SERVE ON THE CD X. SO.
THAT ALSO IS HELPFUL THIS IS AN
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS NATION'S BOND
TRANSPARENCY FRONTIER.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU OF MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MET MISTER PRESIDENT -- I JUST
WANT TO BRIEFLY RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW AS WE MOVE FARTHER AND
FOR FURTHER AND FURTHER INTO
TECHNOLOGY WE NEED TO HAVE A
MACHINE READABLE CODE I KNOW
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT MAKE
HEADLINE NEWS.
WITH THE LA TIMES OF THE AP OR
POLITICO.
BUT THEY ARE THE THINGS THAT
FORM THE BACKBONE OF INNOVATING
AND CREATING THIS LEVEL OF
INNOVATION THAT WE TALK ABOUT IN
CALIFORNIA ALL THE TIME.
BUT OFTEN FINDS ITSELF IN THE
SMALL MONDAY.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S SMALLER
MONDAY AT ALL BECAUSE IT DREW
TRANSCENDS INTO GOOD SERVICE
THINGS THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING FOR FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HI CENTER MORE LIKE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES.
FOR HIS -- APPROVAL -- HE IS
CERTAINLY A A SOFTWARE --
PIONEER HIMSELF AS SUPPORTING
BLOCKCHAIN WHICH IS -- RATHER
CUTTING EDGE A NEW THIS IS NOT
REALLY NEW.
THIS IS BEING USED AROUND THE
WORLD FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND IS
BEING USED BY OUR MAJOR
INDUSTRIES AND IT'S GONNA BE
GREAT TO GET ALL OF OUR
MUNICIPALITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
THE SAME.
AND THE REST THE COUNTRY'S
LOOKING AT US IN THIS GOING TO
BE AN EXCITING OPPORTUNITY I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SAY SHOW ME THE
MONEY MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
ALL THIS DOES A POOR UNANIMOUS
ROGOFF [inaudible]
THIRTY SEVEN ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR RUBIO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE ROUTE.
SENATE BILL SIX FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
CHILD CARE CENTER RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TODAY
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB. ONE
FOUR SIX ONE FOUR WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION GRANT
PROGRAM.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS MAKES THE GRAND.
OPERATIONAL PLAN AN
APPROPRIATION AND THE CHANGE UP
TO THE START DATE IS TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THIS
GRANT PROGRAM WAS FIRST
ESTABLISHED OF THE BUDGET AND SB
SIX ONE FOUR WOULD MAKE THE
GRANT PROGRAM ON GOING RATHER
THAN A ONE TIME ALLOCATION.
FUNDING FOR THIS GRANT PROGRAM
IMPROVES ACCESS TO INCLUSIVE
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN WITH
EXCEPTIONAL ME.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR STUDENTS ARE
NOT ALWAYS SERVED IN THE MOST
INCLUSIVE SETTINGS EVEN THOUGH
RESEARCH SUGGESTS.
THAT IT IS WHEN THEY PERFORM THE
BEST SB SIX ONE FOUR WILL
PROVIDE AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION.
THAT SERVE OUR STUDENTS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND THE MOST
INCLUSIVE SETTINGS THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ENABLE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL.
DESCRIPTION OR COMMENTS ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEN HERE NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR RUBIO.
YES AND I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
SICK BUT SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE
CALDERON TAKE ME AWAY THANK YOU.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THIS MEASURE.
SEE NINE THIRTY SEVEN ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT ON FILE.
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE SENATOR
ALSO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR RAZA AN ACT RELATING TO
CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES.
SENATOR RAZA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
JUST LAST WEEK A TWO AND A HALF
YEAR OLD TODDLER.
WHOSE FAMILY WAS APPREHENSIVE
APPREHENDED THE U. S. MEXICO
BORDER.
BECAME THE SIXTH MIGRANT CHILD
TO DIE IN US CUSTODY.
AFTER SPENDING SEVERAL WEEKS IN
THE HOSPITAL WITH PNEUMONIA AND
A HIGH FEVER.
A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD TEENAGER DIED
ON APRIL THIRTIETH ALSO WHILE IN
US CUSTODY.
THE TEENAGER DIED OF
COMPLICATIONS FROM AN INFECTION.
THE FRONTAL LOBE O HIS BRAIN.
SIX CHILDREN.
DIED IN AN EIGHT MONTH PERIOD.
THERE BEEN CONSISTENT REPORTS.
OF HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES IN THESE
DETENTION OF CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITIES.
PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL ABUSE POR
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
LITTLE ACCESS TO LEGAL COUNSEL.
OVER USE OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
AND DEATH.
OVER THE LAST YEAR OR CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR AND THE DISABLED
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
HAVE RAISED ALARM MEAN ISSUES AT
IMMIGRATION DETENTION FACILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH THEIR
REPORTS.
SINCE MARCH.
TWENTY TEN I SAYS REPORTED A
TOTAL OF EIGHTY TWO DEATHS
NATIONALLY IN ADULT CIVIL
IMMIGRATION DETENTION.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE SINCE TWENTY
LEAST. THIRTEEN DEATHS
ASSOCIATED WITH CIVIL
IMMIGRATION DETENTION.
MEDICAL EXPERTS HAVE FOUND THAT
IN TWENTY THREE CASES INADEQUATE
MEDICAL CARE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
FATALITY.
TRAGICALLY THE INCIDENT OFTEN GO
UNADDRESSED AND VICTIMS HAVE NO
RECOURSE.
SB SIX TWO TWO REQUIRES.
THE BILL DETENTION FACILITIES TO
IMMEDIATELY NOTIFY THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
ANY DEATH IN CIVIL CUSTODY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL
ASSUME JURISDICTION OVER THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE DEATH.
I WILL IMMEDIATELY OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CAUSE AND
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF DEATH.
COLLEAGUES WE NEED GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITIES.
CURRENTLY OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA NO ONE IS ABOVE THE
LAW I RESPECTFULLY ACT ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
I THINK WITH THE RAPID MOVEMENT
OF NEWS WE OFTEN.
GET A CLIP STE BY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
WE LEARNED JUST TODAY OF A SIXTH
CHILD.
WHO DIED LAST SEPTEMBER IN
CUSTODY AND THAT INFORMATION WAS
JUST RELEASED THIS WEEK?
ARM IT'S A HUMAN RIGHTS CRISIS
IT'S A HEALTH CRISIS.
IT TAX FUNDAMENTAL.
FAMILY VALUES I URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON.
SITE -- A STAND AND ALSO WANT.
TO THANK THE OFFICER THIS
MEASURE CAME TO OUR JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE REST
OF YOU BUT EVERY MORNING WE HEAR
ABOUT.
ADDITIONAL INSTANCES OF WHAT IS
GOING ON IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND I FIND MYSELF ALMOST IN
TEARS WHEN I HEAR ABOUT THE WAY
THESE HUMAN BEINGS ARE BEING
TREATED.
AND MISTREATED AND I KEEP
THINKING TO MYSELF THIS IS NOT.
THIS IS NOT MY AMERICA.
THIS IS NOT THE COUNTRY THAT HAS
WELCOMED AND ENCOURAGED AND URGE
PEOPLE TO COME TO IT. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES THE PROMISE OF
THIS GREAT NATION AND SO THE
FACT THAT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS NOT
ONLY TURNED A BLIND DIE.
BUT HAS TAKEN STEPS THAT HAVE
FURTHERED THIS KIND OF IN HUMANE
TRATMENT REALLY REQUIRES THAT
WE AS A STATE.
WE ARE BETTER THAN THIS AND THAT
WE NEED TO DEMONSTRATE AND
STEPPED FORWARD AND LEAD IN THIS
EFFORT OF HUMANITARIANISM IS
COME IN COMPASSION.
KINDNESS AND EMPATHY.
THAT'S REALLY WHO WE ARE AND
MUST BE AND IF WE CAN'T GET THIS
OUT OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND WE IS A STATE.
HAVE A STRONG RESPONSIBILITY AND
DUTY TO DO THAT AND SO I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE AN URCHIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ARE TODAY -- I'M SORRY
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU I ALSO WANT TO COMMEND
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE LOS
ANGELES FOR BRINGING THIS UP I
KNOW THAT SOMETIMES IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT. TO TO SEE THINGS ON
TV AND NOT BE ABLE TO PUT
YOURSELF IN THAT SITUATION AND
SO I JUST WANTED TO SAY. TO
EVERYONE HERE THAT PERHAPS
STRUGGLES WITH.
THE IMMIGRATION SITUATION AND
DEPORTATION SITUATION.
WE'RE NOT STRANGERS AND I SAY
THAT BECAUSE EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU HAVE TO HOUSE TO KNOW
THAT I AM. ONE OF THOSE LITTLE
KIDS THAT WERE SEPARATED AT THE
BORDER SO WE'RE NOT STRANGERS
WE'RE HERE TO CONTRIBUTE.
WE'RE HERE TO BE PART OF THIS
COMMUNITY SO I HOPE WE START
SEEING IT IN A WAY THAT.
YOU CAN RELATE TO A HUMAN BEING
STANDING IN FRONT OF YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR BILL.
BEAUTIFUL AS PRESIDENT MEMBERS
OF THE US SENATE -- SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MENTAL HEALTH WE
HAD A PRESENTATION ON OUR MENTAL
HEALTH CARCASS ON ON FROM THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS INSPECTORS
THAT WENT INTO THESE FACILITIES.
THEY HAVE A WRITTEN REPORT.
THAT I URGE ALL MEMBERS TO READ
IN SUPPORT.
OF THE LEGISLATION THIS THIS --
OF THE DETAILS IN THE PICTURES
YOU SEE IN THAT REPORT --
THERE'S NO REAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE CELLS IN THE STATE
PRISON.
AND THE CELLS THAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE PUT IN THESE
CHILDREN ARE ARE INCARCERATED
FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES.
THEY'RE TREATED LIKE PRISONERS.
THEY'RE TREATED LIKE PRISONERS
ARE NOT HANDLED IN A HUMANE WAY
THAT YOU WOULD NORMALLY HANDLE.
CHILDREN.
ADD AYE AYE REGION I WROTE ON
THIS THIS NEEDS TO BE INSPECTED
WE NEED TO PUT SOME ENERGY.
INTO THIS ISSUE AN INSPECTOR I
PLUG THE SENATOR FOR RAISING
THIS ISSUE BY INTRODUCING THIS
BILL WE SHOULD ALL SUPPORT THE
HUMAN RIGHTS.
AND DIGNITY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE YOURS AND I VOTE.
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE.
SEEN IN HEARING NINE SENATOR TO
RAZA WHICH ELECT CLOSE.
YES THERE ARE I JUST WANT TO SAY
IN RESPONSE TO A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ON THE INITIAL --
PERIOD TO MAKE THE REPORT WE ARE
LOOKING INTO THAT WITH OUR
ADVOCATE SOME FOR YOUR
INFORMATION -- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD ARE I CABALLERO
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I BROWSER[inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NOW.
MEASURES THIRTY ETS. SEVEN KNOWS
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS ITEM SEVENTY SENATOR
STERN ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS.
SOONER STERN.
FAMOUS PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
OUR BALLOT PAMPHLETS ARE PACKED
WITH USEFUL INFORMATION BUT FOR
MANY VOTERS A NINETY SIX PAGE
DOCUMENT.
WHICH IS THE LENGTH OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN GENERAL ELECTION
BALLOT PAMPHLET CAN BE
OVERWHELMING.
ULTIMATELY HIDING MORE THAN IT
ACTUALLY REVEALS.
WE NEED TO MAKE OUR ELECTIONS
ACCESSIBLE WHICH MEANS PUTTING
THE MOST CRITICAL INFORMATION
FRONT AND CENTER.
CURRENTLY PUT WE PUT.
BRIEF SUMMARY TITLE AND A FISCAL
ANALYSIS ON THE LABEL BUT A
CRITICAL PIECE OF INFORMATION IS
MISSING.
THE OFFICIAL SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION.
THAT'S WHY SB SIX THIRTY SIX
WOULD MODIFY BALLOT MEASURE
LABELS TO INCLUDE THE OFFICIAL
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF BALLOT
MEASURES.
KNOWING THE MAJOR GROUPS ON EACH
SIDE OF AN ISSUE IS A CRITICAL
TOOL VOTERS CAN USE TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS.
PUTTING OFFICIALS SUPPORT ON THE
BALLOT ALSO HELPS A ROAD THE
ELUSIVE POWER OF DARK MONEY IN
OUR POLITICS.
INSTEAD OF HIDING DEEP IN THE
PAGES OF A PAMPHLET.
THE PROPONENTS OF AN OP AND
OPPONENTS OF THE MEASURE SHOULD
BE AS CLEAR AS DAY. TO CITIZEN
CASTING THEIR VOTE.
WE TAKE SERIOUSLY THOUGH THE
CONCERNS ABOUT TRYING TO PACK
TOO MUCH INFORMATION AND ADDING
LINKS. TO AN ALREADY LIKE THE
BALLOT.
THAT'S WHY SB SIX THIRTY SIX WAS
WRITTEN TO TAKE MINIMAL
ADDITIONAL SPACE ON THE BALLOT
COMPARED TO CURRENT LAW ONLY THE
NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION THAT
SIGNED ABOUT ARGUMENT IS LISTED.
NOT ALSO THE NAME OF THE PERSON
REPRESENT ANY ORGANIZATION SO
ABBREVIATIONS LIKE CALIFORNIA OR
CERTAIN TO CA AND IT INDIVIDUAL
NAMES ARE LISTED WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION.
EXCEPT THE OFFICE THAT THEY HOLD
IF THEY'RE KERN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
RECENT AMENDMENTS MAKE SURE THAT
THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF WORDS
PERMITTED FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION IS STILL LIMITED TO
FIFTEEN PER SIDE.
WHICH GUARANTEES THAT THIS WILL
CREATE A LINK TO YOUR CUMBERSOME
ADDITION TO THE BALLOT.
MEMBERS KNOWLEDGE IS POWER.
AND THIS DISCLOSURE MEASURE
WOULD BE COMMONSENSE.
AND EMPOWER VOTERS TO FULFILL A
CITIZENS MOST SACRED OBLIGATION
THE RIGHT TO VOTE WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX THREE
SIX FAR TOO OFTEN.
THE BALLOT IMAGE MEASURES HAVE
BEEN MANIPULATED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OR OTHER AND IT AND IT
CONFUSES THE VOTERS I BELIEVE
THE MORE INFORMATION ACCURATE
INFORMATION THE VOTERS GET THE
BETTER CHOICE ARE GOING TO MAKE.
I THINK THIS IS A SMART --
COMMONSENSE REFORM THAT'S GOING
TO SERVE AS A GUIDE POST -- TO
TO VOTERS AND SO I'M A STRONG.
NINE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU IN ADDITION IT'S
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING SHE NINE SOONER STERN
SELECT CLOTHES YES THANK YOU TO
THE CENTER FOR SANTA CLARITA AND
I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
MEASURE NOT JUST FOR LIBERALS OR
CONSERVATIVES BUT FOR
INDEPENDENCE AND ANYBODY ELSE.
WHO WANTS MORE INFORMATION NOT
LESS WHEN THEY MAKE THAT
INFORMED CHOICE TO VOTE WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK DR?
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I BORDERS.
I BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I HAVE A
AUTUMN [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
JONES NO.
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible] ZERO NO
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I BY CASKEY.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
NO MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NOW.
HI IS THIRTY KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT SB FORTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR MINING SENATOR
MONEY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE REFER
[inaudible]
READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR MINING AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU I MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL.
THREE FORTY SEVEN WHICH WE
BELIEVE TO BE A PART OF A BROAD
PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGY.
A CAMPAIGN THAT SEEKS TO LIMIT.
THE HEART THE KNOWN HARMFUL
HEALTH EFFECTS OF SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
MANY OF YOU PRIVATELY ASKED ME
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS AGAIN.
YOU'VE DONE THIS BEFORE
[inaudible]
WELL.
THE EPIDEMIC CONTINUES.
AND I DON'T USE THE WORD
EPIDEMIC IS HYPERBOLE.
I USE THE WORD EPIDEMIC AS USED
BY PHYSICIANS AND SCIENTISTS.
THERE IS A NATIONAL.
EPIDEMIC.
OF PRE DIABETES SOME PREVENTABLE
TYPE TWO DIABETES.
SO WHY IS THAT LINK TO SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES.
BECAUSE THEY REPRESENT THE
SINGLE LEADING SOURCE
[inaudible]
INCREASED BAD CALORIES THAT ARE
BEING.
PROMOTED IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
PUSH ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR.
AT EVR LOWER RATES -- FOR
FAMILIES WITH TOUGH FOOD BUDGETS.
THE MARKETING OF THESE PRODUCTS.
IT BECOMES A STAPLE IN THE DIET.
NOT A WEEKEND TO TREAT
[inaudible]
THE EPIDEMIC.
OF SKYRIM SKYROCKETING
SKYROCKETING RATES OF
PREVENTABLE DIABETES.
IS PROVEN IN MEDICAL ARTICLES
FROM UC SAN FRANCISCO.
ON THE HARVARD MEDICAL SCHOOL
YALE THE RED INSTITUTE.
THE SCIENCE IS AN CONSERVE
CONTROVERSIAL.
NOW SOME OF THE OPPONENTS SAY.
WELL THERE'S DATA THAT SHOWS A
DECREASE IN THE CONSUMPTION OF
SODAS.
BUT A CONTINUED INCREASE IN
PREVENTABLE DIABETES.
THEIR THEIR PART RIGHT.
THE DECREASE IN SODA CONSUMPTION
IS BECAUSE THE PRODUCTS THAT
HAVE BEEN CAMOUFLAGED.
IS HELPFUL DRINKS FORTIES
ANARCHY DRINKS THAT ARE BEING
PUSHED IN OUR COMMUNITIES WITH
EQUAL AMOUNTS OR MORE SUGAR.
THAT WOULD ALSO HAVE THE WARNING
LABEL.
LET ME JUST MENTION SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN.
COMING OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS
THAT I THINK HELP STREAMLINE THE
BILL IN EASE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF BURDENS AT THE
RETAIL LEVEL.
AS AMENDED THE BILL EXEMPTS MILK
PRODUCTS -- AND WE'VE SEEN THE
REMOVAL OF OPPOSITION FROM THE
AG INDUSTRY THE DAIRY INDUSTRY
THE ALMOND INDUSTRY.
WE'VE ALSO MADE IT EASIER FOR
POSTING THE LABEL ON VENDING
MACHINES TO ONLY HAVE TO OCCUR
AT THE TIME THE CONTRACT ON THAT
VENDING MACHINE IS RENEWED OR
THE VENDING MACHINE IS SWITCHED
OUT.
AND AT THE RESTAURANT LEVEL WE
REQUIRE SINGLE POSTING.
THE REAL FOCUS WOULD BE ON THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER THE TWO LITER
BOTTLE IT IS BEING SOLD LESS.
FOR AN AMOUNT LESS THAN AN
EQUIVALENT AMOUNT OF MILK OR
WATER.
FRIENDS THIS IS NOT THE
INVENTION OF POLITICIANS.
THIS IS THE REALITY CONFIRMED BY
DOCTORS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES THAT'S WHY THERE'S
SUCH A STRONG COALITION OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES FROM
DOCTORS DENTISTS. TO PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS TO COACHES TO
THE PTA.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON IS THIS
VAST SOLUTION.
NO.
IS IT PART OF A BROADER PUBLIC
HEALTH STRATEGY. TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND TO PROVIDE IN
INFORMATION.
NOW IN THE PAST WITH BILLS TO
PUT A TAX ON SODAS THE
INDUSTRY'S RESPONSE RESPONDED TO
THAT CALL.
IN THE LABEL WARNING IS JUST
THAT IT'S EDUCATION.
IT'S CONSUMER RIGHT TO KNOW.
IF DOCTORS KNOW IT'S BAD FOR YOU
SHOULDN'T WE GIVE PARENTS.
THE RIGHT TO MAKE THE INFORMED
CHOICE AND AGAIN SOME SAY WELL
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT SO IT IS NOT
HELPFUL BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
CAMOUFLAGE DRINKS.
THE ONES THAT ARE STILL ON OUR
SCHOOLS.
UNDER GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER'S
LEADERSHIP WE GOT SO IT IS OUT
OF OUR SCHOOLS.
BUT THE SPORT TEASE THE ENERGY
DRINKS THE GATORADE.
THEY'VE REPLACED IT AND THEY'RE
LOADED WITH SUGARS AND THEY
WOULD ALSO CARRY.
THE LABEL THE LABEL IS DESIGNED
TO INFORM CHOICE.
WE DON'T TAKE ANYTHING OFF THE
SHELVES.
WE DON'T RESTRICT THE SALE.
WE SIMPLY SAY LET'S GIVE PEOPLE
THE RIGHT TO MAKE AN INFORMED
CHOICE.
OTHERS SAY WILL THE LABELS THEY
DON'T THEY'RE NOT AFFECTED
PEOPLE IGNORE THE LABELS.
WHERE THEY SAY WELL THE CALORIC
CONTEXTS?
CONTENTS ALREADY THERE IN THE
BACK OF THE BOTTLE IN THE SMALL
PRINT [inaudible]
WHAT FRIENDS?
BUT THE WARNING LABEL HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO DO BY MEDICAL STUDIES
PEER REVIEWED STUDIES ONE WITH.
TWO THOUSAND ADOLESCENT TEENAGE
KIDS WHERE THEY HAD A CONTROL
GROUP THAT CHOSE BEVERAGES ON
THE SHELF.
AND THEN THEY PUT LABEL WARNINGS.
AND 10% OUT OF TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED YOUNG PEOPLE.
MORE INFORMED BY THAT LABEL
WARNING.
IN MADE A HEALTHFUL CHOICE.
YOU SAY WE'LL TO HUNDREDS NOT
THAT MANY OUT OF TWO THOUSAND IF
IT'S YOUR CHILD IF IT'S YEAR
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S A START.
MANY OF YOU WERE SUPPORT OF LAST
YEAR ON THE CHILDREN'S MENU.
WE HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
THAT THE FALL OPTION MILK OR
WATER.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH EFFORT A PUBLIC
HEALTH CAMPAIGN TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO GIVE THEM THE
POWER OF INFORMED CHOICE IT'S
NOT MANY GOVERNMENT.
IT'S CONSUMER PROTECTION IT'S AN
FORMING CHOICE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE OUR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DOCTOR
PAN.
THANK YOU -- THAT MISTER
PRESIDENT -- SENATORS I JUST
WANT TO BRIEFLY -- I THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM CARMEL FOR
BRING THIS ISSUE FORWARD WE ARE
SEEING -- ARISING RIGHTS --
RATES OF DIABETES PARTICULARLY
TIED.
TWO ALMOST ALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE PRE DIABETIC
WHICH MEANS AT RISK FOR DIABETES.
AND WHILE CERTAINLY SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES ARE NOT THE
ONLY POTENTIAL SOURCE IT
CERTAINLY IS A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR.
AND SO WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS.
HEALTH CRISIS -- I THINK OF
FORMING CONSUMERS ABOUT THE
VARIETY DIFFERENT DRINKS THAT
MAY FALL UNDER IS I THINK IS
THAT LIKE IT'S GOOD AUTHOR SAID
IT'S PEOPLE MAY RECOGNIZE SODA
HE OTHER NIGHT I WAS -- ALWAYS
AWARE BUT THEY DON'T RECOGNIZE
NAY THE OTHER ONES SO AGAIN I
WOULD STAND IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
I WOULD SAY PEACE BABY VOTE FOR
THE BILL [inaudible]
ENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
LEGISLATION I WANT TO THANK --
OF THE SENATOR -- THE AUTHOR FOR
ON HIS -- TENACIOUS ADVOCACY.
NOT JUST ON THE WARNING LABEL
ISSUE BUT ON THIS GENERAL --
ISSUE.
THIS -- THIS IS INFORMATION. FOR
PEOPLE.
I'D JUST LIKE WE REQUIRE HEALTH
WARNINGS ON CIGARETTE PACKS.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE WARNED -- AND
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS IN THESE
DRINKS ONE TWELVE OUNCE CAN OF
SODA.
HAS ABOUT TEN TEASPOONS OF SUGAR
AND AT THIS IS NOT JUST LIKE
WHAT IS A LITTLE SUGAR IN THEIR
WORK TO HELP PEOPLE.
THE AMOUNT OF SUGAR IN THESE
DRINKS IS EXTRAORDINARY.
AND IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE
HEAR A RESPONSE WELL WHY ARE YOU
PUTTING MORNINGS ON ON COOKIES
ARE CAKES.
LIQUID SUGAR IS UNIQUELY HARMFUL
TO PEOPLE'S HEALTH.
LIQUID SUGAR IS MUCH MORE
QUICKLY ABSORBED INTO YOUR LIVER
LEADING THE FATTY LIVER DISEASE
WHICH ULTIMATELY LEADS TO
DIABETES AND OTHER METABOLIC
PROBLEMS.
AND UNLIKE EATING WHEN YOU'RE
DRINKING LIQUID SUGAR -- YOUR
BODY YOUR APPETITE NEVER
RECEIVED THE TO THE SINGLE TO
TURN OFF.
SO YOU CAN DRINK.
AN ABSOLUTELY ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
LIQUID SUGAR WITH AL EVEN.
HAVING YOUR HUNGER TURN OFF
UNLIKE WHEN YOU ARE EATING
SOMETHING.
SO THIS IS A UNIQUELY HARMFUL
PRODUCTS IT IS ABSOLUTELY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE EXPLOSION OF
TYPE TWO DIABETES INCLUDING
AMONG CHILDREN.
TYPE TWO DIABETES USED TO BE A
DISEASE THAT WE ASSOCIATED WITH
AGING CHILDREN ARE NOW GETTING
THIS DISEASE.
AND THIS PRODUCT THESE PRODUCTS
OR A SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR AND WE NEED TO HAVE THESE
HEALTH WARNINGS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SKINNER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU IT'S PRESIDENT THIS
BILLS ABOUT BEVERAGE CONTAINERS.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
THE INITIATIVE SHOULD BE DONE ON
A NATIONAL BASIS NOT ON JUST A
CALIFORNIA BASIS -- AND MAKING
CALIFORNIA NOT LINER A LIAR WILL
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR BUSINESSES
THAT SELL PRODUCTS [inaudible]
NATIONALLY.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF BUSINESSES
JUST TAKE THE INITIATIVE AND DO
IT ON THEIR OWN -- WE WERE
WOULDN'T BECOMING AN ADDED
BURDEN OR COSTS BUT I THINK
COLLEAGUES SAID -- MAKING
CALIFORNIA OUT WHY YOU'RE UNIQUE
AND THEN.
MAKING ANOTHER COST OF DOING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE IS MAYBE
SOMETHING WE OUGHT TO BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT AND FOR THAT
REASON -- I'M.
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT SB.
THREE FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
ON SEEN ON SENATOR MINING WHICH
LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I APPRECIATE --
THE INDULGENCE THE ENGAGEMENT
THAT I'VE HAD WITH MANY OF YOU.
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS CONCERNS --
I APPRECIATE THOSE WHO.
EMBRACE THESE EFFORTS IF I COULD
JUST COMMENT ON A CUT -- THE
LAST COMMENT -- MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM TEMECULA NO THAT'S TO MAKE
KILLER THAT SOME.
THANK YOU ORANGE COUNTY.
ABOUT CALIFORNIA BEING IN OUT
LIAR -- THERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO
LOOK AT THIS LET'S MAKE
CALIFORNIA LEADER.
OFTEN.
OUR NATIONAL POLITICS LOOK TO
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY IN THE
AREAS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION ALSO
INCLUDES PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTION THIS BILL IS ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTION --
OTHERS IN THE OPPOSITION OF SAID
WHY DO YOU PICK.
ON THESE PRODUCTS WHEN THEIR
SUGAR AND OTHER PRODUCTS -- IS
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO INDICATED SCIENCE HAS
PROVEN NOT POLITICIANS THAT
LIQUID SUGAR IS ABSORBED.
MORE RAPIDLY IT'S CONVERTED TO
FAT BY THE KIDNEYS AND PANCREAS --
WEARS SUGAR IN FOODS WELL WE
DON'T ENCOURAE THAT CONSUMPTION
EITHER -- IT'S DIGESTED
DIFFERENTLY.
FRIENDS THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO JOIN KNOWS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
COR WORK FOR WORKING TO PROTECT
AND PROMOTE.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES SOME OF OUR MOST AT
RISK COMMUNITIES UNFORTUNATELY
ARE THOSE THAT ARE THE MOST
TARGETED. FOR THE PROMOTION.
IN SALE OF SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS.
AND ALL JUST CLOSE MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
BY SAYING IMAGINE THERE'S NO
CHILDHOOD OBESITY PREVENTABLE
DIABETES OR TOOTH DECAY.
IT'S EASY IF YOU TRY.
IMAGINE WE TAKE STEPS TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTH.
IT'S EASY IF YOU TRY.
A MANSION COMMUNITIES WHERE
HEALTH PROMOTION TAKES PRIORITY.
OVER THE TREATMENT OF ILLNESS
AND DISEASE.
IT'S EASY IF YOU TRY.
YOU MAY SAY I'M A DREAMER.
BUT I'M NOT THE ONLY.
ONE I HOPE SOME DAY YOU'LL JOIN
US.
IN PRIORITIZE OUR CHILDREN'S
HEALTH.
OVER THE MONEY OF THE BIG ONES
THANK YOU.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I'M SORRY ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR AGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO [inaudible]
OUR DAUGHTER [inaudible]
JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STONE.
NO I'M BURKE [inaudible]
WILK.
SENATOR MONEY MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GONNA BE MOVING BACK TO FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SB.
TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR CAFIERO
[inaudible]
AUG [inaudible] TWENTY
FOURTEENTH OUR HIGHLY.
FOURTEEN SENATE BILL TWENTY FIVE
BY SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
SENATOR COVER YOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS FOR FOR THOSE OF NOTE
THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW ME HEY HOW
YOU UNDERSTAND MY BACKGROUND AND
AND WHY I HAVE SPENT SO MUCH
TIME WORKING ON SB -- TWENTY
FIVE I BECAME AN ATTORNEY
BECAUSE I WANTED TO WORK WITH.
WORKING FAMILIES AND I MOVED TO
SALINAS BECAUSE I WANTED TO WORK
WITH FARMWORKERS.
AND I ENDED UP IN POLITICS FOR
THE SAME REASON.
I WANTED TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN IN.
IN IN PARTICULAR FOCUSED ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS GOOD JOBS.
I BURKE TO BUILD RESILIENCY AND
HER PURSE COMMUNITIES.
BY CHANGING THE ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH PEOPLE LIVE WORK AND PLAY.
AND THAT'S ELECTED AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS WE REGULARLY HERE FROM
OUR CONSTITUENTS ABOUT PERVASIVE
POVERTY AND HARDSHIP IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
POVERTY THAT RESULTS FROM THE
LACK OF LOCAL GOOD PAYING JOBS.
POVERTY THAT TAKES AWAY AMBITION
AND HOPE.
AND POVERTY THAT LEADS TO
RESIGNATION THAT THINGS.
HAVE NO CHANCE TO IMPROVE.
SB TWENTY FIVE CREATES AN
INCENTIVE FOR GREEN SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT. FOR CRITICAL
HOUSING STATEWIDE AND FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
IT IS A MODEST ATTEMPT TO JOIN
FORCES WITH THE FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT.
DESIGNED TO FINAL AN ESTIMATED
SIX TRILLION DOLLARS FROM
CAPITAL GAINS EARNING INTO
AMERICA'S POOREST NEIGHBORHOODS.
THIS TAX INCENTIVE.
WAS THE BRAIN CHILD OF TWO
AUTHORS.
ON WHO PUT IT INTO THE FEDERAL
TAX TAX CREDIT BILL.
SENATOR CORY BOOKER FROM NEW
JERSEY AND SENATOR TIM CAUGHT
SCOTT -- BOTH WHO ARE LONG TIME
FIGHTER FIGHTERS FOR THE POOR.
HERE'S THE FRAMEWORK.
SB TWENTY FIVE ATTACKS POVERTY
IN THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE DESIGNATED OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
BY CREATING MARKET CONDITIONS
FOR PRIVATE INVESTMENT CAPITAL
TO REACH COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY CHRONIC POVERTY.
IT MAKES CALIFORNIA'S POOREST
AREAS ATTRACTIVE FOR
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUND
INVESTMENT WITHOUT COMMITTING A
DOLLAR OF LOCAL OR STATE FUNDS.
THE LACK OF ACCESS TO INVESTMENT
CAPITALS HEAPS POOR PEOPLE POOR.
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUNDS WILL
CLOSE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX SO THERE IS A
VERY SHORT WINDOW TO TAP INTO A
SIX TRILLION DOLLAR MARKET A
PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
AND SB TWENTY FIVE CARRIES A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET DATE.
SO LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IT DOES.
IT SETS THE HIGHEST
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS FOR
QUALITY PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH REQUIRE THAT ALL
CONSTRUCTION BE CONSISTENT WITH
LOCAL GENERAL PLANS.
ZONING CODES AND IT REQUIRES
LEED GOLD CERTIFICATION.
IT REQUIRES ZERO NET ENERGY.
AND IT REQUIRES ZERO NET GHG.
NONE OF OUR PROJECTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REQUIRE THIS
AS A AS A FUNCTION OF THE
DEVELOPMENT.
SB TWENTY FIVE PROTECTS AGAINST
COMMUNITY GENTRIFICATION AND
DESPITE DISPLACEMENT.
BY REQUIRING UP 275% OF THE
TOTAL SQUARE FOOTAGE IN MIXED
USE PROJECTS BE DEDICATED TO
HOUSING.
AND A MINIMUM OF 40% OF THE
UNITS BEING AFFORDABLE.
WITH A THIRTY YEAR AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS.
SB TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES A
TRAINED WORKFORCE.
AND CREATE NEW WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN IN THE GREEN
BUILDING TRADES WHICH IS A SKILL
SET THAT THE STATE DESPERATELY
NEEDS.
IT ENSURES THAT THE LABOR FORCE
IS FAIRLY COMPENSATED.
WITH PREVAILING WAGE.
AND REQUIRES LEADING AGENCIES TO
GO THROUGH THE EXACT SAME
DECISION PROCESS REGARDING THE
pTODAY.
SO THERE ARE NO CHANGES.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE.
SEQUOIA IT IS NOT AN EXEMPTION
LET ME REPEAT.
THIS IS NOT A SEQUEL EXEMPTION.
AND IT DOES NOT ALTER A SINGLE
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
UNDERSEA C<c.cyan>.</c>
SB TWENTY FIVE DOES ONLY ONE
THING.
IT GIVES PROJECTS IN THE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND HOUSING
PROJECTS FINANCED WITH TAX
PAYERS MONEY.
CERTAINTY THAT THE PROJECT WILL
NOT BE UNDULY BURDENED WITH
NIMBY LITIGATION.
SB TWENTY FIVE DOES THIS BY
SIMPLY REQUIRING THAT IF
LITIGATION IS FILED.
COURTS ARE TO REACH A FINAL
DISPOSITION WITHIN TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY DAYS OR AS SOON
THERE AFTER AS FEASIBLE.
SB TWENTY FIVE WILL DISCOURAGE
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS BECAUSE
PLAINTIFFS WILL KNOW.
THEY ARE CHALLENGING PROJECTS
THAT ARE ABOUT ALREADY MET IN IN
CREEK CREDIBLY HIGH PUBLIC
INTEREST STANDARD.
AND THAT THE SUITS WILL BE
RESOLVED IN A TIMELY MANNER
UNABLE TO KILL THE PROJECT JUST
BY CAUSING UNDUE DELAY.
SB TWENTY FIVE ALSO CREATES A
MULTIPLIER PLAYER EFFECT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLANS FOR
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS CLEARLY SET
OUT IN THE MAY BUDGET REVISED
WHERE THE GOVERNOR ALLOCATE
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
INFO INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM. TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND DEVELOPERS THAT PARTNER
TOGETHER TO BUILD CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPOSE
SUPPORT HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
LOOKING TO MAKE THE AYE BANK
MORE EFFICIENT TO SPUR
OPPORTUNITIES ON DEVELOPMENT.
AND SB TWENTY FIVE WILL HOPE TO
ENSURE THE PROJECT WITH I BEING
FUNDING.
DO NOT DIE IN LITIGATION
PURGATORY.
THE ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
CREATE JOB OPPORTUNITIES IN
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS IN ADDITION
TO HOUSING AND THAT IS WHY THE
GOVERNOR SEEKS TO INCENTIVIZE
GREEN TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS.
IN THESE COMMUNITIES WITH STATE
TAX CREDIT CONFORMITY. TO THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM.
THIS COULD GENERATE BILLIONS OF
NEW REVENUE THAT WILL BE MATCHED
WITH THE INFLUX INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM.
SB TWENTY FIVE AMPLIFIES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OPPORTUNE
OPPORTUNITIES OWN PLANS AND
MAKES CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE FOR
THIS PIVATE CAPITAL THAT ARE
POOR COMMUNITIES DESPERATELY
NEED.
PRIVATE INVESTORS COULD INCLUDE
WEALTHY INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUALS
BUT IT ALSO COULD INCLUDE PUBLIC
PENSION FUNDS MEANING THE
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS COULD VERY
WELL BE INVESTORS IN
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUNDS.
THAT COULD HELP TO REBUILD
CALIFORNIA'S POOREST COMMUNITIES.
I AM COMMITTED TO INCREASING THE
HOUSING SUPPLY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO BRING
AFFORDABILITY TO THE HOUSING
MARKET.
I'M ALSO COMMITTED TO TACKLING
DECADES OF INSUFFERABLE POVERTY
FOR THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE CENSUS TRACKS THAT
ARE CALIFORNIA'S POOREST HOUSING
AND JOB POOR COMMUNITIES.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS OPPORTUNITY
ZONES I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION HERE TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON'S.
YES THANK YOU A MISS PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES WHILE I APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS AND THE DESIRES
ARTICULATED BY THE AUTHOR THIS
BILL THIS IS A BILL THAT
BASICALLY IS JUST GOING TO BLOW
UP SEQUEL.
IT TALKS ABOUT OPPORTUNITY ZONES
WHICH COULD BE ALMOST ANYTHING
SO IF WE'RE PREPARED TO SEE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TURN INTO
MIAMI BEACH.
THAN VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
PROBLEM THIS BILL TRIES TO
ADDRESS AND THERE IS A PROBLEM.
IS NOT.
THROUGH SEQUEL.
WE KNOW THAT WHEN YOU START
PRIORITIZING THESE.
THESE BILLS AND FAST TRACKED
THEM THAT OTHER PRIORITIES THAT
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED IN THE
STATES FOR THE COURTS.
BECOME SECONDARY.
WHETHER IT'S MEDICAL MALPRACTICE
OR ELDER ABUSE OR A RESTRAINING
ORDERS IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES THEY'RE ALL GOING TO GET
PUSHED BACK.
OPPORTUNITIES JONES AS I
MENTIONED ARE COULD BE ANYTHING
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT A
LIMITED HOUSING TRACT.
OPPORTUNITY ZONES MEAN THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE -- CREATING
THIS FAST TRACK IGNORING SEQUEL
REQUIREMENTS REMEMBER.
SEE QUIRK IS THE ONLY.
PLANNING.
THE VICE.
THAT IS THE TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THE
PROJECT.
THAT'S WHAT SEE WHAT IS.
THAT IS THE ONLY CONSIDERATION
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT COMES UNDER
SEQUEL.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING HERE IS WE ARE
GOING TO IGNORE OR WE ARE GOING
TO CIRCUMVENT ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSIDERATIONS?
AND WHILE I APPRECIATE THAT WE
HAVE NEEDS IN THE STATE. TO GET
RID OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSIDERATIONS RUNS CONTRARY I
BELIEVE TO THE WILL OF
CALIFORNIANS.
SO.
WHILE I APPRECIATE WE HAVE WORK
TO DO. TWO OF THIS CHARADE
SEQUEL IS SIMPLY NOT THE RIGHT
WAY TO GO IN WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY.
ORIGIN OVERLOOKED.
SENATOR ALSO.
YES -- TO MY SENT -- SENATOR
FROM SALINAS.
MY CONCERNS ARE VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE SENATOR FROM SANTA
BARBARA RAISED AN YESTERDAY I
VOTED FOR A BILL.
THAT DID MAKE ALLOWANCES FOR
SEQUEL.
UP BECAUSE IT WAS VERY IN MY
OPINION NARROW AND IT WAS
FOCUSED.
THIS IS WAY WAY BEYOND THAT.
THIS IS ALL OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
ZONES AND WHEN I FIRST LOOKED.
I WAS UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT
IT WAS FOR HOUSING.
BUT AS WE LOOK MORE INTO IT AS I
DID.
I REALIZE THIS IS FOR EVERY
SINGLE KIND OF PROJECT IN EVERY
SINGLE OPPORTUNITIES OWN.
THAT IS I THINK GOING.
PAST THE LINE AND I BELIEVE THAT
IN YOUR HEART YOU ARE REALLY
DOING THIS FOR ALL THE RIGHT
REASONS WE HAVE TO DO MORE
DRAMATIC THINGS.
BUT I THINK TAKING IN
[inaudible]
AWAY.
THIS AS A PROTECTION FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE POOR
COMMUNITIES ARE THE ONES WHO
SUFFER.
ENORMOUSLY FROM CONTAMINATION
AND OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
TO TAKE IT AWAY FROM POOR
COMMUNITIES IS ALSO A DIS
SERVICE TO THEM.
I WAS I REMEMBER I LED.
UP PIECE OF LEGISLATION YEARS
AGO WHICH WAS THE FIRST TIME.
THAT WE DID DO AN EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW ON A PROJECT OF
OF SEQUEL -- AND I BELIEVE VERY
MUCH THAT THERE IS A PLACE AND A
TIME TO DO THAT.
UP BUT I UNDER UNFORTUNATELY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS TRYING TO
COVER EVERYTHING TOO MUCH.
AND EVERYTHING FROM STADIUMS AND
HOTELS.
TO SOME HOUSING YOU NAME IT AND
I THINK THAT'S GOING TOO FAR
THANK YOU.
SENATOR WHY BECAUSE THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I A TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION I WAS A NO VOTE IN
VIRAL CALL THE IN A NO VOTE IN A
JUDICIARY I DO WANT.
TO APPLAUD THE AUTHOR YOU HAVE
TAKEN LOTS OF AMENDMENTS ON THIS
BILL THE ZERO NET ENERGY -- TO
ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THAT LEADS GOLD CERTIFIED -- THE
CHALLENGES THE EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW THIS IS YOU KNOW
THIS IS THE BIG ENCHILADA OF OF
IT AND THERE'S EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE OPPORTUNITY SONS
WHEN WE DO THESE.
OR WELL PUBLICIZED -- THE
STADIUM BILLS YOU HAVE ONE
STADIUM YOU HAVE ONE SECRET
DOCUMENT YOU HAVE ONE POTENTIAL.
LAWSUIT YOU HAVE ONE POTENTIAL
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW NOW
YOU HAVE A POTENTIALLY.
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES THAT MAY HAVE
EXPEDITE OR WILL BE AVAIL THE
AVAILED TED EXPEDITED A JUDICIAL
REVIEW AND THAT'S MY CONCERN
THAT'S WHY I WILL.
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE BILL --
TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE.
I WAS CENTER WINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT OFF
HERE IN THE CORNER -- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- I I
RESPECT OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
DO SAYS ONE A RESPOND A COUPLE
POINTS OF MY OF MY GOOD COLLEGE
SANTA BARBARA MADE.
THIS IS NOT EVISCERATES --
SEQUEL THIS IS AN EXPEDITED
REVIEW IT DOES NOT IF HISTORY --
SIKORA IF IT WERE IN DISARRAY
SEQUEL I WOULDN'T BE SUPPORTING
IT -- IN ADDITION THIS IS NOT
GOING TO RESULT IN ANY PLACE IN
MIAMI BEACH -- EXITING
CALIFORNIA BECOMING MIAMI BEACH
THIS IS NOT ABOUT HIGHER LIMITS
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WHERE YOU CAN
BUILD.
THIS IS ABOUT AREAS THAT ARE
ZONED FOR ACTS WIRES THE HAVING
AN EXPEDITED REVIEW THAT'S WHAT
IT'S ABOUT.
AND SO -- I GOT AYE AYE PEOPLE
OF I THINK CAN DISAGREE ON THIS
BILL -- BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT NOT TO OVERSEE -- WHAT
THE BILL DOES THANK YOU?
SENATOR DODD.
MISTER -- PRESENT I'M NOT GONNA.
THE FURTHER THIS DEBATE MUCH
MORE BUT I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
STAND -- WITH MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL LAST YEAR I BOTH.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE.
HEARING SEEN ON SENATOR COVER
YOU ARE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES MISTER PRESIDENT I PROBABLY
SHOULD ADOPT MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SAN FRANCISCO'S -- CLOSED --
QUITE FRANKLY THIS IS A WAY FOR
US TO GET.
COMPETING WITH THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY ON THE SIDE THIS
OPPORTUNITIES ON MONEY AND THE
MORE CERTAINTY THAT WE CAN
CREATE. FOR DEVELOPERS TO BRING
THEIR MONEY.
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
MORE OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO
ACTUALLY INVEST IN OUR POOREST
COMMUNITIES -- AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
NO FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD ARE AYE CABRERA.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THEY'RE AWESOME [inaudible]
NO GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WAS SO.
I THOUGHT OF I JACKSON
[inaudible]
NO JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
NO MCGUIRE [inaudible]
NO MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WAKE OWSKI.
NO WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
AUGUST TWENTY SEVEN NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS NEXT REMOVING CHIU FILE
ITEM.
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR GLAZER SB SIX
TWO ONE MOUNT SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
CENTER GLAZER THANK THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
SB SIX TWENTY ONE WOULD PROVIDE
JUDICIAL STREAMLINING. TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
THAT MEET CERTAIN ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS.
THIS BILL WOULD DO FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHAT WE HAVE
DONE HERE IN THE SENATE. FOR
BILLIONAIRES IN THEIR SPORTS
ARENAS.
AND EVEN FOR OUR OWN LEGISLATIVE
PARKING STRUCTURE.
DURING HIS STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS GOVERNOR NEWSOME SAID
QUOTE IN RECENT YEARS WITH THE
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW ONE
SEQUEL FOR PROFESSIONAL SPORTS.
IT'S TIME WE DO THE SAME THING
FOR HOUSING.
SB A SIX TWENTY ONE GETTING BACK
TO MY WORDS FINALLY DOES JUST
THAT.
AS WE HAVE HEARD IN THE PREVIOUS
DEBATE THE CALIFORNIA VINYL
QUALITY ACT IS THE HALLMARK OF
CALIFORNIA'S DEDICATION TO
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND OUR STATE'S BROADEST
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW.
THIS BILL OF HOLDS ALL OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS AND
REVIEWS AND SYKORA.
DOES NOT LIMIT THE PUBLIC'S
ABILITY TO OBJECT TO PROJECTS
UNDER SYKORA.
TOWARDS A GRANT ANY NEW
EXEMPTION.
THE SEQUEL.
PROCESS OF PUBLIC INPUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT AND THE ABILITY TO
CHALLENGE A PROJECT.
ALL REMAIN INTACT.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ESTABLISHES A
SET PERIOD IN WHICH A COURT
OVERSEEING A SECRET CHALLENGE.
ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT
MUST BE COMPLETED.
IN FACT THIS BILL ADDS A HIGHER
STANDARD FOR THOSE PROJECTS
UNDER SB SIX TWENTY ONE THOSE
PROJECTS MUST BE INFILL PROJECTS
CLOSE TO MAJOR TRANSIT.
AND NEED THE EQUIVALENT OF A
LEAD GOLD STANDARD.
REGARD TO PROTECTION OF THE
ENVIRONMENT.
DEVELOPERS HAVE TO PROVIDE A
MINIMUM OF 30% OF THE PROJECT AS
AFFORDABLE.
AND THEY MUST AGREED WITH THIRTY
YEAR AFFORDABILITY COMMITMENT.
AND OF COURSE THEY CANNOT BUILD
ON LAND DESIGNATED AS HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREAS.
THERE CONTINUES TO BE
DISCUSSIONS IN THIS BILL WAS
STAKEHOLDERS.
INCLUDING THE ALLOWANCE OF
COMMERCIAL ELEMENTS IN
AFFORDABLE PROJECTS TO MAKE THEM.
FEASIBLE TO ACTUALLY CONSTRUCT.
STREAMLINING PROCESS CREATED BY
SB SIX TWENTY ONE CREATES MORE
LEGAL CERTAINLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS.
WILL ADVANCING THE KIND OF
PROJECTS STATE IS FOUND TO BE
INCLUSIVE AND SAFE. FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A COALITION
HOUSING ADVOCATES NONPROFITS AND
BUSINESS GROUPS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SOONER ACOSTA.
MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE MEASURE -- THE
SIX THIS THIS MEASURE VOTED NO
IN AN ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND
ALSO AN ISSUE ONCE AGAIN THIS
TAKES.
A BIG JUMP ON ALL HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT GO THROUGH THE
SECRET PROCESS YOU KNOW WE'VE
SAID TIME AND AGAIN THAT THE
ONLY OPPORTUNITY THAT THE PUBLIC
CAST OBJECT.
TO THAT THE PROJECT IS TO FILE A
LAWSUIT AND WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE FORCING EVERY HOUSING
PROJECT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE A FINAL
JUDICIAL DETERMINATION IN TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS IS JUST.
WHO DO JUSTICE WE DON'T AND THE
COURTS CANNOT POSSIBLY GET
THROUGH THE DAY THE DETAIL OF OF
INFORMATION WHETHER IT'S A
NEGATIVE DECK WARRANTY AYE AYE
COMPLETE E. R. R. TAKES SPLIT
EXPECT THEM TO DO THIS ON EVERY
HOUSING?
PROJECT IS JUST TOO MUCH HI BUT
DON'T -- A QUESTION THAT THE
AUTHORS DETERMINATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS BUT THIS IS JUST SIMPLY
NOT THE WAY. TO DO IT OUR COURTS
ARE GOING TO GET CRUSHED UNDER
THIS AND I REGION I VOEPEL NOVO.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF IT
ON THE SIDE OF SENATOR JACKSON.
YES -- NOT TO BELABOR THE POINT
WE'LL KEEP ON TRUCKIN BUT THIS
BILL.
APPLIES INSTANCES IN THE
ANALYSIS TO AN UNKNOWN.
NUMBER OF FUTURE PROJECTS WITH
UNKNOWN IMPACTS.
SINCE THE PROJECTS ARE UNDEFINED
IT'S DIFFICULT TO EVALUATE THEIR
MERITS MUCH LESS WHETHER THOSE
MERITS JUSTIFY.
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT THIS IS
OPENING A MASSIVE HOLE IN THE
WHOLE PROCESS PERHAPS I WAS
SPEAKING TO STRONGLY TO SAY THIS
WILL OF THIS RATE SEQUEL.
BUT I WILL BET YOU THAT THIS
KIND OF CONTINUED EFFORT WILL
INDEED EVISCERATE SYKORA AND
ALTHOUGH WE MAY NOT LOOK LIKE
MIAMI BEACH TOMORROW IF WE KEEP
DOING THIS WE WILL LOOK LIKE
MIAMI BEACH IN THE FUTURE --
INTO THE GOOD PEOPLE OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
YOU SEEN WHAT HAPPENS WITH
RAMPANT GROWTH.
WE'RE GOING TO START SEEING THIS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WITHOUT
OUR ABILITY TO DO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS AS THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES
POINTED OUT.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO TO HELP
THE UNDERSERVED WILL HURT THEM?
NOT HELP THEM AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REGIONAL VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
SENATOR DEALERS OR TO LIKE CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I THINK IT'S ALL OF US
ARE AWARE WE HAVE A HOUSING
PROBLEM IN THE STATE.
AND THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS WE'RE
WORKING TO TRY TO DEAL WITH IT.
THIS BILL IS ONLY FOCUSED ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NOT ALL
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SOMETHING WHICH I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE.
THERE WAS A REPORT ISSUED -- I
GUESS MAYBE LESS THAN TWO YEARS
AGO BY OUR ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE.
THAT ANALYZE THE CHALLENGES --
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD ON
THE ISSUE OF SEQUEL TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE IS IT A BIG PROBLEM
OR IS IT A LITTLE PROBLEM.
AND THE CONCLUSION THAT THAT
COMMITTEE REACH WAS THAT IT'S A
VERY SMALL PROBLEM.
THAT ONLY A FRACTION OF THE
CHALLENGES ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS.
ARE ON THE ISSUE OF SEQUEL.
SO THE SUGGESTION THIS IS GOING
TO CLOG THE COURTS I THINK HIS --
MASSIVELY OVERBLOWN.
IN FACT THE HOPE WOULD BE THAT
THERE WOULD BE FEW CHALLENGES --
UNDER THE EFFORT THAT WE'RE ALL
PUTTING IN TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BUT IF THERE IS WE'RE
SIMPLY ASKING NOT THAT THE COURT
EGGMAN OR THE ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS AND RULES.
BUT THEY EXPEDITE THE REVIEW IT
DOESN'T PUT A THUMB ON THE SCALE
OF JUSTICE ON ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER IT'S SIMPLY SAYS RESOLVE
THE ISSUE.
IN TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAYS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT TO BUILD
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
STATE IS NOT GOING TO REQUIRE.
SIMPLY THE ACT OF OUR BUDGET
THAT WE CAN FIND AND AND BY OUR
WAY OUT OF THAT PROBLEM.
IT'S GONNA REQUIRE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO INVEST IN THESE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
TAKE THE RISK AND THE CHANCE.
OF THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE KNOW WE NEED TO BE INVESTED
IN BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THAT WILL ONLY COME FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS INCLUDING.
SOME ELEMENT OF CERTAINTY THAT
WHATEVER THAT IS IS ON THE
PROJECT THEY CAN GET RESOLVED IN
A TIMELY WAY.
WHEN A PROJECT GOES TO THE
SEQUEL PROCESS?
IT'S NOT JUST ALL ABOUT.
SIX IT'S A GOVERNING
JURISDICTION REVEALING IT AND
MAKING CHOICES CITY COUNCIL'S
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS LOOKING AT
ALL THE ISSUES AOUND A PROJECT
INCLUDING THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENT AND MAKING A JUDGMENT.
I CHALLENGE ON SEQUEL IN MOST
CASES UNDER THIS BILL WILL BE
AFTER THAT JURISDICTION'S
DECIDED THAT THAT AFFORDABLE
PROJECT IS.
THOUGHTFULLY DONE REASONABLE
NECESSARY IT COMPLIES WITH THE
QUOTE.
THIS BILL ONLY DEALS WITH THE
CHALLENGES.
AND IN SOME CASES IT'S ARGUED
THEIR RARE.
BUT ITS FOCUS IS ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH HIGHER
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS.
I THINK IT'S DESERVING OUR
SUPPORT TODAY AND I ENCOURAGE
AND I'VE OF THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES.
I FELL.
GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
NO GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
NO JONES.
I MET LEYVA [inaudible]
NO MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
BYE BYE CASKEY [inaudible]
NO WIENER [inaudible]
I WILL [inaudible]
I I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
STERN.
HI AGE TWENTY NINE KNOWS FIVE
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GOING BACK TO FILE
ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO SENATOR LABOR ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP TO
SADDAM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
THREE SENATE BILL SIX NINETY
EIGHT BY SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
[inaudible]
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS STARTING IN
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
HUNDREDS OF LOW WAGE WORKERS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WILL WEEKS AND EVEN MONTHS
WITHOUT RECEIVING THEIR
PAYCHECKS.
THIS OUTRAGEOUS TO LAY IN WAIT
REGIS WAS THE RESULT OF THE
DISASTROUS IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
UC PATH PAYROLL SYSTEM.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF MISSED LATE
OR INCORRECT PAYCHECKS HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING FOR WORKERS AT THE
UC.
SB SIX NINETY EIGHT SIMPLY AMEND
SECTION TWO ZERO FOUR OF THE
LABOR CODE TO REQUIRE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
FOLLOW THE SAME RULES AS PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS.
AND ENCOURAGES UNIVERSITY
ADMINISTRATORS TO PRIORITIZE THE
ACCURATE TIMELY AND FEAR PAYMENT
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES.
RECENT AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT
THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE PAY
SCHEDULES ALREADY IMPLEMENTED AT
UC GREATLY REDUCING THE COST OF
SB NINETY EIGHT SIX NINETY EIGHT
IMPLEMENTATION.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
AND UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN BOTH
THE SENATE LABOR AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES.
SB SIX NINETY HAS NO OPPOSITION
I WOULD ENSURE THAT WORKERS AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE THE SAME WAGE AND HOUR
PROTECTIONS THAT WORKERS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CURRENTLY ENJOY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SENATOR ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE SIDE ON JEAN ON IT.
IS THE CANDIDATE THAT --
ELIGIBLE -- FOR UNITS ROLL CALL
ANY OBJECTION TO USING UNITS
ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE OF HEARING
CHAIN. NINE THIRTY SEVEN FIVE
ZERO KNOWS MEASURE PASSES.
EXCEPT IS FILE ITEM. SEVENTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
DISPENSED SEVENTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR SENATOR NELSON MOUNT
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL ONE NINETY THREE BY
SENATOR NELSON AN ACT RELATING
TO NITROUS OXIDE SOONER NIELSEN.
THIS PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE WE KIND OF HAVE A QUIET.
PLAGUE AMONGST US.
NOT OFTEN MENTIONED.
BUT VERY MUCH ALIVE AND VERY
DEVASTATING.
THE PLAGUE IS ALIVE.
THE VICTIMS MAY NOT BE.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS.
RETAILERS OF THE SO CALLED
TOBACCO SHOPS [inaudible]
SMOKE SHOPS.
FROM SELLING NITROUS OXIDE OXIDE
CANISTERS.
NOW THESE CANISTERS ARE
[inaudible]
SOMEWHAT DECEPTIVE.
THEY'RE SOLD WHEREAS.
AS FAR AS THE DISPENSING
MECHANISM IS CALLED A CRACKER.
THAT'S AN INDUSTRIAL CREAM
DISPENSER TO PUT THE CREAM ON
YOUR THE ICE CREAM OR YEAR.
BUDGET [inaudible]
BUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING AS
MODIFYING THESE.
CANISTERS WHICH SIMPLY.
BECAUSE THE NITROUS OXIDE
[inaudible] TO BE [inaudible]
INGESTED.
BY THE USER AS TO HOW THEY
DESIGN [inaudible]
THE CANISTER.
THE CALL WEAPONS.
THIS IS THE NITROUS OXIDE.
AND I AM CERTAINLY NO MEDICAL
EXPERT BUT IT IS USED IN
[inaudible]
SEDATION.
THERE ARE SAFE USE.
BUT IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
THERE'S ALMOST AN UNLIMITED
ABILITY.
OF THE USER [inaudible]
THE CONSUMER [inaudible]
THESE [inaudible]
LITTLE VIALS.
OF NITROUS OXIDE. ONE MOTHER
FROWNED OVER.
TWO HUNDRED FROM ONE DAYS USE.
IN HER SON'S CAR.
AND WE'RE AWARE OF SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE.
PEOPLE HAVE GONE IN.
TO PURCHASE THESE CANISTERS.
JUST TO LEARN ABOUT HOW THIS
SORDID BUSINESS WORKS.
AND THEY PURPOSEFULLY ASK.
IS THERE ANYTHING I NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS.
END OF PREPARE.
SAID WELL YES NO CHIU NEED SOME
MORE.
IN OTHER WORDS ONE BOX.
IS NOT ENOUGH.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO MEET
[inaudible]
YOUTH.
WHO HAD THIS [inaudible]
SEVERAL ADDICTION.
THE ONE WHO MIGHT ENJOY IT.
IT MUST BE A RATHER SAD.
MOMENT OF JOY BECAUSE IT DOES
NOT LAST.
AS MANY OTHER DRUGS WILL PERSIST.
GIVEN YOUR HIGH THIS DOES NOT.
IT IS VERY [inaudible]
TEMPORARY.
BUT THE INGESTION.
CAN VERY SERIOUSLY.
DAMAGE THE BRAINS [inaudible]
COMPLETELY DEBILITATE
[inaudible]
THE USER.
IT NOW IT IS.
ILLEGAL TO INHALE THESE
CANISTERS.
BUT WHO WILL ENFORCE.
WHEN THE PERSON NOT JUST YOU?
THE PERSON.
ACQUIRED THAT CANISTER
[inaudible]
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
SO I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. TO HELP
MAKE THIS DISASTER.
MUCH LESS AVAILABLE. TO ALL OF
US WHO MIGHT BE TEMPTED. TO HAVE
THAT DISASTROUS.
IN ALL TO TEMPORARY [inaudible]
HI.
VIRGIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM [inaudible]
SENATOR GALGIANI.
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR DOES THIS
MEAN IF THESE CANISTERS ARE USED
WRONG THEY CAN GO UP IN SMOKE.
SENATOR NELSON WHEN YOU TAKE A
QUESTION FROM ALL I MEAN I WOULD
JUST A LET'S WEAPON.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO
SUFFICIENT PLUS WEAPON.
WITH A GOOD [inaudible] ONE
WEAPON.
ALL RIGHTS HERE DOES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK THAT'S SUFFICIENTCLOSED.
ALL RIGHT.
THESE CALL THE ROLL.
ALWAYS UNANIMOUS -- YES.
THIRTY SEVEN ZERO ANY OBJECTIONS
TO USING UNITS ROLL CALL.
SEEN HERE NINE THIRTY SEVEN ZERO
MEASURE PROCESS.
THANK YOU NEXT UP CENTER NIELSEN
ITEM.
SEVENTY FIVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR NELSON AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIME STATISTICS.
DINNER NIELSEN MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES.
THIS.
IS ABOUT INFORMATION.
VERY NECESSARY INFORMATION THAT
WE DO NOT NOW [inaudible]
HALF.
IT REQUIRES IT THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO INCLUDE IN THEIR
JUSTICE JUSTICE STATISTICS THAT
THEY PUT OUT EACH YEAR.
THE DATA RELATED LEWD AND
LASCIVIOUS OFFENSE. TO BE
INCLUDED.
IN THEIR ANNUAL REPORT.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
[inaudible]
EVERY YEAR.
PUTS OUT A LOT OF DATA FOR US.
VEHICLE THEFT.
LARCENY OR COLLUDED.
SOME MORE SERIOUS.
BUT LEWD AND LASCIVIOUS ACTS
AGAINST CHILDREN.
IS NOT REPORTED.
THESE ARE OF THE WORST.
CRIMES PERPETRATED ON THE MOST
[inaudible]
VULNERABLE.
AND SOME OF THESE PREDATORS
[inaudible]
GROOM.
AND SEEK OUT.
THEIR TARGETS OF OPPORTUNITY.
WITH OUR USE [inaudible] TO
CONDUCT.
THEIR INSIDIOUS PREDATIONS.
IT'S A LIFETIME SENTENCE LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN.
SADLY MOST OF THE PERPETRATORS.
WE'LL NEVER SEE A LIFE IN PRISON
SENTENCE.
BUT THAT CHILD [inaudible]
CHAU ABUSE.
IS PERMANENTLY DAMAGED
[inaudible] FOR LIFE
[inaudible]
WE MUST [inaudible]
STOP.
NOW AGAIN WE PURSUE LEGISLATION
AND I'VE AUTHORED MANY OF BILLS
RELATED TO THIS.
INCLUDING HELPING RIGHT THE
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
STATUTE THAT ALLOWED CIVIL
COMMITMENT. TO KEEP SUCH
INDIVIDUALS.
IN CUSTODY [inaudible]
MUCH LONGER.
BUT WE NEED TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
BODY AND THE NUMBERS OF
INCIDENTS.
THE PLAGUING [inaudible]
OUR STATE [inaudible]
AND HARMING [inaudible]
PARTICULARLY [inaudible]
OUR YOUTH [inaudible]
MR DISTRICTS.
BUT I THINK CONSCIENCE AWAKENING
STATISTICS LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
I WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE SO
THAT WE MAY KNOW.
AND THEN BETTER AND MORE
POSITIVELY RESPOND THAN WITH US
FOR HALF.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE SIDE ON
KERN SEEN NINE IT'S ACCOUNTED
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION USING ANNOUNCED
ROLL CALL ON THIS MEASURE.
THIRTY SEVEN EYES ZERO KNOWS THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON NOW TO
ITEM.
SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR GALGIANI
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS
MEASURE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR GALGIANI AN ACT RELATING
TO INCARCERATED PERSONS.
SENATOR FOR GEORGE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SB FIVE
NINETY ONE AUTHORIZES A
PRACTICING PSYCHIATRIST.
OR PSYCHOLOGIST FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS OR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO HAVE PROMPT AND UNIMPEDED
ACCESS TO AN INMATE.
WHO IS TEMPORARILY HOUSE AT A
COUNTY CORRECTIONAL FACILITY A
COUNTY MEDICAL FACILITY OR A
STATE ASSIGNED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER?
AS WELL AS THEIR RECORDS FOR THE
PERIOD OF CONFINEMENT AT THAT
FACILITY IN ORDER TO COMPLETE A
MENTALLY DISORDERED OFFENDERS
EVALUATION. TO ENSURE THAT
ARE PROPERLY EVALUATED AND
TREATED PERCENT TO PENAL CODE
SECTION TWENTY NINE SIXTY TWO IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT PSYCHOLOGISTS
AND PSYCHIATRISTS EMPLOYED BY.
CDC ARE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INMATES HEALTH RECORDS AND
TO THE INMATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RIVAL -- HIS -- ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS SENATOR
NELSON.
ESPECIALLY GENERAL CENTER I
WOULD URGE.
AND I VOTE.
AND ONE OF THE ASPECTS.
OF THIS [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
LITIGATION PERFECT. TO ALL
ENSURE THAT.
ADVOCATES FOR INMATES
INCARCERATED UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
DO NOT GET OUT ON TECHNICALITY
WHAT WITH THE TECHNICALITY.
THAT THERE WERE NOT
PROFESSIONALS IN THESE LOCAL
INSTITUTIONS. TO PROPERLY
EVALUATE.
AND TREAT THEM.
I'M PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH THIS
AND I HAVE SEEN.
SUCH PROVISIONS AND IN FACT PUT
HIM IN MYSELF.
IN LEGISLATION TO LITIGATION
PROOF CRIMINAL JUSTICE MATTERS.
AND IT DOES SUCCEED IN SOME
CASES FOLLOW US SUPREME COURT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL.
DO NOT DISCOUNT IT AND IT WILL
BE HELPFUL TO OUR LOCAL JAILS.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OF A CENTER GALGIANI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU THIS ITEM IS ALSO
AVAILABLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF
USING A YOU NATURAL CALL ON THIS
ROGER.
SCENE NINE MEASURE PASSES THIRTY
SEVEN EYES YOU ZERO KNOWS.
MEMBERS IF THERE'S ANY OBJECTION
WILL BE TAKING UP SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY RATHER
THAN TOMORROW AND IT WILL TAKE
UP.
TO GALLAGHER AFTER THE REGULAR
ORDER OF BUSINESS TODAY IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO THAT.
SEEN A HEARING ON THE IT WILL WE
WE WILL BE TAKING UP TO SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
SEVENTY ART WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE SENATOR
REID RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THIS MATTER.
MATTER YES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL.
THE I MEAN I READ PLEASE READ.
THE BILL SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
HOMELESSNESS DINNER RUBIO.
THANK YOU HAVE PRESIDENTE
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN A BILL TO
INCREASE THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
EQUITY OF HOMELESS POLICIES BY
INCLUDING COLLEGE STUDENTS.
VETERANS AND PARENTS WITH LIFT%
HOMELESS EXPERIENCES AND THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS CRISIS THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCIAL COUNCIL SERVICES AS
THERE IS A STATE WIDE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT RESOURCE.
ON ANY IN THE HOME THIS CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA THE COUNCIL IS
MADE UP OF SEVENTEEN MEMBERSHIP
REPRESENTING GOVERNMENT AND
STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATIONS IN
ONLY TWO MEMBERS WITH LIVED
HOMELESS EXPERIENCES ONE
FORMALLY HOMELESS PERSON AND ONE
FORMERLY YOUTH UP PERSON.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE INCLUDE A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND A VETERAN
AND A FORMERLY HOMELESS PARENT
AS WELL ON THE COUNCIL SO THEY
CAN PROVIDE THE UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE.
THE ACCOUNT FOR A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THE STATE'S TOTAL
HOMELESS POPULATION.
SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE AND
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YEAH
I PULLED THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
JEANNIE HEARING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD HI I HAVE A A I
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THEY'RE AWESOME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I BROWN [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I'VE STONE.
I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible] FIVE WILK
[inaudible]
HI.
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY NIELSEN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I THIRTY FOUR KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES BERMAN OUR MOVING
BACK CHIU FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SENATOR BORDERS ARE YOU PREPARED
TO TAKE UP.
THIS MEASURE.
MANAGER TERRY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX OH THREE BY
SENATOR GORGEOUS AN ACT RELATING
TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS CENTER
BORDERS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT -- COLLEAGUES SB SIX
OF THREE DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
PERFORM ONE OF ITS CORE
FUNCTIONS RE REGULATION.
INEFFICIENT AND TIMELY MANNER
FOR SMALL RURAL TELEPHONE
COMPANIES.
RANGING IN SIZE FROM LESS.
THAN THREE HUNDRED CUSTOMERS TO
OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND FOR
DECADES THE COMMISSION HANDLED
THE RAPE CASES ON THE SMALL VERY
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANIES.
THROUGH THE ADVICE LETTER
PROCESS TYPICALLY TAKING LESS
THAN A YEAR FROM THE FILING TO
THE FINAL COMMISSION VOTE.
SB SIX OH THREE SIMPLY RESTORES
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE ADVICE
LETTER PROCESS FOR SMALL
TELEPHONE COMPANY.
RATE CASES AND CODIFIES TIME
LINES FOR THE COMMISSION'S
PROCESSING OF THEM.
SB SIX OH THREE WILL HOPEFULLY
RESTORE A MORE EFFICIENT COST
EFFECTIVE AND TIMELY PROCESS FOR
BOTH THE COMMISSION AND THE
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
THIS MEASURES ELIGIBLE
[inaudible]
FOR I'M SORRY.
IT'S ALL I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
CENTER NIELSEN GREAT AT THIS
PRESENT LAYS DOWN THE SENATE I
PROBABLY REPRESENTED MORE OF
THESE SMALL.
TELEPHONE COMPANIES THAN ANYBODY
WOODS REPRESENTING NINETEEN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES THERE
INTERESTING LITTLE ENTITIES.
THE STORE I COULDN'T VERY
SIGNIFICANT IN OUR HISTORY.
IN A REMINDED OF A SATURDAY
NIGHT LIVE.
SOLILOQUY WERE WONDERING A DAY
TO RING A DING A THREE RING
GETTING AS WELL LET'S KEEP THOSE
RATING IS GOING [inaudible]
SENATOR CHIANG.
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
THE NEW BOARD IS WOULD YOU TO
QUESTION.
NO.
OKAY.
WE REFUSE YES A CORD YES YES.
HOW FAR OUT?
ARE THE DEADLINES FOR THE CPUC
TO COMPLETE RATE CASES.
WILL RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE THE
LATEST TALLY THAT I HAVE.
IN A FAR OUT FASHION IS THAT --
WE'RE LOOKING AT FOURTEEN MONTH
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINE FOR
SMALL TELEPHONE COMPANY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FAR OUT I ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
CENTER WAS SO.
THANK YOU MEMBER SIMPLY I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS VERY PART
MEASURE TO KEEP.
OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE -- SMALL --
TELEPHONE OPERATORS OUT IN THE
KIND OF AREAS THAT HAVE VERY
SMALL MARKETS.
THE HELP KEEP THEM IN BUSINESS --
MAKING SURE THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE.
IN IN ON CERTAIN AREAS THAT ARE
OF THE STATE THAT ARE HARD TO
SERVICES THIS IS A VERY
ESSENTIAL SERVICE OR PROVIDING.
THIS THIS PROCESS WILL AT LEAST
ALLOW THEM -- TO SAVE SAVE SOME
MONEY TRUTH DURING THE PROCESS
THEY GO THROUGH THIS -- YOU SEE
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO WORK WITH
THE PC TO ESTABLISH.
A REASONABLE TIME LINE FOR THEM
TO RESPOND TO RATES RATES.
A REVIEW.
AND AS WELL AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT SIT ON THIS COMMITTEE --
AND HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WORK ON RATES ISSUES RIGHT NOW
OF THE PC IS BACKED UP IN ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE RATE CASE AND FOR
WORK FOR THE LARGER -- IT
DOESN'T HELP ANYBODY A FRANKLY
BUT FOR THE SMALLER OF THE
FIGHTERS SAID IT IS REALLY
PROVIDING A FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
ON THEM.
AND ON A HARDSHIP -- IN THEIR
ABILITY TO STAY IN BUSINESS SO
THIS IS A VERY PURPORT MEASURE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD IN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE.
ON BEHALF OF HIS DISTRICT AND IT
ALSO COVERS -- SMALL OPERATOR MY
DISTRICT AND AND FOR IN A LOT OF
A YEAR DISTRICTS AS WELL SO.
I I PRISON I VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER MORLOCK THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- THE
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO AND THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE ENERGY.
UTILITIES AND AND AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE JUST
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD.
SO IT BRINGS TO MIND A QUOTE.
FROM THE MOVIE YOUNG
FRANKENSTEIN.
THE ROLE PLAYED BY KENNETH MARS.
A RIOT IS AN UGLY THING.
AND IT'S JUST ABOUT TIME THAT WE
HAD.
ONE AND THAT'S SORT OF THE
REACTION THAT INDUSTRIES HAVING
TO THE CPUC.
JUST TAKING SO LONG AND IT'S IS
DRAGGING OUT IT'S SO BIG SO
CUMBERSOME SO.
OUT OF TOUCH MAYBE AND AND SO I
WITH THIS BILL I SUPPORT.
THIS BILL MISTER PRESIDENT --
BUT BUT I THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT HERE.
AND THAT THAT IS THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS OPPOSING
THIS BILL.
AND IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE HELPING.
RATE PAYERS BUT I I'M I'M
GETTING THE SENSE THAT AS WE
LOOK AT THE CPUC UNDER A
MICROSCOPE LATELY.
THAT -- I'M I'M GETTING DOUBTS
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR.
OFFICE SITS INSIDE -- THE
DEPARTMENT THE CPUC I'M I'M
GETTING WORRIED ABOUT ITS
INDEPENDENCE -- WITH IT
DEFENDING THE STATUS QUO WHICH
IS NOT RIGHT AND SO I'M A I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL IT SINCE
THE RIGHT MESSAGE AND ENCOURAGE
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU.
SOONER BORDERS WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST EITHER
THANK YOU.
OKAY THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS -- IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USE IN A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THIRTY
SEVEN EYES ZERO KNOWS THE
MEASURE PASSES. FOR MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE IN
THIS PORTANTINO.
NO I'M SORRY MISS BILL I'M SORRY
MISTER BELL [inaudible]
CRITICAL.
THIS BILL YOU PREPARED YEP.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE
ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHTY ONE AN IMPORTANT.
SENATE BILL TWELVE BY SENATOR
BELL AN ACT RELATING TO MENTAL
HEALTH [inaudible]
SENATOR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- MORE THAN 75% OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ACTUALLY
DEVELOP BEFORE A PERSON TURNS.
TWENTY FIVE YET TWO THIRDS OF
ADOLESCENTS WITH MAJOR
DEPRESSIVE ISSUES DO NOT GET
TREATMENT AND LOW INCOME
FAMILIES -- AND THEIR CHILDREN
GET EVEN LESS -- TREATMENT IN
OUR IN OUR GREAT STATE.
SB TWELVE ESTABLISHES MENTAL
HEALTH YOUTH DROP IN CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE IT AUTHORIZES
THE MENTAL HEALTH.
OF OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION TO ADMINISTER GROUNDS
PART APPROPRIATION TO ESTABLISH
UP TO A HUNDRED YOU'VE DROP IN
CENTERS AROUND THE STATE.
NO USE SUICIDE RATES ARE
INCREASING.
WE NEED OPTIONS FOR THE YOU'VE
DESIGNED JUST FOR THEM.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU THIS STATISTIC
THAT I THINK PEOPLE WILL BE
SHOCKED WITH ONE IN NINE TEENAGE
GIRLS IN CALIFORNIA ATTEMPT
SUICIDE. ONE IN NINE TEENAGE
GIRLS ATTEMPT SUICIDE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
THE IS CURRENTLY DEVELOPING TO
DROP IN CENTERS BASED ON THE
AUSTRALIAN MODEL WHICH IS NOW A
NATIONAL MODEL THROUGHOUT
AUSTRALIA. TO PROVIDE WRAPAROUND
CARE BY UTILIZING PEERS LICENSED
PROVIDERS AND COUNTY HEALTH
PROGRAMS -- TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
HELP.
SB TWELVE WILL BRING THIS MODEL
STATEWIDE.
SB TWELVE IS A COMPANION TO MY
BILL SB.
FIVE EIGHTY TWO THAT CREATES
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTIES IN
SCHOOLS. TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON THE CAMPUS.
SB TWELVE WILL SERVE YOU THROUGH
MAY NOT ATTEND A PUBLIC SCHOOL
INCLUDING OUR MOST VULNERABLE OR
HOME ISSUE.
ARE RUN AWAYS FOSTER YOU AS WELL
AS THOSE.
CHILDREN THAT ARE IN CHARTER
OTHER KINDS OF ALTERNATIVE
SCHOOLS THEY CAN'T GET STORE
SERVICES THROUGH THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
TOGETHER THESE BILLS AS COVERAGE
WISE ENSURE THAT ALL YOU'VE CAN
RECEIVE SERVICES AT SCHOOL OR IN
A SAFE NEIGHBORHOOD LOCATION.
EARLY DETECTION AND TREATMENT --
GREATLY IMPROVES THE HEALTH AND
SUCCESS OF ADOLESCENCE.
AS A TRANSITION TO ADULT HOOD --
WE GOTTA GET DOWN TO IT I URGE
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HE'S HERE IN CHINO AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible] FIVE ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I TELL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible] FIVE JONES
[inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
I Y. CASKEY [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
YOUR BILL MOVES A CALL. SIX
REMOVER TO FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE
SOONER BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR BELL AN ACT RELATING TO
USE MENTAL HEALTH.
CARE BILL.
YES -- THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SAW THE
LAST BILL WAS FOR OFF CAMPUS
MENTAL HEALTH FOR USE THIS BILL.
SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO IS FOR SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH COLLABORATIVE'S.
WE HAVE HEARD FOR MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- THAT THEY WANT TO
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
SERVICES.
IN THE SCHOOLS OVER THE PAST
DECADE THE STATE SAW
HOSPITALIZATION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH EMERGENCIES SPIKE MORE
THAN 40% AMONG OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO PAY MORE ATTENTION TO
THE EARLY INTERVENTIONS AND
PREVENTIONS.
IN PLACE THAT WE CAN REACH
ALMOST ALL THE KIDS AND THAT'S
IN A THE SCHOOL.
SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO DIRECTS MORE
RESOURCES INTO SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH PARTNERSHIPS THE BILL
INCENTIVIZE IS COUNTIES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TO PARTNER IT
IN A GREAT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THE SCHOOLS REQUIRES
AT HALF OF THE EXISTING MENTAL
HEALTH.
ROUND FUNDS -- BE ALLOCATED TO
YOU PROGRAMS AND THAT'S WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT ORDER
TO SERVE CALIFORNIA'S.
SCHOOL AGE POPULATION WE MUST
ENSURE HALF THE FUNDS ARE TARGET
TO YOU.
WHERE WHERE WHERE THEY ARE IN
SCHOOL?
THIS BILL HAS NO OP OPPOSITION.
I REGION I WROTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE SIDE I'M.
STRAINING HEARING NINE AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I FELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD HI I HAVE A ADAM
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I RATHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TANTO[inaudible] FIVE JACKSON.
I WOULD JONES [inaudible]
THE JONES I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
ROB.
FIVE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
HI.
SENATOR BREAUX MOVES A CALL.
MOVING NOW TO FOLLOW ITEM EIGHTY
THREE SENATORS KEEP SKINNER ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THIS
[inaudible]
MAJOR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE ONE
SECOND. EIGHTY THREE YES.
SENATE BILL FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
SKINNER AN ACT RELATING TO JAILS.
THANK YOU I MISSED RESIDENT AND
MEMBERS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
JESSICA ST LOUIS WAS RELEASED
FROM SANTA RITA JAIL.
AT ONE TWENTY FIVE IN THE
MORNING.
SHE WAS GIVEN A PARK TICKET IN
FOR THOSE OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH THE BAY AREA PART IS OUR
TRANSIT SYSTEM.
THE NEAREST BART STATION FROM
SANTA RITA JAIL WAS ABOUT A HALF
A MILE.
THE AREA BETWEEN STANNARY TO
JAIL AND PARTS IS PRETTY REMOTE
VERY DESERTED -- BUT THIS IS
WHAT SHE WAS AT ONE TWENTY FIVE
AM IN THE MORNING.
RELEASED FROM JAIL GIVEN OF OUR
TICKET.
PART DID NOT OPEN DID NOT BEGIN
ITS OPERATIONS FOR HOURS LATER.
THAT MORNING JESSICA ST LOUIS
WAS FOUND.
ABOUT A BLOCK AND A HALF AWAY
FROM BART.
DEAD FROM AN OVERDOSE.
THIS WAS AN AVOIDABLE DEATH.
LATE NIGHT RELEASES ARE
DANGEROUS THEY'RE DANGEROUS FOR
ANYONE BUT ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN
WHAT ARE WE DOING.
PREDATORY PEOPLE.
HANG OUT NEAR OUR JAILS. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
RELEASED SO WHEN FOLKS ARE
RELEASED WITHOUT A WORKING CELL
PHONE.
WITHOUT A RIDER TRANSPORTATION.
IN DURING UNSAFE HOURS.
DANGEROUS AVOIDABLE INCIDENTS
CAN HAPPEN.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES?
IS ALLOWS.
JAILS TO OFFER TO THE PERSON.
A SAFE PLACE TO STAY UNTIL IT'S
DAYTIME HOURS TO A TO SEE FOR
RELEASE TIME.
GIVES THEM ACCESS TO FREE PHONE
CALL SO THEY MIGHT ARRANGE
TRANSPORTATION.
GIVES THEM ACCESS TO A CELL
PHONE CHARGER SO THEY COULD
CHARGE THEIR CELL PHONE.
SHE TOOK REALLY GOOD HANDS.
HERE SO SIMPLE THINGS LIKE THAT.
TO MINIMIZE THE DANGER OF A LATE
NIGHT RELEASES THE HIGHLY COSTLY
PARTS OF THE BILL THAT WOULD
HAVE REQUIRED TO IT A COUNTY TO
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION.
OR REQUIRED OTHER THINGS ON THE
COUNTY WERE REMOVED THOSE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN.
SO THIS BILL IS NOW MUCH MORE
NARROWED BUT IT'S REAL PURPOSE
IS TO TRY TO MINIMIZE -- THOSE
UNSAFE RELEASES AND IT'S SIMILAR
TO SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS IN LA
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SOONER JONES THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FORTY TWO I VOTED NO ON THIS
MAJOR OPPOSED IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
BUT COLLEAGUES I HOPE YOU DON'T
MIND.
THAT I PUT DOWN INTO WORDS.
AFTER REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN COMING OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS I BELIEVE THE
BILL NOW ESTABLISHES VERY
REASONABLE SAFETY MEASURES. FOR
THOSE BEING RELATE RELEASED FROM
COUNTY JAILS.
I THINK THE AUTHOR AND PLOT THE
AUTHORED AND APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR FOR THEIR MAJOR CHANGES IN --
DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THE SENATOR FROM BERKELEY
FOR ADVANCING THIS BILL THIS
TRAGIC DEATH OCCURRED.
THIS WOMAN DIED.
IN MY DISTRICT AND CIRCUMSTANCES
WERE OBVIOUSLY NOT NOT GOOD AT
ALL AND THINK WHICH IS ASKING
FOR THIS BILL IS PERFECTLY
REASONABLE AND I AND I SUPPORTED
NERDS EITHER TODAY.
SOONER MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR.
SOONER SKINNER YOU TO QUESTION.
CENTERS CAN WE TAKE QUESTION YES
I WILL THANKS CENTER MORE LOCK
JUST [inaudible]
ONE QUESTION ABOUT.
THE POLICE THAT THE SHERIFF
WOULD HAVE. TO TO DRIVE A
POTENTIAL.
RELEASE PERSON UP TO ONE HUNDRED
MILES FROM THE JAIL IS THAT
STILL IN THE BILL NO THAT A MAN
THE AMENDMENTS INTO PROBES
REMOVED THAT FROM THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OF IT ON THE SIDE OF NINETEEN
NINE SENATOR -- YES.
SENATE ARE JULY.
MATTER PRESS.
MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE BECAUSE
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
OBVIOUSLY THE TIME THAT I SPENT
WITH THE AUTHOR VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME.
THE THE ISSUES THAT ARE HERE
SAFETY.
SAFETY AND AND A SENSE OF
HUMANITY AS SENSE OF CARING.
OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED THEY'VE DONE THEIR
TIME WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE AND
SOMETIMES IT'S YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN.
WHO DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO GO AND
ARE LEFT OUT IN THE STREET AND I
THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE?
THAT ALL OF US TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE TAKEN CARE OF WHETHER
THEY GO TO A HOMELESS SHELTER
WERE PICKED UP BY FAMILY BUT
CERTAINLY NOT THROWN UP THE
STREET AND I THINK THIS
ADDRESSES THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO FOR ALL OF US TO
COME TOGETHER AND REALIZE THAT
THE LESS FORTUNATE CAN NOW BE
TAKEN CARE OF AND I THINK THIS
BILL NOT ONLY TO PUBLIC SAFETY
BILL.
BUT AS A BILL TO TAKE CARE OF
THOSE WHO REALLY NEED HELP.
AND I THANK YOU AND I URGE OF AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL.
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM -- SENATOR
BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- A
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM OAKLAND I'D LIKE TO
CERTAINLY COMMAND YOU I THINK
THIS IS A VERY APPROPRIATE AND
VERY OB.
COMPASSIONATE LOOK ON A OUT THE
SITUATION THAT DEVELOPED TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND HOPEFULLY NOT FOR
OTHERS HOWEVER THERE REMAINS A
CONCERN.
ON ONE PARTICULAR ELEMENT AND
THAT IS THE RELEASE OF IT UN
MADE WITH THREE DAYS OF
MEDICATION.
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED -- COMES THE
HAVE ANY CONCERN OR CONSIDERED
PERHAPS AN AMENDMENT.
THAT WOULD BE RESTRICTIVE ON THE
KIND OF MEDICATIONS BECAUSE OUR
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF HAVE
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED A WILL A
NUMBER OF THESE THINGS THAT
REMAIN CONCERNED.
REGARDING THE MEDICATION ISSUE
AND I THINK ABOUT SOMETHING IF
SERRATION WITH ABUSE PROBLEMS HE
MIGHT BE.
GOOD TO ALLOW AWESOME
RESTRICTION ON THAT PART.
QUESTION ARE.
YEAH I I WOULD TAKE YOUR
QUESTION.
HOW'S IT PROGRESSES WOULD YOU
CONSIDER WRITING NARROWING DOWN
A TAD AT CURRENTLY.
END OF COLLEGES MY I'M NOT
READING THE WHOLE BILL IN FRONT
OF BUT MY RECOLLECTION IS THAT
WE WORDED THAT SECTION AS THAT
IS ESSENTIAL MEDICATIONS.
BUT I'M CERTAINLY WILLING TO
LOOK AT WHETHER THAT WORDING IS
TO BROADEN MIGHT BE VIEWED AS
BUT IT WAS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PERSON RELEASED HAD THREE DAYS
OF ESSENTIAL MEDICATIONS AND
CLEARLY AS WE KNOW IF FOR
EXAMPLE THE PERSON IS DIABETIC.
THAT DO WE KNOW THAT CERTAIN
PRESCRIPTIONS ARE VERY ESSENTIAL
FOR THIS LIFESAVING PURPOSES --
BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO LOOK AND
SEE WHETHER THAT LANGUAGE IS TO
ADD A IS NOT.
DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH CLARITY.
THANK YOU ON MY OWN TIME MISTER
PRESIDENT I AM NOT PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THEIR SAID YES WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THAT PARTICULAR
AYE ELEMENT IN THE BILL --
CONSIDER A PERMISSIVE PART IN
TERMS OF THE APPLICATION -- THE
OB.
THE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS BEING
GIVEN FOR THREE DAYS SUPPLY.
THANK YOU AND I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM HEARING SEEN.
NINE SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A MASS FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE SIDE OF ALAN
[inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
I THEY'RE AWESOME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible] FIVE
MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MARROW [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I'M BURKE.
I Y. CASKEY.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER SKINNER MOVES AWAY ALL
THAT [inaudible]
HUESO I NEXT UP FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FOUR SENATOR WIENER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC RESOURCES.
SENATOR FLOORS YOURS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB -- SIXTY NINE THE
OCEAN RESILIENCY OCT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN ALL REPRESENTS A MAJOR
STEP FORWARD IN PROTECTING OUR
OCEAN ECOSYSTEMS.
AGAINST THE GREATEST THREAT
FACING THEM TODAY CLIMATE CHANGE
AND THE ACIDITY HYPOXIA AND MASS
EXTINCTION IT CAN LEAD.
TO HEALTHY OCEANS INTERN WE KEEP
THEM HEALTHY CONSERVE AS THE
LARGEST THINK OF CARBON
EMISSIONS AND ABSORBER OF CARBON
ON THE PLANET.
AND CAN HELP BLOOD THE WORST
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
SB SIXTY NINE WILL HELP RESTORE
HABITATS AND ENCOURAGE PRACTICES
THAT INCLUDE INCREASE THE
FRUSTRATION OF WHAT WE CALL BLUE
CARBON.
INCLUDING RE USE OF MARINE
SEDIMENTS TO BUILD UP A ROAD
WETLANDS.
WE ALSO NEED TO PROTECT OUR
ECOLOGICALLY CRITICAL SPECIES
INCLUDING THOSE THAT COASTAL
ECONOMIES RELY ON THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT WHALES BY CODIFYING AN
EXISTING VOLUNTARY PROGRAM AIMED
AT PREVENTING SHIP STRIKES.
SB SIXTY NINE ALSO TAKES A
NUMBER OF LONG OVERDUE STOPS TO
BEGIN REBUILDING OUR SALMON
FISHERIES.
INCLUDING PROTECTION OF THE
FORESTS STREAMS WHERE SALMON
SPAWN.
TOGETHER THESE MEASURES WILL
HELP ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA HAS A
STRATEGY AND THE ABILITY TO
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON OUR OHSEN.
SEQUESTER GREATER AMOUNTS OF
CARBON AND ALLOW COASTAL
COMMUNITIES IN COASTAL ECONOMIES
TO CONTINUE THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
INTO THE FUTURE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
JANUARY SO.
MEMBERS YOU KNOW AS IN MY
DISTRICT -- I'VE I'VE MADE THESE
COMMENTS A COMMITTEE BUT I I
JUST WANT TO PRESS BOND PEOPLE
HOW.
IMPORTANT THIS BILL IS -- IN MY
IN MY DISTRICT OF WE USED TO
HAVE -- A SALMON CANNERY ON THAT
THE QUAN A RIVER VALLEY IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES AND THIRTIES.
AND I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE
ANYTHING NOW SURVIVING ALONG
THAT THAT WATERSHED.
WE'RE TRYING TO RESTORE IT BUT I
DON'T THINK WE'LL EVER.
RESTORE THE SALMON RUNS THAT WE
USED TO HAVE IN SENEGAL COUNTY
OR IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR
THAT MATTER OR EVEN IN VENTURA
COUNTY IT'S THE SALMON RUNS ARE
BECOMING MORE SCARCE.
THE FURTHER NORTH YOU COME
ACROSS THE STATE THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL -- IF SOMETHING
THAT DEALS WITH THE QUALITY OF
THE WATER ALONG THE ON ON THE
OCEAN IN OUR RIVERS -- I I WENT
BY IT'S ONE TO RISE TO TO TO
SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL IN THE WATER WATER QUALITY
AND THESE DAYS.
YOU CAN EVEN HANG TEN ON A
GNARLY WAVES IN IN SAN DIEGO
ABOUT COMING ACROSS -- HEPATITIS
B. SO -- I REGION I VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT.
HOWEVER.
I DID TALK WITH YOU AUTHORED I
UNDERSTAND THAT HE IS GOING TO
TALK WITH.
THE FORCE INDUSTRY TO WATER SHE
BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER SOME
AMENDMENTS IS STILL PENDING.
AND HE'S AGREED TO WORK WITH
THEM AND AND I'M HOPING THAT WE
ALL UNDERSTAND WE CAN BRING
THOSE TWO AND EIGHTY SIX GATHER.
FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT AND AND I'M
SO PLEASED THAT -- SENATOR FROM
SAN FRANCISCO'S AGREED TO DO
THAT AND I URGE THE AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
IS PRESENT MEMBERS I TOO HAD THE
SIMILAR CONCERNS -- THERE'S A
LOT OF REGULATION RIGHT NOW IN
THAT AREA WITH FORSTER'S AND
ALSO CATTLEMEN.
IN A CONCERNED ABOUT -- WHAT
THIS BILL THE DUPLICATION THAT
THIS BILL WILL BRING TOTHEM BUT
WITH THE AUTHORS -- ASSURANCES
THAT HILL -- WORK WITH THEM -- I
WILL SUPPORT THIS -- VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE
OR CONVERSATION ON THIS ITEM
SEEN DONE SOONER WINNER TO LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MISTER
PRESIDENT I YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FOR OCEANS I
WOULD LOVE TO SOLVE ALL OF OUR
OCEANS PROBLEMS OVERNIGHT -- BUT
I THINK IT'S GONNA BE A LONG
LONG TIME BUT WE'LL GET IT DONE
THANK YOU.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
WELL.
I FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD ART I CARILLO
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I TELL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SURE WINNER MOVES CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
SENATOR WIENER YOU PREPARED.
YES MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO CORRECTIONS CENTER WINNER I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- SP --
ONE THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES A VERY
REAL PROBLEM FACING INCARCERATED
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS --
NAMELY THAT TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
ARE BEING HELD ACCORDING TO
THEIR BIRTH SSIGNED SOCKS
RATHER BAD AND NOT ACCORDING TO
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY OR HAVING
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THEIR OWN
PERCEPTION.
OF THEIR SAFETY WHICH RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT -- VIOLENCE --
SPECIFICALLY TRANSGENDER WOMEN
ARE FREQUENTLY CLASSIFIED AND
THEN HOUSED IN PRISON AS MEN
WHERE THEY ARE PROMPTLY
VICTIMIZED ASSAULTED RAPED.
AND THEN THEY ARE PLACED IN
ISOLATION FOR THEIR QUOTE ON
QUOTE FOR THEIR OWN PROTECTION
WHICH SURPRISED SOME OF ACCESS
TO SERVICES.
SB ONE THIRTY TWO WILL ENSURE
THAT TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED ARE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND EXTRA ARE TREATED
ACCORDING TO THEIR ACTUAL GENDER
IDENTITY NOT DOT.
WHICH WAS ASSIGNED TO THEM I
BIRTH.
SB ONE THIRTY TWO WILL REQUIRE
THAT DURING THE INITIAL INTAKE
PROCESS I SEE TO SEE OUR WILL
RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL'S GENDER
IDENTITY -- AND OTHER
INFORMATION RELATING TO THAT
INDIVIDUALS -- GENDER.
HI THE BILL WILL REQUIRE ALL
SEVEN CONTRACTORS -- AT CDC ARE
TO CONSISTENTLY -- THREE AND
ADDRESS THE PERSON ACCORDING TO
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY. FIVE THE
BILL REQUIRES YOU TO SEE OUR TO
HAL'S BY THE INDIVIDUAL
ACCORDING TO THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY UNLESS THERE IS A
SPECIFIC @SAFETY
DO SO THAT IS SPECIFIC TO THE
INDIVIDUAL.
AND SO FORTH -- WE KNOW THAT
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
FACING OUR POPULATION OF
TRANSGENDER INCARCERATED --
CALIFORNIANS -- AND IT'S TIME TO
START TREATING THEM WITH THE
RESPECT AND DIGNITY THAT THEY
DESERVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
DR -- IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION A BIT ON THE SIDE ON
SCENE HERE.
NINE MOUNT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SIR BORDERS IS RESUMES POSE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
FROM CENTER BORDERS YES.
CENTER BORDERS SO CAN YOU
CLARIFY -- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IF IT INDIVIDUAL IDENTIFIES.
THAT THEY ARE IN A SAFETY RISK
SITUATION AND THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL -- BE RE HOUSED.
IS THAT IS THAT CORRECT I'M
SORRY I COULDN'T HEAR YOU SPEAK
CLOSER TO THE MICROPHONE I GOT A
NOTHING I MEAN I GOT.
ONE AS BIG AS YOURS NOW ANY OF
OUR IDEA -- IF THE IN IF THE
INMATE BELIEVES THAT HE OR SHE
IS AT RESTORING DANGER.
THAT INDIVIDUAL THEN TRIGGERS A
RIGHT FOR THEM TO BE RELOCATED
ELSEWHERE.
IS THAT THE WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
WHETHER IT'S AN INTAKE OR LATER --
I EXPRESSES THAT THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY IS INCONSISTENT WITH
HOW THEY'RE BEING HOUSE.
I'VE BEEN THERE WILL BE HAVE TO
BE HOUSED ACCORDING TO THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY UNLESS CDC ARE
HAS A SPECIFIC SAFETY OR
SECURITY REASON.
NOT TO HONOR.
THAT REQUEST SO THE BILL DOES
HAVE FLEXIBILITY FOR CDC ARE IF
THERE'S A SPECIFIC SAFETY
RESEARCH OUR CONCERN RELATING
THAT INDIVIDUAL BUT OTHERWISE
YES.
ALRIGHT SO -- THE THIRD DANGER
BY THE MOVING OF INDIVIDUALS
BASED ON RISK OR DANGER IS BASED
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF GENDER
IDENTITY IS THAT CORRECT.
I'M SORRY I CAN YOU REPEAT THAT.
THE REMOVAL OF AN INDIVIDUAL
BASED ON RISK OR DANGER IS ONLY
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF GENDER
IDENTITY IS THAT CORRECT.
THE THE THE THE GOAL OF THE
BILL'S PURPOSE IS TO ENSURE THAT
IF SOMEONE.
IF THAT PERSON GENDER IDENTITY
IS [inaudible]
EMAIL.
AND THE PERSON WILL BE HOUSE AS
A FEMALE.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S THE GOAL OF
THE BILL AND SAFETY AND SECURITY
IS PART OF THAT.
BUT IT'S NOT.
THE ENTIRETY IT'S REALLY ABOUT
TREATING PEOPLE WITH DIGNITY AS
WHO THEY ARE.
INSTEAD OF SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
TELL YOU WHO YOU ARE CERTAINLY
AND AND MAYBE I'LL JUST POSE MY
DIRECT QUESTION TO YOU.
DOES THIS CREATE A SCENARIO IN
YOUR OPINION -- THE INDIVIDUALS
ARTIFICIALLY EXPRESSING A RISK
FOR A DANGER TO SHOP. FIVE
PLACES WHERE THEY WILL BE HELD
SO THEY CAN MOVE FROM POINT A TO
POINT B..
BECAUSE OF A PERCEIVED RISK I I
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
IS A REAL RISK HERE THAT WAS
OKAY -- DIE THAT'S AN ARGUMENT
THAT WE SOMETIMES HEAR WITH THE
SO CALLED ODD BATHROOM BILLS YOU
MAY RECALL IN NORTH CAROLINA.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL --
SAYING THAT YOU HAVE TO USE THE
RESTROOM THAT CORRESPONDS TO THE
GENDER ASSIGNED TO A BIRTH AND
THE ARGUMENT WAS THAT PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO USE THE THE A
RESTROOM IN ORDER TO ASSAULT
PEOPLE -- THERE WAS NEVER ANY
EVIDENCE OF THAT -- AND AND THAT
LAW WAS ULTIMATELY A CAMERA CREW
WAS REPEALED OR SCALE BACK --
YOU KNOW THE I. SO I DON'T SEE
THAT -- AS A RISK AND AGAIN CITY
SIR DOES HAVE FLEXIBILITY -- TO
MAKE A SECURITY ASSESSMENT
SPECIFIC THAT INDIVIDUAL -- SO
THERE IS NOT FLEXIBILITY BUILT
INTO THE LAW [inaudible]
DINNER BILL.
OF THIS PRESENT MEMBERS -- I
RECENTLY -- HAVE VISITED MANY OF
OUR STATE -- PENAL INSTITUTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA LATELY I WENT DOWN
TO THE DONOVAN'S -- PRISON AND
SAN DIEGO.
AND EVERY TIME I GO TO ONE OF
THESE FACILITIES.
THE ISSUE RAISED BY.
THE CENTER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
COMES UP.
IN TERMS OF SAFETY IN FACT --
THE PRISON OF PROCESS AND AND
AND POLICIES OF OF MIXED YARDS
HAS BECAUSE A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS.
IN TERMS OF THINGS LIKE FIGHTS
RIOTS OTHER KINDS OF PROBLEMS.
AND WE NEED TO ESTABLISH --
SPECIFIC -- SECURITY.
AT PROTECTION [inaudible]
FOR BECAUSE OF THIS POPULATION
AND OTHERS IN OUR CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS.
SO HERE'S AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
THIS IS A THIS IS A PROTECTION
ON THIS WILL PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
BEING HARMED.
INJURED.
AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD POLICY
FOR THE STATE TO ADD AS WELL AS
WELL CONCEIVED.
ARJUN AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
UNION SEEN NONE CENTER WE WERE
TO LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
CALLING THIS IS -- ULTIMATELY
ABOUT TREATING PEOPLE WITH
DIGNITY -- PROTECTING PEOPLE'S
SAFETY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible] FIVE SKINNER
[inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I Y. CASKEY [inaudible] FIVE
WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK.
WINDOW HI MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
WILK.
ALL EYES TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX
SENATOR GLAZER YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT MATTER.
YES MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
GLAZER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS.
SB ONE FORTY EIGHT WILL CREATE
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
UNDERSERVEDSTUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CALIFORNIA.
PROMISE PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM WHICH
WENT INTO EFFECT IN TWO THOUSAND
SIFT.
SEVENTEEN GAY STUDENTS WHO WANT
TO GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS THE
TOOLS TO DO SO SO FAR NEARLY
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS HAVE
PARTICIPATED.
THE PREVIOUS BILL ALSO REQUIRE
THE CSU TO SUBMIT A REPORT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS ON INCENTIVES
THAT ENCOURAGE COURAGE MORE
STUDENT PARTICIPATION.
IN THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM THAT'S WHAT'S CONTAINED.
IN THIS BILL THEIR TWO ELEMENTS
IN THE BILL. ONE IS THE ABILITY
TO PROVIDE SUMMER TERM GRANT
SOMETHING THAT SENATOR ROBB IN
HIS PRESENTATION HIS BILL
EARLIER TODAY.
ALSO ADDRESSED -- ALSO IT
PROVIDED -- INSTEAD IS FOR
ONTRACK PROGRESS GRANTS.
AND FINALLY THE LAST PROVISION
OF THE BILL THAT'S NOT OPTIONAL
IS THAT IF THE STUDENT IS IN A
PROMISE PROGRAM.
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR CLASSES IN FOUR YEARS
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
THAT THE INSTITUTION WOULD
PROVIDE THAT AT NO COST THIS IS
A RECOMMENDATION THAT CAME OUT
OF THEIR TASK FORCE WORK AT THE
STATE UNIVERSITIES.
ON IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
A HELPFUL THING TO PUT IN THE
BILL.
ANY PARTICULAR THIS MEASURES
FOCUS ON STUDENTS IN NEED AND
WITH THAT MET MEMBERS ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE SITE ON SCENE HEARING ON
THIS IS ALL DOUBLE FOR YOU
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THIRTY
SEVEN A AYE AYES ZERO KNOWS THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SEVEN SENATOR Y. KAUTSKY
WHEN YOU'RE READY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT
RELATING TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
SOONER WHY BECAUSE WE MISTER
REPP PRESENT I'M PLEASED HER A
PRESENT THIS BILL WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CHIEF CLIMATE.
RESILIENCE OFFICER HOUSE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH NOW THROUGHOUT THE
CITY CALIFORNIA WE'VE SEEN THE
TERRIBLE EFFECTS OF CHANGING
CLIMATE NOW SEVERELY IT CAN
DESTROY OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
LOCAL ECONOMIES AND THIS.
CAN LEAD TO LOSS OF LIFE AND
LOSS OF PROPERTY THE
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH CLIMATE.
CHANGEASSESSMENT POINTS TO
DRIER CONDITIONS IN THE FUTURE
INTERRUPTED BY LARGER INTENSE
STORMS. TWO MEMBERS THAT
INCREASE THE RISK OF FLOODING SO
WHAT WE DO OR WHAT WE NEED WE
NEED A WELL COORDINATED STRATEGY
BASED ON THE LATEST SCIENCE THE
NAPLES THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TO BE RESILIENT ENOUGH TO MEET
THESE AND OTHER INCREDIBLE GOALS
THIS.
IN A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE HAD A
BILL WHICH SB TWO FOUR SIX WHICH
ADDRESSED THE LACK OF
COMPREHENSIVE AND COORDINATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING
BETWEEN STATE.
REGIONAL AND LOCAL ENTITIES THIS
BILL SB ONE SIXTY EIGHT TAKES
THE NEXT STEP INCREASES CHIEF
RESILIENCE OFFICERS WITHIN THE
OPR THE CHIEF OFFICER WOULD BE
THE STATE WIDE LEAD TO MANAGE
THIS EFFORT ON CLIMATE
ADAPTATION.
THIS THIS THIS THIS BILL MEANS
THAT IT'S ANOTHER STRONG STEP
FORWARD FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- REESE LEADING --
MAGNIFYING OUR LEADERSHIP AND
CLIMATE ADAPTATION.
YOU BET YOUR FIFTY AMENDMENT
APPROPRIATIONS REQUIRES SENATE
CONFIRMATION FOR THIS POSITION
AND WITH THAT I WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
I HAVE A I DON'T [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROSS [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MERLE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I Y. CASKEY [inaudible]
I WIENER.
I WILK.
I I'M SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
NO GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO.
ICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR DODD YOU
PREPARE TO TAKE UP THIS ITEM YES.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TO FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD.
AN ACT RELATING TO MEDI CAL AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
THE TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR DOG MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB TWO FOURTEEN CODIFIES
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONS.
PROGRAM THAT SUCCESSFULLY
TRANSITIONS MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES WITH DISABILITIES
FROM INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS.
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY
INDIVIDUALS WHO VOLUNTARILY AND
ROLE IN THE CCT PROGRAM RECEIVED
TRANSITION COORDINATION AND CARE
PLANNING.
HOME SET UP AND MODIFICATIONS
FAMILY CARE GIVER TRAINING AND
MANY OTHER SERVICES THAT ENSURE
THESE INDIVIDUALS THRIVE IN A
HOME BASED.
SETTING AMENDMENTS AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MADE
THE BILL CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION WHILE AN EXTENSION
OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING IS UNDER
ACTIVE CAM.
CONSIDERATION SO MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE A CHILL PILL AND VOTE YES
ON SB.
TWO FORTY ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SITTING HEARING ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE [inaudible]
OF EIGHTY SEVEN I'M SORRY.
THIS ARE.
MMHM ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR ALL DO
I MEAN I YOU DANCE ROLL CALL.
THIRTY SEVEN ON THE URGENCY
THIRTY SEVEN ON THE MATTER
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM.
NINETY BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACTUALLY
INTO SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER PRESIDENT
AND A FAMOUS PHILOSOPHER ONCE
LOOKED OUT ACROSS THE OCEAN AND
WAS DISTRESSED AT WHAT HE SAW
AND HE SAYS.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET A BIGGER
BOAT.
WELL WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GET A BIGGER BOAT
I'M GONNA HAVE TO DO MORE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE
SURE THAT EARLY INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS ARE WELL FUNDED THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE DISTRICTS WITH
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EVERY
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD CHILD
WHO WAS AN INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PLAN ALSO KNOWN AS AN
I EP.
THAT ARE SERVED IN A MAINSTREAM
EARLY EDUCATION SETTING THE BILL
ALSO ALLOWS FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH
IT PIECE TO ENROLL IN TRADITION
TRADE.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN CORD
IN THE LA -- APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN AGED THREE AND
FOUR HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING A DISABILITY CURRENTLY IS
THE LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
COULD PROVIDE I. E. P. SERVICES
TO THESE THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS WITH DISABILITIES
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THOSE
STUDENTS ARE IN A STATE SCHOOL
OR PRIVATE PRESCHOOL HEAD START
ORCHARD TRANSITIONAL CAM ECONOMY
SAID THAT AGAIN.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR PROVIDING THE IEP SERVICES
EVEN IF THAT STUDENT IS NOT
ENROLLED IN THAT SCHOOL HOWEVER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALSO DO NOT
RECEIVE ANY FUNDING FOR THAT SO
THEY HAVE TO USE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS. TO HELP THESE MOST
NEEDY STUDENTS SB TWO SEVENTEEN
WOULD REPRISE PROVIDE THE
FUNDING AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO INVEST IN
THEIR PROGRAMS AND EXPAND THE
STRESS TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS AND FRANKLY THIS EARLY
INTERVENTION IS CRITICAL. TO THE
LONG LONG TERM SUCCESS OF THE
STUDENTS THEY DESERVE IT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF
HEARING TEEN ON THIS IS ALL
DOUBLE FOR YOU NOT A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
OF USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ON THE SIDE OF SEE. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN EYES IS ZERO KNOWS THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NOBODY GOT MY NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM NINETY ONE SOONER NELSON
ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR NIELSEN AN ACT RELATING
TO WATERSHED RESTORATION.
SENATOR NELSON AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WATERSHED
RESTORATION HAS BEEN AN ISSUE
EXTENT FOREVER.
BUT EVEN MORE SO NOW WITH THESE
FIRES THAT HAVE SOLD DENUDED THE
LAND.
IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
[inaudible]
THE HABITAT.
THE PRODUCTIVE ANY OF THE LAND.
THE AVAILABILITY OF THAT LAND
[inaudible]
AFTER FIRES.
SOME THINGS.
NEED TO BE TENDED [inaudible]
TO RESTORATION.
BUT WE CALLED.
IN SOME CASES THAT WOULD REQUIRE
SOME SORT OF BARRIERS TO IMPEDE
THE EROSION.
SOMETIMES IT WILL BE REQUIRING
OF PLANTING OF TREES.
OTHER KIND OF BRUSH TO HOLD THE
SOIL TOGETHER.
THIS IS A NECESSARY PART.
OF OUR PLANNING.
AND THE FUTURE FOR MANAGING OUR
FOR AND A WILD LANDS.
THEY'RE ALSO THE BREED THAT
COMES FLOWING OFF OF THESE
[inaudible]
LANDS.
THE CLUB RECORD RIVERS I WATCHED
IN EVERY WEEK WHAT BY THE HOUSE
[inaudible]
SOMETIMES TREES [inaudible]
SOMETIMES [inaudible]
JUST LAMPS [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
SET SET UP [inaudible]
THE FUN. FOR THE RESTORATION.
OF OUR FORCE.
IN A WILD LANDS.
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION.
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
WE WOULD HAVE TO THEN MAKE.
OPINION THAT THIS WAS.
THE NECESSARY EXPENDITURE.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SET UP THIS.
GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT AS WE MIGHT FIND.
LOCAL ENTITIES CAN PROVIDE HEAVY
PROVIDED WITH SOME RESOURCES. TO
HELP THEM.
WE'VE DONE SMALL THINGS LIKE
THIS IN THE PAST.
BUT I THINK WITH THE RECURRENCE
THAT WE SEE NOW.
A MORE PERMANENT STRUCTURE AT
LEAST.
IT'S WELL TO HAVE THAT IN PLACE.
AND WE WOULD FUNDED.
THEN AS WE COULD.
A RESTORATION GRANT PROGRAM I'D
ASK AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF YOUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IN THIS
ROGER.
JANE NINE OZ THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW THE FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
NINETY TWO SENATOR LEYVA.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL WE NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING TO
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
GENERAL OVER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
SB TWO NINETY ONE WOULD INSIST
YOUR INSURER A SIGNIFICANT AND
MORE EQUITABLE INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES THAT
WOULD SUPPORT THE TOTAL COST OF
COLLEGE.
NEARLY TWO POINT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS ANNUALLY INCLUDING THE
VAST MAJORITY OF FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
ACCESS OUR PROMISE TO A HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGH ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE TRUE COST OF COLLEGE
INCLUDES NON TUITION EXPENSES.
SUCH AS HOUSING TEXTBOOKS
TRANSPORTATION FOOD WHICH CAN
EXCEED NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THESE HIGH NOT TUITION
COSTS MAKE SUCCEEDING TO
COMMUNICATE ALL AGE.
ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT FOR LOWER
INCOME STUDENTS ADDITIONALLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVE THE
LOWEST PERCENT.
LOWEST PER STUDENT FUNDING LEVEL
OF ANY OF THE STATE'S EDUCATION
SEGMENTS.
COLLEGES COLLEAGUES AS THE
LEGISLATURE CONTEMPLATES WHETHER
STUDENTS SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
SLEEP IN THEIR CARS ON CAMPUS
AND AS WE PUSH FOR THE EXPANSION
OF FOOD BANKS ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
I ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO THINK
ABOUT THE BOLD SOLUTIONS TO
SOLVE THE ISSUE OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY.
CLEARLY ARE COLLEGE STUDENTS
DESERVE BETTER SB TWO NINETY ONE
MOVES US CLOSER TO ENSURING THAT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE IN
AFFORDABLE GATEWAY TO HIGHE
EDUCATION.
AND FUTURE SUCCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER THE DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
CENA AND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible] FIVE ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I DATO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I BY CASKEY [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO.
ICE THIRTY KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM. NINETY THREE SENATOR
CAFIERO YOU'RE PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TO NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACTUAL
LEADING TO POVERTY REDUCTION.
CENTER GOVERNOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT SB TO NINETY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH
SPECIFIC TARGETS.
AND DEEP CHILD POVERTY IN FOUR
YEARS AND REDUCE CHILD POVERTY
BY 50% WITHIN TEN YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE WAS PASSED CREATING
THE LIFTING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY TASK
FORCE.
THIS TASK FORCE SPENT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS DEVELOPING A ROAD MAP FOR
THE STATE TO MAKE REAL
INVESTMENTS IN ORDER TO TACKLE
THE RISING POVERTY RATE.
THIS TASK FORCE AND THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCES STUDY ON
TRIAL POVERTY HIGHLIGHT THE
DEVASTATING NUMBER OF CHILDREN.
LIVING IN POVERTY NATIONWIDE AND
IN CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE CAN DO
TO ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL ACTION
ISSUE.
DUE TO THE HIGH COST OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE IN THE NATION.
THE DIRE AFFECTS ON POVERTY ON
CHILDREN ARE MANY IT IT
UNDERMINES BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AFFECTS PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
REDUCES ACADEMIC SUCCESS IN
SCHOOL INCREASES RISKY BEHAVIORS
AND LEADS TO LESS WORKING ADULT.
HOURS IT WORKING HOURS IN THE
ADULT YEARS THESE IMPACTS
CREATED CYCLE OF POVERTY THAT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO CHANGE.
REDUCING CHILD POVERTY BY 50%
AND EFFECTIVELY ENDING THE CHILD
POVERTY.
CAN BE DONE OUR CHILDREN DESERVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE IN TO
MEET THEIR FULL POTENTIAL IF WE
CAN SET.
UP MEASURABLE ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS WE CAN CERTAINLY DO THE
SAME FOR POVERTY SB TO NINETY
EIGHT HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ZERO NO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEN HEARING ON THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THIRTY SEVEN A OUR EYES ZERO
KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS MADE -- FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR
CAFIERO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO HAZARDOUS WASTE
[inaudible]
CENTER EURO.
MISTER PRESIDENT AND CENTERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB THREE
SEVENTEEN WHICH WOULD BAN THE
SALE OF CERTAIN TOXIC CHEMICALS
USED IN OUR BE WASTE WATER TANKS.
WHICH CAN CAUSE GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION.
RECREATIONAL VIC VEHICLES OUR RV
TO REDUCE ODORS FROM THE BLACK
AND GREY WATER TANKS IN THERE
ARE VIS.
THESE DEODORANTS CONTAIN TOXIC
CHEMICALS LIKE FORMALDEHYDE
WHICH REDUCE ORDERS BY KILLING
THE BACTERIA THAT LIVE IN THE
TANKS AND PRODUCE THE ODORS WHEN
RV OWNERS HOOKED THEIR TANKS UP
TO AN RV PARK SEPTIC TANKS.
THEY DEPOSIT THE CONTENTS OF
THEIR TANKS INCLUDING THESE
TOXIC CHEMICALS ONCE IN THE
PARK'S SEPTIC TANK THESE
CHEMICALS KILL THE BACTERIA
NEEDED TO TREAT THE THE PARTS
WASTE WHICH CAUSES.
SYSTEM FAILURE.
THIS INCREASES THE RISK THAT
UNTREATED WASTE AND TOXIC
CHEMICALS WILL MAKE THEIR WAY
INTO.
THE ROUND WATER WHICH THREATENS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF PARK
VISITORS THE OWNERS AND
NEIGHBORS IN THESE MOSTLY RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
IN AN EFFORT TO PROTECT THE
GROUND WATER ENCOURAGE THE THE
USE OF SAFE ALTERNATIVE ARE TURN
IT IS SB THREE SEVENTEEN WILL
BAN THE SALE.
OF AND USE OF CERTAIN TOXIC
CHEMICALS AS WELL AS REQUIRE THE
RV OWNERS.
PART THAT OWN THE PARKS TO
INFORM THE CUSTOMERS OF THE BAND
WITH SIGNAGE REQUIREMENTS.
THIS WAY A GROUNDWATER IS
PROTECTED AND THE WORRY OF OUR
B. R. V. PARK OWNERS AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY IS
RELIEVED.
THAT THIS IS A IS A COMPROMISE
THAT WAS REACHED WITH THE RV
OWNERS AS WELL AS THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
THE TOXIC CHEMICAL COMPANIES
HAVE ALSO ALSO HAVE A GREEN
ALTERNATIVE THAT IS READILY
AVAILABLE SO JEEPERS CREEPERS
CREEPERS ACCESS IS ASSURED.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD THINK YOU IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN.
NINE THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF USING THE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS MEASURE.
AYE AYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO A FILE ITEM THEN
NINETY FIVE SENATORHILL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR HELL AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SENATOR HILL WHEN YOU'RE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT SUBSTANCE ABUSE COSTS
OUR NATION OVER FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
BUT EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT HELPED REDUCE THESE
COSTS.
TREATMENT IS ALSO LESS EXPENSIVE
THAN COMMON ALTERNATIVE OUTCOMES
SUCH AS INCARCERATING ADDICTED
PERSONS CURRENTLY RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS ARE REQUIRED
TO HAVE A LICENSE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES DH CS.
LAST YEAR I AUTHORED AS BE EIGHT
TWENTY THREE WHICH FURTHER
REQUIRED RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS TO
UTILIZE EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT
STANDARDS.
OUTPATIENT PROGRAMS HOWEVER DO
NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRE ANY
LICENSING NOR DO THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT.
DH CS OFFERS A CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM BUT IT IS ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARY TODAY IF YOU WANT TO
OPEN YOUR OWN OUTPATIENT
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT FACILITY
YOU COULD DO SO IMMEDIATELY.
NO LICENSE NO TRAINING OR PRIOR
EXPERIENCE IS REQUIRED.
SB THREE TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT PROGRAMS TO
BE LICENSED WITH DH CS IT ALSO
REQUIRES A LICENSED PROVIDERS TO
KEEP RECORDS OF ADMISSIONS
WITHDRAWALS TRANSFERS AND
DISCHARGES.
AND THE REASON FOR EACH.
ADDITIONALLY THIS MEASURE WOULD
PROHIBIT LICENSED PROVIDERS FROM
ENGAGING IN PATIENTS CELL IN AND
RECRUITING FOR MONETARY GAIN.
THOUGH SHE CAN TREAT SEEKING
TREATMENT.
NEED TO KNOW THAT ANY PROVIDER
THEY SELECT MEETS AN EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENT STANDARD AND
THAT THOSE STANDARDS ARE BEING
ENFORCED BY THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SHE HAD SEEN IN HEARING NINE
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. THIRTY SEVEN OUR EYES
ZERO KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES.
X. REMOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN BY SENATOR -- TADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR D'AMATO AN AXE RELATING
TO SUICIDE PREVENTION.
CENTER A TITLE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT SB THREE THREE
ONE FULL REQUIRE ALL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP A SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRATEGIC PLAN.
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON ADOLESCENCE.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS EXPERIENCED A CONSTANT RISE
AND DEATH BY SUICIDE.
ALARMINGLY YOUTH SUICIDE AND
SELF INFLICTED INJURY ARE ON THE
RISE AND IS THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG YOUNG YOUTH
AGES FIFTEEN THROUGH TWENTY FOUR
IN THE U. S..
AND FOR OUR YOUNG WOMAN SUICIDE
RATES AMONG TEENAGE GIRLS HAVE
HIT A FORTY YEAR HI.
IN CALIFORNIA ALMOST ONE HALF OF
LGBT Q. STUDENTS REPORTED
SUICIDE -- IDEATION AND MORE
THAN THREE TIMES AS TO MY
BROTHER ST PEERS.
AND FRESNO COUNTY ALONE FOR EACH
TEAM WHO DIES BY SUICIDE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY YOUTH WERE
TREATED IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT.
BALLING SELF INJURY AND MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND ADOLESCENTS
BUT SERIOUSLY ABOUT AND IN THEIR
LIVES.
STUDIES SHOW THAT PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION EFFORTS CAN
HELP AVOID A SUICIDAL CRISIS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN CONVENING STAKEHOLDERS
FROM DIVERSE SECTORS LIKE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
HEALTHCARE YOUTH JUSTICE PUBLIC
SERVICE AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
TO HELP FORM STRATEGIC
PREVENTION ORIENTED PLANS.
WHEN COUNTIES IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIC SUICIDE PREVENTION
PLANTS THEY RESULT IN FEWER SO
YOUR SUICIDE DEATHS IN THEIR
COUNTY?
HOWEVER SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
ONLY SEVEN OF CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE ADOPTED
SUICIDE PREVENTION STRATEGIC
PLANS.
MORE PROACTIVE ACTION IS NEEDED
TO HELP ADDRESS SUICIDAL
BEHAVIOR AND PREVENT TEEN SO
ONCE TEEN SUICIDE INCLUDING A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON SUICIDE
PREVENTION FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE YOUTH.
SB THREE THREE ONE WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES ARE TAKING THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO HELP PREVENT
TEEN SUICIDE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM.
IT'S ELIGIBLE FOR A BILL I'M
SORRY SENATOR BILL -- YES THE
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS THE
MENTAL HEALTH CAUCUS HAD A A
SESSION ON SUICIDE PREVENTION
AND THIS THIS BILL WAS ONE OF
THE KEY ELEMENTS.
THAT WE NEED -- TO DEAL WITH WE
HAD SIXTY TWO HUNDRED SUICIDES
IN CALIFORNIA -- LAST YEAR AND
GET THOSE FORTY FOUR THOUSAND
ATTEMPTED SUICIDES IN CALIFORNIA
LAST YEAR WE NEED THIS BILL.
AND WE DID ALL THE THINGS WE CAN
DO TO STOP SUICIDES AND STOP THE
RISE IN SUICIDES IN CALIFORNIA
ARJUN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IN ADDITION --
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING ON CENTER OF
TITLE WHICH ELECT CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IN THIS MEASURE.
THIRTY SEVEN EYES ZERO KNOWS THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT BY SENATOR DODD MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
MR.
SENATOR WHEN YOU'RE READY MISS
PRESENT MEMBERS SB THREE FOR
FIFTY TWO WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF AB CD ISSUE UP TO
NEWT.
TEN NEW TYPE FORTY SEVEN
LICENSES IN THOSE COUNTIES OF
REACH THECURRENT LIMIT ON
ALCOHOL LICENSES.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW CURRENT LAW
PLACES A LIMIT ON THE NUMBER OF
ON SALE GENERAL LICENSES. TO ONE
LICENSE FOR EVERY TWO THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN THAT COUNTY WELL
THE SYSTEM WORKS FOR MOST.
THERE ARE A LARGE NUMBER OF
COUNTIES WHERE THE DEMAND FOR
ALCOHOL LICENSE FAR OUTWEIGHS
CURRENT NUMBER OF LICENSES.
IN NAPA COUNTY FOR INSTANCE THE
POPULATION IS LOW THAT'S THE
NUMBER OF LICENSES IS AS WELL
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF TOURISM THE
DEMAND FOR RESTAURANTS TO SERVE.
ALCOHOL IS MUCH HIGHER
INDIVIDUALS HOPING TO GET ARE.
OPEN A RESTAURANT IN THESE
COUNTY SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
FORCED TO GO TO THE OPEN MARKET
WERE LICENSES CAN COST UPWARDS
OF FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN OBSTACLE THAT MANY CANNOT
OVERCOME.
THIS RESULTS IN THE LOSS OF
REVENUE TO OUR CITIES IN OUR
STATE NOT TO MENTION LOTS OF
JOBS FOR COMMUNITIES.
AT A TIME MORE DEMAND FOR
RESTAURANTS AS AN ALL TIME HIGH
IT IS TIME FOR US TO RE EVALUATE
HOW THE STATE ISSUES THESE
LICENSES.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION THE BILL IS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
A THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEN HEARING NINE AT A TO
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU NOW IS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SHE NINE THIRTY EIGHT EYES ZERO
KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM NINETY NINE
BY SENATOR HILL.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY BY
SENATOR HILL AN ACT RELATING TO
MANDATED REPORTERS SENATOR HILL.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
UP MEMBERS OF THE CLERGY IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ALREADY MANDATED
CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT
REPORTERS.
BUT A LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS CLERGY TO LAWFULLY IGNORE
SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE ENDED IN
THE COLLECT IF THEY ACQUIRE THE
KNOWLEDGE DURING A CONVERSATION
THAT I INTENDED. TO BE
CONFIDENTIAL.
SB THREE SIXTY WOULD BEGIN TO
CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE BY REQUIRING
CLERGY TO REPORT SUSPECTED CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
IF THEY ACQUIRE THE KNOWLEDGE OR
SUSPICION DURING A PENITENTIAL
COMMUNICATION WITH AN EMPLOYEE
AT THEIR FACILITY FOR WITH
ANOTHER CLERGY MEMBER.
SB THREE SIXTY ALSO NARROWS THE
DEFINITION OF PENITENTIAL
COMMUNICATION. TO QUALIFIED THE
COMMUNICATION MUST BE VERBAL.
MADE PRIVATELY TO A CLERGY
MEMBER INTENDED TO BE AN ACT OF
CONTRITION OR MATTER OF
CONSCIENCE AND IN A CONTEXT OF
STRICT CONFIDENTIALITY THAT IS
CONSIDERED INVIOLATE BY CHURCH
DOCTRINE.
AS MANDATED CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT REPORTERS DOCTORS
PSYCHIATRISTS THERAPISTS AND
OTHERS SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT WITHOUT EXCEPTION.
CLERGY HAVE BEEN EXEMPT FROM
FULL REPORTING IF THEY BELIEVE
THE CONVERSATION WAS INTENDED TO
BE CONFIDENTIAL.
CHILD ABUSE WITHIN RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN MAKING OF
GLOBAL HEADLINES WITH POPE
FRANCIS RECENTLY PROPOSING
MANDATORY INTERNAL REPORTING
WITHIN THE CATHOLIC CHURCH.
IT'S ALSO A LOCAL ISSUE IN MARCH
A PRIEST WAS ARRESTED IN THE BAY
AREA ON SUSPICION OF THIRTY
COUNTS OF CHILD SEX ABUSE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IT SPANS
DENOMINATIONS WITH CASES COMING
OUT OF THE MORMON CHURCH
JEHOVAH'S WITNESSES.
AND UNITED METHODIST CHURCH.
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE
TRAILBLAZING WITH THIS MEASURE.
CONNECTICUT INDIANA MISSISSIPPI
NEBRASKA NEW HAMPSHIRE NEW
JERSEY NORTH CAROLINA OKLAHOMA
RHODE ISLAND TENNESSEE.
TEXAS AND WEST VIRGINIA ALREADY
HAVE SIMILAR STATUTE THEY
OPERATE UNDER THE SAME
CONSTITUTION AND BILL OF RIGHTS
AS WEAK.
AND HAVE FOUND NO LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO THOSE STATUTES
WHEN A CHILD IS BEING ABUSED OR
NEGLECTED THEY OFTEN DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HAPPENING TO
THEM.
WE RELY ON ADULTS WHO HEAR
SOMETHING OR SEE SOMETHING TO
SAY SOMETHING WHICH IS WHY
DOCTORS AND THERAPISTS MUST
REPORT.
CHILD ABUSE OR NEGLECT NO MATTER
WHAT FAITH LEADERS HAVE BEEN THE
ONLY EXCEPTION TO THIS RULE
AMONG MANDATED REPORTERS INSTEAD
OF PROTECTING CHILDREN.
SOME HAVE BEEN SHIELDING ABUSERS
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO PUT
CHILDREN FIRST I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL CALLING.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING.
NINE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A AUTUMN [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN'S [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MA'AM SIR TO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I UMBERG [inaudible]
HI.
NIELSEN NOTE I'D.
OUR EYES THIRTY KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP S FILE ITEM ONE A ONE
BY SENATOR STONE.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THAT
ITEM.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR STONE AN ACT RELATING O
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
STONE THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SO I'M HAPPY TO
PRESENT SB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR THE PROBLEM IS
CURRENTLY PLAYING CALIFORNIA'S
OR AMOUNT OF VETERANS WHO ARE
HOMELESS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAD TEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX HOMELESS VETERANS.
EQUATING TO ALMOST 30% OF THE
NATION'S TOTAL VETERAN
POPULATION.
VETERANS OF SACRIFICE SO MUCH
FOR OUR COUNTRY AND RETURN LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER. TO HELP THEM SUCCEED.
THERE'S NO SIMPLE SOLUTION IS
GOING TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS
REASONS FOR THE LARGE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS VETERANS ARE NUMEROUS
AND COMPLEX. TWO OF THE BIGGEST
FACTORS ARE THE EXTREME SHORTAGE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND A
LIVABLE INCOME.
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR ATTEMPTS TO
ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS AT
VETERANS FACED BY DOING THE
FOLLOWING.
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR CAPS THE
PROPERTY TAXES ON THE PRIMARY
RESIDENCE OF AN HONORABLY
DISCHARGED VETERAN.
OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE IT
ALSO PROVIDES A BASIC STEP IN
HELPING OUR VETERAN COMMUNITY BY
EXPANDING THEIR CURRENT PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION.
AND THE CURRENT REACH OF THE LAW.
CALIFORNIA'S HONORING THE
SACRIFICES THAT VETERANS AND
PROVIDING THEM WITH A WAY TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES SB SIX THREE
SIXTY FOUR PASSED OUT OF EVERY
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY.
AND WITH THAT I REQUEST PLEASE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT'S IT'S ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
NATURAL CALL I APOLOGIZE SHOW
ANY OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS ITEM.
SHE NINE THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
YOUR GAL.
I RISE TO ASK A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR ON ITEM FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT SB.
THREE FORTY SEVEN CENTER MONEY
WILL YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION FROM
SENIOR CENTER GALGIANI
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AND THIS IS THE THE BILL DEALING
WITH SWEETENED BEVERAGES AND I
WANTED TO CLARIFY.
IS IT IS IT IN THE BILL THAT
THERE WILL BE NO PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION FOR RESTAURANTS OR
COMPANIES THAT HAVE NOT COMPLIED
WITH THE BILL.
THERE IS NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IN THE BILL.
IT DOES NOT CREATE A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION I AM PREPARED TO
MAKE THAT EXPLICIT SHOULD THE
BILL MOVE FORWARD.
INCLUDING LANGUAGE THAT MAKES
EXPLICIT THAT IT DOESN'T CREATE
A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION OKAY
AND SECONDLY FOR ITS FOUR
RESTAURANTS PARTICULARLY THE
SMALL RESTAURANTS IN MY DISTRICT
TO HAVE BEEN HIT WITH.
LAYER UPON LAYER OF OF
REGULATIONS AND MEETING
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS -- IF
THEY DO NOT HAVE A SIGN POSTED.
IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP
YOUR SAID THAT THEY WON'T BE
SUED FOR NOT HAVING A SIGN
POSTED YES FIRST OF ALL THERE'S
NO PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
AGAINST THEM FOR NON COMPLIANCE
THERE IS A RIGHT TO CURE THE
FIRST NOTICE OF VIOLATION IS A
WARNING.
WITH THE RIGHT [inaudible] TO
CARE.
A SECOND VIOLATION LEADS TO A
FINE SPECIFIED IN THE STATUTE
AGAIN I'M PREPARED TO OFFER
FURTHER LANGUAGE MAKING THAT
EXPLICIT AN EXPLICIT RIGHT TO
CURE.
OKAY AND IF A SMALL BUSINESS
GETS DANG THAN THEIR WARNED AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET A NICE
FORMAL SIGN AND IN THE MEANTIME
THEY POST THEIR OWN SIGN THAT
HAS THE LANGUAGE BUT IT'S NOT A
FORMAL.
PAID FOR BY KIND OF SIGN IF IT'S
JUST POSTED.
DOES THAT TAKE CARE OF THEIR
OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE NOT FIND YES I'M WILLING I'M
PREPARED TO MAKE THAT EXPLICIT
IS WELL.
I THINK WHAT YOU FIND THE BILL'S
INTENT IS NOT TO BE A GOT SHOULD
BILL.
THE BILL'S INTENT IS PRIMARILY
TO MAKE SURE THE MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS.
CONTAIN THE WARNING LABEL THAT
GO TO MARKET THAT GO TO THE
SMALL MARKETS OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU.
GONNA LIST THE CALL ON ITEM FILE
ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
AMBERG [inaudible]
WILK.
CALL.
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD.
HI.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible] FIVE RUBIO
[inaudible]
I'M BURKE [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
I TWENTY ICE TWENTY ONE KNOWS A
LOT OF THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW MEMBERS TO FILE
ITEM ONE OH TWO QUESTION --
ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
THAT MEASURE UP.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT RELATING TO
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS.
AT THE GENERAL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPRESSANT --
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB THREE
NINETY TWO IT'S AN ACT. TO
UPDATED STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S.
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM IN ORDER
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
HAZARDOUS AND GROW THE CHEMICALS.
IN THEIR DAILY LIVES.
HI TEN YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISH THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
INITIATIVE INCLUDING.
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM INTO
THE DEPARTMENT TALK TO SUB IS
CONTROL.
SINCE THEN THE PROGRAM IS
DEVELOPED A ROBUST AND PROMISING
FRAMEWORK TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
HAZARDS US MANUFACTURERS. TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES IN
REGULATE BEST PRACTICES.
HOWEVER IN TEN YEARS. ZERO
PRODUCTS MEMBERS NOT A SINGLE
PRODUCT HAS SUCCESSFULLY GONE.
THROUGH THIS REGULATORY PROCESS
AND SO -- AT LAST YEAR.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE --
TOOK A TEN YEAR OF SURVEY OF THE
CURRENT GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM.
INTERVIEWED DOZENS OF
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS INDUSTRY
ACADEMIA GOVERNMENT TO FIND THE
CAUSES OF THIS SLOWDOWN IN THIS
IN ACTION.
IN A RELEASE THEIR FINDINGS AND
REPORT.
WE WERE ABLE TO HEAR THAT REPORT
IN A JOINT HEARING OF SEVERAL
COMMITTEES BOTH ON THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY SITES.
SO THIS BILL USES THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE REPORT.
TO STRENGTHEN THE PROGRAM AND
ALLOW IT TO ACHIEVE ITS GOALS.
HI SIXTY SUPPORT DTS SEES
MANAGEMENT SAVER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM BY BOTH
GRANTING THEM GREATER DATA CALL
IN AUTHORITY.
ALLOWING THEM TO MOVE MORE
QUICKLY TO ISSUE REGULATIONS
WHEN THERE IS NOT A BUT IT'S A
PUBLIC DATA.
AND SHIPPING THEIR EXISTING
PRODUCT WORK PLANS TO ENSURE
TIMELY IMPACTFUL REGULATORY
ACTIONS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE REGULATED
INDUSTRIES TO ENSURE THAT SB
THREE NINETY TWO WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS WHILE STILL.
RESPECTING BUSINESS NEED FOR
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
PROTECTIONS IN A PREDICTABLE AND
FAIR REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT. TEN
YEARS HAS ALREADY BEEN LONG
ENOUGH TO WAIT. FOR AN EFFECTIVE
EFFICIENT SCIENCE SPACE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM TO KEEP.
CALIFORNIA STATE SAVE.
MEMBERS I ASK US ALL THE LET'S
GET DOWN ON IT.
I ASK FOR HAVE A IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE SIDE ON HEARING AND
SEEING -- NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS ON AYE BATES
[inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI -- TADA [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible] FIVE
MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROB [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
HI MY CASKEY.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
NO.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH.
ICE TWENTY THREE KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS REMOVING BACK ON THE
FILE WE'RE GONNA RETURN TO FILE
ITEM NINETY SIX SENATOR MITCHELL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING
TO DISCRIMINATION. FOR YOUR
CENTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THE
HOUSING CRISIS AS WE ALL KNOW.
HAS HIT LOW INCOME RENTERS THE
HARDEST.
RISE HE RIPS LACK OF AVAILABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INSPECTED
INCOMES MAKE THIS POPULATION THE
MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS.
A HOMELESSNESS INCREASE ACROSS
THE STATE AND IN RECOGNITION OF
RISING RATE BURDEN BEING THE
PRIMARY DRIVER THIS HOMELESSNESS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
INCREASINGLY TURNING TO HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
THIS IS A HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION MEASURE THAT WILL
HELP TO STEM THE TIDE OF
HOMELESSNESS AND INSURE THOSE
EFFORTS ARE EFFECTIVE.
SB THREE TWENTY NINE WILL ENABLE
FAMILIES WITH HOUSING ASSISTANCE
TO SUCCESSFULLY APPLY FOR AND
OBTAIN HOUSING THAT THEY CAN
AFFORD.
IN NEIGHBORHOODS OF OPPORTUNITY
WITHOUT BE LITERALLY TURNED AWAY
AT EVERY DOOR AND FORCED TO
RETURN THEIR ASSISTANCE ON USE.
AS WE THINK SOLUTIONS TO HOUSING
SUPPLY ISSUES WE MUST ENSURE
STRICTLY RENTERS.
CAN ACCESS EXISTING HOUSING TO
EXISTING SUBSIDY PROGRAMS WHILE
SUPPLY SIDE MEASURES PLAY OUT.
I'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH MANY
OF YOU ABOUT THE SECTION EIGHT
PROGRAM IN SEOUL A NUMBER OF
VERY.
REASONABLE QUESTIONS HAVE COME
UP. FOR EXAMPLE HOW DIFFICULT IS
IT FOR ABOUT YOUR SISTER FAMILY
OR INDIVIDUAL TO FIND HOUSING.
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS OFTEN
WAIT YEARS TO RECEIVE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND EVEN WHEN THEY
CAN AFFORD THE RENT BEING ASKED
FOR WITH THEIR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
THEY OFTEN HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
FINDING THE LANDLORD THAT WILL
ACCEPT THE PAYMENT.
ONCE AN ELIGIBLE FOUND IN THE
WEIGHTLESS IS ISSUED A VOUCHER
THEY TYPICALLY ARE ONLY GIVEN
SIXTY DAYS TO SUCCESSFULLY FIND
AT LEAST HOUSING WITH THEIR
ASSISTANCE.
IF THEY ARE UNABLE TO MEET THE
FINE LINE THE ASSISTANCE IS
REVOKED WHICH MEANS THEY LOSE
THEIR VOUCHER.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT PUBLISHED A
REPORT THAT LOOKED AT THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF HOUSING FOR
FAMILIES WITH SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS.
THE STUDY FOUND THAT FOR EVERY
THIRTY NINE RENTAL
ADVERTISEMENTS FOR APARTMENTS
THAT A FAMILY WITH HOUSING
ASSISTANCE COULD AFFORD.
THERE WAS ONLY ONE THAT DID NOT
EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT VOUCHER
HOLDER FROM APPLYING.
YOU'VE SEEN THE NOTICES TWO
BEDROOM ONE BATH NO SECTION
EIGHT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT [inaudible]
INDEED.
WHERE WHERE WERE SB THREE TWENTY
NINTHS PROTECTIONS -- IN PLACE
WE WOULD HAVE MORE PEOPLE USING
THEIR VOUCHERS.
IN SITUATIONS WITH THOSE
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT IN PLACE WE
SEE THE NILE RATES AS HIGH AS
75% OR MORE.
COLLEAGUES I BELIEVE THE
SITUATION IS AN ACCEPTABLE IF WE
FIND OURSELVES FACING DATA THAT
75% OF GROCERY STORES REFUSE
FOOD STAMPS AND PEOPLE CAN USE
THAT ASSISTANCE.
TO EAT IT WILL BE PERCEIVED AS A
FAILURE OF PUBLIC POLICY.
SB THREE TWENTY NINE REPRESENTS
A PROVEN SOLUTION.
THE A THE HUD STUDY FOUND THAT
IN JURISDICTIONS WITH SOURCE OF
INCOME PROTECTIONS THIS DENIAL
RATE WAS ALMOST CUT IN HALF.
FOLKS OF EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS WOULD BE FORCED TO ACCEPT
ALL APPLICANTS WHO USE A HOUSING
VOUCHERS.
CLARIFICATION THIS BILL WILL NOT
REQUIRE THAT ALL LANDLORDS
EXCEPT EVERY VOUCHER HOLDING
APPLICANT NOR INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF DOCTORS IN THE MARKET.
THE BILL REQUIRES LANDLORDS TO
ALLOW ASSISTANT RESIDENTS TO
SUBMIT APPLICATIONS WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING LANDLORDS TO APPLY
THEIR RENTAL CRITERIA TO
ACCEPTED DID NOT A FAMILY WITH
ASSISTANCE IN THE SAME WAY THEY
WOULD ACCEPT OR DENY.
ANY OTHER POTENTIAL TENANTS.
THE BILL ALSO DOES NOT DICTATE
WHAT LANDLORDS MAY CHARGE FOR
RENT.
IF AN ASSISTED FAMILIES ABLE TO
AFFORD THE RENT BEING CHARGED
THE BILL ALLOWS THEM TO APPLY.
BUT DOES NOT FORCE LANDLORDS TO
RENT IT ANY SPECIFIC LEVEL OR TO
COMPLY WITH SECTION EIGHT
PAYMENT STANDARDS.
LASTLY A NUMBER OF YOU THEY ASK
QUESTIONS WITH REGARD.
TO THE A SECTION -- EIGHT
PROCESS BY WHICH YOU COULD GET
YOUR UNIT VERIFIED I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WE'RE ALL CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT IT TAKES.
SO WHAT STEPS ARE REQUIRED OF
LANDLORDS TO RECEIVE SECTION
EIGHT ANOTHER HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
THE LANDLORD COMPLETES AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY WHICH STATE THAT THEY
WILL MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY AND
COMPLY WITH THE PROGRAM
REGULATIONS AND HOUSING.
IF THE UNIT IS APPROVED IN THE
RENT BEING CHARGED WITH THE
PAYMENT STAND FOR THE PROGRAM
THE TENET IS ALLOWED TO USE
THEIR ASSISTANCE FOR THE UNIT
AND SIGNED THE LEASE WITH THE
LANDLORD.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT HOUSING AUTHORITIES
ALL ACROSS THE STATE ARE TYING
TO USE TECHNOLOGY ALLOWING
PEOPLE.
TO KIND OF PRE APPLY HAVE UNITS
PRE APPROVED EXCEPT ARE TO TRY
TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS.
I'VE SHARED WITH SOME OF YOU
DOCUMENTATION VERTICALLY WITH
REGARD TO HALFWAY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THAT CLEAR FIVE THAT IT
DOES NOT TAKE AS MUCH MS AS LONG
AS TWO MONTHS. TO GET A UNIT
APPROVED IT CAN HAPPEN WITHIN A
SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME UP TO A
WEEK AND A HALF TO TWO WEEKS.
SO WE WORKED VERY HARD TO
PROVIDE AS MUCH CLARIFICATION AS
POSSIBLE TO ALL OF YOU SO YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BASIC TENETS
OF THIS BILL.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT ONE SOURCE
OF INCOME DOESN'T BECOME.
A SOURCE OF DISCRIMINATION.
THAT JUST BECAUSE I HAVE A
HOUSING VOUCHER I SHOULD BE
TREATED ANY DIFFERENTLY FROM
ANYONE ELSE WHO APPLIES FOR YOUR
UNIT AND CAN AFFORD TO PAY THE
RENT.
AS WE TALK ABOUT WAYS IN WHICH
WE WANT ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
STOCK PRICES ARE HOMELESS THIS
CRISIS WE MUST CAPITALIZE ON THE
CURRENT.
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM SECTION
ACTUALLY STEP UP TO THE PLATE
AND ACCEPTED.
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SB.
THREE TWO NINE THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. TWO
BEDROOMS TWO BATHROOMS.
NO SECTION.
EIGHT YOU'RE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS YOU WORK YOUR HEART
OUT.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR A PLACE.
AND IT SAYS DESPITE FINALLY
GETTING AN OPPORTUNITY.
THERE IS NO REAL OPPORTUNITY.
THE DIGEST IN OUR ANALYSIS SAYS.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS LANDLORDS
FROM DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
TENANTS WHO RELY UPON THE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE PAID DIRECTLY
LANDLORDS SUCH A SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER. TO HELP THEM PAY THE
RENT.
PRETTY SIMPLE PRETTY BASIC WE
HAVE CERTAIN RIGHTS IN OUR
COUNTRY CERTAIN BSIC IDEAS
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
CLEAN WATER WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
WHAT WE BELIEVE IN IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY CRITICAL AND I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
WHAT I DO SO WITH THAT
ADMONITION TO THIS BODY?
NOT TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
BUT TO REALLY UNDERSTANDING WHAT
SECTION EIGHT IS.
IT'S OVER TWELVE HUNDRED PAGES
OF REGULATION.
THE TERMINATION PROVISIONS WHICH
I HAVE HERE ORDER SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING ARE PRETTY EGREGIOUS.
AGREE JUST ON BOTH SIDES WITH
THE YOUR TENANT OR LANDLORD.
I CAN GO THROUGH AND READ THEM I
LOOKED AT THEM AND THEY KIND OF
TURN MY STOMACH AND I DON'T WANT
TO GO ON TOO LONG.
BUT OWN TELLING YOU IS THAT
WE'VE GONE WHICH A CHALLENGE
HERE ONE THE ONE HAND WE'RE
WORKING ON THIS HOUSING PROBLEM
WE USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS. TO GO
OUT AND TO TRY TO FIND STUFF TO
GIVE PEOPLE HOPE AND THEN BE
LANDLORDS BECAUSE PARK WITH.
SUCH A TIME FOR ALL DIFFERENT
SORTS OF REASONS BUT THE REALITY
IS AND WHAT I WANT TO RAISE YOUR
AND I REYES WHEN CENTER LENO HAD
THIS MEASURE I RAISE IT AGAIN
BECAUSE IT SUPPORT IN THE
DISCUSSION.
IS THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
BE VIGILANT.
THAT EVEN THOUGH THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S CRITICAL AND WE
HAVE TO SUPPORT IT IS NECESSARY
IT MEANS THAT ALL OF US IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THE DETAIL.
THE GREAT ARCHITECT IN FROM FROM
CHICAGO MEETS VANDROSS SAYS GODS
IN TE DETAILS I DON'T BELIEVE
DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS I BELIEVE
GOD IS IN THE DETAILS WOULD YOU
FOCUS ON THE DETAILS.
AND WHEN YOU DON'T JUST LOOK AT
THE TOP LINE BUT START DIGGING
IN ABOUT HOW PEOPLE ARE IMPACTED
ON ALL SIDES WE CAN'T STOP THE
FIGHT THIS IS A CRITICAL ELEMENT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS FIGHT.
BUT IT IS ONLY A A GIGANTIC
CRITICAL STEP BUT IT IS NOT THE
ONLY STEP I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK CENTER CENTER HUESO.
THANK YOU -- INITIALLY I I HEARD
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE --
PRETTY MUCH EVERY EVERY RENTER
DATED TO TO GO INTO -- THE
SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM SO WE
STARTED REALLY DIGGING INTO THIS
BILL AND READING THE LANGUAGE
AND I COULDN'T FIND ANYBODY OUT
THERE.
ANYWHERE TO PROVIDE ME WITH THE
LANGUAGE PROVISION OF THE BILL
THAT DID THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TALKING ABOUT.
THE DEVIL BEING IN THE DETAILS.
FORGOT BEING IN THE DETAILS OR
US THE LEGISLATURE REALLY VERY
VERY NOT THE DETAILS.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT WE WORK VERY HARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WE HOUSE EVERYONE
IN THE STATE AND AND THE SECTION
EIGHT PROGRAM -- IS IS BEING
CRITICIZED CURRENTLY BY THE
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL SENATE
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
BUREAUCRACY TO SORT THROUGH.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO CONSIDER ESPECIALLY WHEN.
YOU MAY HAVE -- SOME SOME PEOPLE --
THAT ARE -- UNSOPHISTICATED IN
THE IN IN THE PROCESSES OF
RENTING MAYBE A LITTLE SIDE UNIT
THEY HAVE OR A OR A HOME THEY
HAVE BEEN CAUGHT UP IN THIS NOT.
NECESSARILY WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SECTION EIGHT
PROGRAM [inaudible]
BUT THIS IS A DIFFICULT MATTER --
BECAUSE I I I WANNA ONE OF ALL.
FOUR FOUR HOUSING MORE PEOPLE
BUT AT THE SAME TIME HOW DO YOU
DO THAT WITHOUT.
REQUIRING PEOPLE TO DO -- ONE
ONE THING IN PARTICULAR IN THIS
CASE SAYING YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT
SECTION EIGHT YOU HAVE TO WAIT.
FOR AN INSPECTION IN SOME
INSTANCES I AM I'M GETTING SOME
DATA THAT SHOWS THAT SOME PEOPLE
OF WAITED THREE THREE MONTHS TO
GET THAT INSPECTION.
AND THAT COMES AT A COST IT'S
NOT COMPENSATED TO THE PROPERTY
OWNERS AND THAT MADE -- CREATE A
ARE A BURDEN.
ON ON THE SMALLER -- PROPERTY
OWNERS WHO RAN.
AND AND MAY -- OFTENTIMES HAVE A
MORTGAGE ATTACHED TO PROPERTY.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WHILE I
HOLD.
THE ARE YOU KNOW IF IF THAT
CONTINUES TO COME UP DURING THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS OF THE THAT
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL BE SAID
SYMPATHETIC. TO THAT LOOKING AT
THAT TO SEE IF THE THE SMALLER
PEOPLE THAT.
WOULD BE AFFECTED BY THIS AND
IMPOSE ON WHO WOULD BE IMPOSED.
WHO WHO OF HOME A HARDSHIP WOULD
BE IMPOSED ON?
IN GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
BOB I I HOPE YOU KNOW I HOPE
THAT WE DON'T -- MAKE IT SO
PEOPLE TAKE PROPERTIES OFF THE
MARKET BUT YOU KNOW WHAT IN THE
SPIRIT OF THE BILL.
IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL.
I I'M LOOKING AT THE BILL
LOOKING AND SAYING I THINK THIS
BILL IS WELL WRITTEN.
I THINK IT IT GETS TO WHAT WE
ALL WANT TO SEE [inaudible]
A OPPORTUNITY.
A FAIR SYSTEM IN WHICH PEOPLE
ARE ARE [inaudible]
OUR OF ARE ARE GIVEN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR REVIEW AND IF
THE PEOPLE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
FIND THAT HOUSING THERE ALSO
FINDING A WAY TO RESOLVE.
THE CHALLENGES WITHIN THE
SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM.
IF THERE ARE ANY BURDENS ARE
POSED UPON THE PEOPLE THERE ARE
THERE ARE PARTICIPATING IN THIS
IN THIS RENTAL ECONOMY -- WE
NEED TO FIX THOSE -- BUT
GENERALLY.
I I DO NOT SUPPORT
DISCRIMINATION.
AND THIS IS A DISCRIMINATION
ISSUE AND I THINK.
ON THAT BASIS -- EVERYONE
EVERYONE HERE SHOULD COME UP ON
THIS BILL THIS IS A RIGHTEOUS
BILL -- THE THIS IS THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO VOTE FOR HERE
NONE OF US HERE OR ANONE OUT
THERE.
IN OUR STAGES FOR DISCRIMINATION
OF ANY BODY AND THERE ARE IF
THERE ARE CHALLENGES I'M SURE
ANYBODY OUT THERE CAN WORK
THROUGH THEM AND I'M SURE.
WE WILL WE WILL STAY -- VIGILANT
ON THIS ISSUE AND HELP OUR OUR
THE PEOPLE ARE COMMUNITY SORT TO
KIND OF THOSE CHALLENGES IN THIS
PROGRAM BUT BUT I JUST WANT.
TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
OF UP THIS THIS MATTER.
THANKYOU AND WE'RE SO CENTER
OUR MEMBERS I SO I VOTED FOR
THIS IN COMMITTEE HI IT WAS.
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED -- BY THE SENATE FROM SAN
DIEGO WERE RAISED TO ME IN
MEETINGS AFTERWARDS AND I DID
WANT TO RAISE AN ISSUE AND AND
ASK.
THE AUTHOR -- ABOUT THE IT SEEMS
AS THOUGH ONE OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES AT PLAY HERE.
IS THAT THERE ARE -- DID THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TASKS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS INTERNET YOU
YOU TOO QUESTION YEAH IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TASK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY -- INSPECTION AND
OTHER ISSUES RELATING TO THE
GRANTING OF SEXUALLY FINES FOR
PARTICULAR PROPERTY.
AND WHAT I'VE HEARD THAT IN MY
DISTRICT APPARENTLY CITY SANTA
MONICA.
IS VERY FAST AND VERY QUICK AND
AND DOES THESE THINGS WELL IN
FACT WAS A GROUP OF FOLKS WHO
DON'T OFTEN.
A COMPLEMENT THE CITY SANTA
MONICA WHO WERE IN MY OFFICE --
FROM THE LANDLORD SIDE -- BUT ON
THIS ISSUE THEY SAID THIS IS IN
A MARKET HAS BEEN DOING A
FANTASTIC JOB WITH REGARDS. TO
QUICK TURNAROUND FOR SEXUALLY
HOUSING BUT THAT IN THE CITY OFLOS ANGELES.
THERE WERE ENORMOUS DELAYS
ENORMOUS PROBLEMS.
CAN YOU SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
DISPARITIES IT SEEM TO EXIST AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND TALK ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IF WE PASS SOMETHING LIKE
THIS TO ENSURE THAT MORE
LOCALITIES.
ARE ARE ACTING IN A QUICK AND
FARE -- EXPEDITED MANNER IN
MAKING SURE THAT -- THAT THAT
YOU KNOW THERE'S COULD TURN
AROUND.
DO YOU MIND IF I JUST AT MY
CLOSING.
OUR SERVER I IN THE BE FINE YEAH
BUT I PLAN TO OKAY LET ME JUST
THAT MICHAEL YEAH OKAY SO I'M
I'M VERY MUCH LOOKING FOR DO YOU
YOUR CLOSING.
THAT THAT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT I
THINK MEMBERS WE PASS THIS BILL
IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO SPEND
SOME TIME LOOKING AT THAT --
THAT THERE IS THERE ARE THERE
ARE WAYS TO DO THIS RIGHT AND
ACTUALLY MAKE A VERY
ADVANTAGEOUS TO LANDLORDS A LOT
OF LAND WAS ACTUALLY REALLY LIKE
SECTIONING ONCE THEY GET THE
TENANTS IN BECAUSE IT'S A
REGULAR PAYCHECK IT SHOWS UP ON
TIME.
NEVER BOUNCES YOU KNOW THERE'S
NOT ANY PROBLEMS BUT THE ISSUE
IS WITH THE INSPECTIONS AND THE
THE FRONT END.
IN SOME CITY SEEM TO DO WELL
OTHER CITIES DOWN -- WE CAN MAKE
THIS PROGRAM WORK A LOT BETTER
IF WE CAN REPLICATE WHAT'S
HAPPENING THE CITIES ARE DOING A
RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR PROTON ATKINS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- I
THINK A LOT OF THINGS I COULD
HAVE SAID OF ALREADY BEEN SAID
IN TERMS OF WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT CRITICALLY AT THIS
TIME.
JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS -- YOU
KNOW CITIES ARE GETTING BETTER
AT THIS BECAUSE OVER THE LITTLE
OVER THE YEARS -- THERE WAITING
LISTS HAVE GROWN AND THEY'VE
THEY FOCUSED MY CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IS FOCUSED VERY HEAVILY ON
WORKING WITH LANDLORDS. TO GET
THESE ISSUES IRONED OUT BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO USE
THOSE VOUCHERS AND BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE CASE -- IN THE EVENT
THAT OTHERS BECOME AVAILABLE --
WHETHER IT'S VAST VOUCHERS FOR
VETERANS OR JUST THE GENERAL
POOL -- SO I DO KNOWS THAT
HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN PUBLIC
HOUSING AGENCIES ARE WORKING ON
THAT VERY ISSUE.
YOU KNOW I WANTED TO SAY IN MY
CITY WHERE THERE'S MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND FAMILIES ON
A WAITING LIST -- AND WE HAVE
BEEN BUILDING HOUSING IN SAN
DIEGO FOR DECADES --
PARTICULARLY WHEN I WAS ON THE
COUNCILAND WE HAD REDEVELOPMENT
WE COULD USE THAT 20% SET ASIDE
TO BUILD -- THE AFFORDABLE UNITS
WHICH ALSO -- THEY COULD ACCESS
VOUCHERS.
YOU KNOW ABOUT FOR A FAMILY WHO
HAS WAITED EIGHT TO TEN TWELVE
YEARS TO FINALLY BE APPROVED FOR
A VOUCHER.
AND THEN HAVE IT JERKED RIGHT
OUT FROM UNDER THEIR FEET
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO FIND
A UNIT OF HOUSING IN A TIMELY
FASHION.
THAT'S JUST WRONG IT'S A I WOULD
SAY ALMOST CRUEL -- AND FINALLY
YOU KNOW.
I RECALL WHEN I WAS A STAFF
MEMBER CHRIS KEYHOE AT THE CITY
COUNCIL I BEG TO DO HOUSING I
WANTED TO DO HOUSING AND I
LEARNED A LOT -- IN THE IN THE
MID NINETIES WHEN I WENT TO WORK
FOR HER. 10% VACANCY RATES IN
NORTH PARKING MY COLLEAGUE FROM --
SAN DIEGO -- AND AND SOUTHERN
SAN DIEGO WILL REMEMBER THIS --
BECAUSE HE WORKED IN THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY A NUMBER OF
YEARS -- AS THAT WE WERE COMING
OUT OF THAT RECESSION.
AT 10% VACANCIES 12% VACANCIES --
AND LAND OF PROPERTY OWNERS
SMALL COMPLEXES THEY COUNTED.
ON THE SAN DIEGO HUSING
COMMISSION TO BE A PARTNER WITH
THEM AT THAT TIME.
THERE WERE THERE WAS NO DEBATE
AND DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE TYPE
OF PEOPLE OR YOU KNOW THESE ARE
SMALL -- PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
WERE STRUGGLING.
AND SO THEY WERE HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE -- THE OTHER THING I
WOULD SAY -- THIS REALLY IS
ABOUT OPPORTUNITY NOT
REQUIREMENTS BUT OPPORTUNITY AND
I THINK WHEN YOU MEET THE
FAMILIES AND THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ON THESE WAITING LISTS
THAT HAVE WAITED SO LONG.
AND YOU YOU SEE WHO THEY ARE
THESE ARE STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED A HOME WHO
HAVE WAITED -- AND IF YOU ALSO
THEN LOOK AT THE REQUIREMENTS AS
AS MY COLLEAGUE OFFROM OUR SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY POINTED OUT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REQUIREMENTS.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE A PERCEPTION
THAT THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
VOUCHERS.
SOMEHOW THEY'RE NOT GOOD TENANTS.
AND I RECALL AS A STAFF MEMBER
GETTING THOSE COMPLAINTS AND I
WAS A I DID CONSTITUENTS
SERVICES AND I RECALL.
TALKING TO PEOPLE WHO SAID I
KNOW THAT UNIT IN THAT BUILDING
IS A PROBLEM I KNOW IT'S SECTION
EIGHT IT'S PUBLIC HOUSING.
AND THESE ARE BAD PEOPLE THERE
DISRUPTING MY QUIET THEY'RE
DOING THIS OR DOING THAT IN
AVIDLY I WOULD CHECK ON THAT.
ADDRESS AND THAT UNIT AND FIND
OUT THERE WERE NO SECTION EIGHT
TENANTS IN THAT BUILDING THERE
WERE NO UNITS.
THEY WERE ALL MARKET RATE
[inaudible]
HOUSING.
SO.
YOU KNOW THERE WAS A POINT IN
TIME MY POINT IN ALL THIS THERE
WAS A POINT IN TIME WHEN
PROPERTY OWNERS.
WE'RE PARTNERS BECAUSE THEY
NEEDED THERE THEY NEEDED THIS
THE CHECK THEY NEEDED THE THE
SUPPORT TO TO KEEP THEIR
PROPERTY.
AS THEIR PROPERTY AND MAKE IT --
VIABLE AND SUSTAINABLE AND SO IT
WAS FINE. TO ALLOW OPPORTUNITY
AND ACCESS AT THAT TIME.
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE HAVE A MARKET
THAT IS LESS THAN 5% LESS THAN
3%.
AND P. AND AND PEOPLE CAN BE
MORE CHOOSY AND THEY THINK IF
THEY CAN BE MORE PICKY PICKY IN
CHOOSING.
THEY WILL HAVE BETTER TENNIS
IT'S A MYTH IT'S IT'S A FALSE.
PREMISE BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
THAT ARE IN THOSE UNITS.
THEY TEND TO BE THE ONES THAT
FOLLOW THE RULES THAT ARE SO
GRATEFUL TO BE GIVEN THIS
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THEY'VE
WAITED SO LONG.
SO.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
DISCONNECT HAPPENED OVER THE
YEARS THAT THAT OPPORTUNITY WAS
SOMEHOW GONE WHEN IT REALLYUSED
TO BE THERE FOR FAMILIES.
THE DISCRIMINATION WAS LESS
LIKELY WHEN PEOPLE NEEDED THE
SUPPORT AND THE RESOURCE.
SO I JUST FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I KNOW A GUY YEAH WE
WE ARE.
WE MAYBE SPEND A LITTLE TOO MUCH
TIME TALKING ABOUT FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE BUT THIS IS
INTERESTING TO ME IN TERMS.
OF THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT THE
THE ABILITY FOR PROPERTY OWNERS
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND MATCHING
THAT WITH THE NEED OF PEOPLE WHO
JUST ARE ASKING FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO NINETY NINE
POINT 9% OF THE TIME HAVE HAD TO
BE VETTED IN ORDER TO EVEN GET.
A VOUCHER AND AN OPPORTUNITY SO
I WOULD JUST REMIND MY
COLLEAGUES -- ABOUT THOSE
EXPERIENCES BECAUSE I LIVED IT
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AS I TRIED TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC THAT THAT
COMPLAIN YOU JUST MADE ABOUT
THAT PROPERTY I WANT TO KNOW.
TO PLEASE I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
EDUCATE YOU THAT THAT'S MARKET
RATE HOUSING THAT IS NOT A
PERSON ON A SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER.
SO GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY LET
THE PROPERTY OWNERS SEE YOU AT
FACE VALUE AND AND SEE WHO YOU
ARE.
AND TAKE A A YOU KNOW TAKE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY VYING FOR
HOUSING AND I GUARANTEE YOU --
THOSE ARE THE TENANTS THAT WILL
BE YOUR BEST TENANTS I SO
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES FOR OUR
BRING IN THIS ITEM FORWARD AGAIN.
AND I AGREE AGAIN WITH MY FELLOW
SAN DIEGANS EVERYONE SHOULD
SUPPORT THIS.
THIS IS THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO FOR THE RIGHT REASONS AND
WE HAVE ALL THE PROOF
HISTORICALLY WE NEED.
THAT IT WORKS.
AND IT AND IT'S GOOD SO I URGE
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK.
SHARKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TOM.
ORANGE COUNTY TO HAS A LONG
WAITING LIST.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WAITING FOR A
LONG TIME TO GET THEIR VOUCHERS.
AND TRYING TO FIGURE THAT OUT AS
A COUNTY SUPERVISOR YOU DO GET
THE STORIES AS THIS [inaudible]
SENATOR FROM.
ROLL CENTER FROM SAN DIEGO THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM YOU YOU START
TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON AND YOU YOU.
YOU START TO HEAR LANDLORDS GIVE
STORIES ABOUT.
BAD TENANTS AND I DON'T KNOW IF
IT IS A MYTH.
WE WOULD HOPE THAT EVERYONE
THAT'S ON THIS PROGRAM AND
FINALLY GETS TO BENEFIT FROM IT
IS GRATEFUL BUT MAYBE SOME THINK
IT'S AN ENTITLEMENT AND THEN.
DO NOT -- TREAT THE OPPORTUNITY
WITH THE RESPECT.
THAT THEY SHOULD.
OR AND MAYBE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED.
AND SO THERE IS THIS.
FRUSTRATION FROM THE MARKET
PLACE WITH WITH THE PROGRAM.
AND SO I APPRECIATE WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO SO I JUST
HAD. ONE OR TWO QUICK QUESTIONS.
IF I MAY MISTER PRESIDENT
DETERMINES TO INTO QUESTION OF
COURSE.
I AM SURE.
SENATOR THAT YOU HAVE.
GONE THROUGH ALL THE LEGAL
RAMIFICATIONS.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOW DEALING WITH
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS AND I'M
WONDERING.
IF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WOULD
BE CONSIDERED UNCONSTITUTIONAL
TAKING.
IT IS NOT BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
REQUIRING THAT A LAND OWNER
EXCEPT A SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER
WHAT WE ARE SAYING IS THAT YOU
MUST INCLUDE.
YOUR SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER IN
YOUR ALREADY ESTABLISHED
CRITERIA IN TERMS OF QUITE SURE
YOU ESTABLISH AS A LANDLORD
[inaudible]
FOR RENTING.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THAT IF YOU
SIR HAVE A VOUCHER I DO NOT?
THAT AS LONG AS BOTH OF US MEET
THE SAME BACKGROUND CHECK AND
CREDIT CHECK.
NOW WE COME OUT EVEN.
THAT YOU ARE AUTOMATICALLY
ELIMINATED FROM CONSIDERATION.
BASED ON THE SOURCE OF YOUR
INCOME.
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT A PORTION OF
THE SOURCE OF YOUR INCOME IS A
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER.
IT DOES NOT MANDATE THAT THE
LANDLORD ACCEPTED.
IT STATES THAT THE LANDLORD DOES
NOT GET TO ARBITRARILY --
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST YOU BASED
ON THE SOURCE OF YOUR INCOME.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DEBATE ERR
ON THE SIDE ON SCENE HEARING
NINE ANSWER MISTER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT NOT PRE SHEET THE
OPPORTUNITY.
LET ME FIRST ADDRESS MY
COLLEAGUE -- FROM SANTA MONICA I
DON'T WANT HIM TO THINK I FORGOT
HIS QUESTION A WITH REGARD -- TO
THE INCONSISTENCIES OF HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- PRIMARILY HOUSING
AUTHORITIES ACROSS THE STATE
DEAL WITH THEIR SECTION EIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES.
ON AND I THINK -- YES I'VE GOT
OF MUNICIPALITIES IN MY DISTRICT
THAT DO VERY WELL AND AS A
RESULT A GOOD YOU KNOW LANDLORDS
WELCOME SECTION.
EIGHT AND I TO HAVE HEARD SOME
OF THE COMPLAINTS POSITIVELY
WITH REGARD TO LOS ANGELES.
AS DID THE CITY COUNCIL AND
OTHERS WHICH IS WHY THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY PRODUCED IN THE END OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN LESS THAN SIX
MONTHS AGO.
A REPORT BACK THE HOUSING
AUTHORITY OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN THE LOS ANGELES
HOUSING COMMUNITY INVESTMENT
DEPARTMENT WITH CONSULTATION
FROM THE CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
REPORT REGARDING CITY OR DOES TO
PROTECT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RENTERS.
UTILIZING RENTAL ASSISTANCE FOR
OTHER SOURCES OF INCOME AS
PAYMENT.
ON PAGE FOUR OF THAT REPORT PAY
SIX OF THAT REPORT IT'S STATE
PERMISSION TO READ.
THANK LATE THANK YOU.
HAPLESS.
POLICY IS THAT ALL INITIAL
INSPECTIONS AND RE INSPECTIONS
ARE SCHEDULED WITHIN TWO TO
THREE DAYS IF THE UNIT IS READY
FOR INSPECTION.
HOW COOL IS ALSO WORKING TO
PROCESS ANNUAL RATE INCREASES
FAMILY AND DOES AND DOES PROCESS
RATE INCREASES RETROACTIVELY IF
APPLICABLES?
AND SO WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
DIFFERENT TIME FRAMES I HEARD
FROM A COLLEAGUE TODAY THAT THEY
HEARD THAT IT TAKES AS MUCH AS
TWO TO THREE MONTHS.
AND SO WE ARE WORKING HARD TO
GET A CLEAR PICTURE THE CIVIC
LEE FROM.
LA COUNTY ABOUT HOW LONG IT
REALLY DOES TAKE.
AS I STATED PREVIOUSLY I THINK
THAT A HOUSING AUTHORITIES ARE
WORKING HAVE HEARD THAT
COMPLAINT ARE WORKING HARD. TO
REALLY TRY TO CREATE -- MINIMAL
DELAYS FOR LANDLORDS IN
NAVIGATING THEIR PROCESS.
THEY'RE WORKING ACTIVELY TO
REDUCE THE TIME FOR INSPECTION
SUMMER USING -- PRE INSPECTION
PROGRAMS IN REAL TIME ELECTRONIC
INSPECTIONS TO REDUCE DELAYS FOR
THINK THAT THERE ARE EXAMPLES
ALL ACROSS THE STATE -- WHERE
TECHNOLOGY ON THIS BEING USED TO
TRY TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS OF?
COULD LA COUNTY DO A BETTER JOB.
WITHOUT QUESTION ON DOES LA
COUNTY PERHAPS HAVE THE LARGEST
POOL OF VOUCHERS I DON'T KNOW
THAT FOR A FACT BUT BASS IN THE
POPULATION I WOULD ASSUME SO.
AND SO I THINK WE HAVE A
COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
WORK ARM IN ARM HAND IN HAND
WITH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
FIGURE OUT.
IS IT RESOURCES WHAT IS THE CASE
BUT TO PUT PRESSURE ON THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT
GOVERNMENT IS IN CREATING A
BOTTLENECK.
THAT'S COMPLICATED OUR
COLLECTIVE ABILITY TO TAP INTO A
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM. TO
HELP PEOPLE FAYE HOUSE.
THE POPULATION WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE
ISSUES WE HAVE RAISED HERE ON
THE FLOOR TODAY AND TALK ABOUT
THAT NAUSEAM.
BASED ON WHAT WE CAN FRONT ONLY
GO HOME TO OUR DISTRICTS EVERY
DAY.
LASTLY I BELIEVE I WOULD SAY ON
A RESPONSE MOM TO CONTINUE THE
POINTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO.
THE POINT OF THE BILL IS TO END
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON SOURCE
OF INCOME AND I GUESS WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES.
WHO WE THINK IS WORTH HELPING?
THERE ARE SENIOR VOUCHER
PROGRAMS THERE VETERAN VOUCHER
PROGRAM.
SECTION EIGHT TYPICALLY FOCUSES
ON LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
THERE ARE ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM TO
HELP THOSE WITH PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES COOL IT IS WORTH
HELPING.
IN YOUR INDIVIDUAL OPINION.
YOU KNOW RICHARD GET A BAD RAP.
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO RENT.
WE HAVE A REAL BIAS AND A
PERCEPTION OF THOSE WHO RENT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY AREN'T GONNA VALUE THE
PROPERTY THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
LIVE.
IN -- HEALTHY HABITABLE
STANDARDS BUT RENTERS GET A BAD
RAP.
THE COMMUNITY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WHERE I RAN BECAUSE WE'RE HERE
FOUR DAYS A WEEK.
HAS A STIPULATION THAT YOU CAN'T
USE THE BENEFITS OF THE CLUB IN
THE POOL IF YOUR RENTER.
AND I'M CERTAIN THE RENT ON PAIN
PROBABLY COVERS THE WHOLE
MORTGAGE ON THE PROPERTY.
AND SO RENTERS GET A BAD RAP.
AND SO I JUST ASK THAT WE
CONSIDER WHAT IS THE REAL ISSUE
WITH REGARD TO THIS BILL.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
IT'S NOT GOING TO INCREASE
VALUES IN THE SYSTEM IT DOESN'T
WORK IN AT AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN
ON HOUSING BIRD ON HOUSING
AUTHORITIES BECAUSE THERE AREN'T
ADDITIONAL DOCTORS COME INTO THE
SYSTEM.
WE WORK TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
REALLY OLD HOUSING AUTHORITIES
FEET TO THE FIRE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE COMPLICATING THIS
PROCESS BY CREATING LONG DELAYS.
THE QUESTION IS WHO IS WORK
HELPING.
AND THE SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM A
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO HELP LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND PREVENT THEM FROM
BEING ON THE STREET WERE FAR TOO
MANY CURRENTLY ARE.
WITH FAST WITH THAT I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION
OF SENATE BILL.
THREE TWO NINE THANK SENATOR.
ALSTON CAM OUT MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE SIDE
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL [inaudible]
I GORGEOUS [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
I THEIR OTHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I TELL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
NO.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO ROCK [inaudible]
OUR CALL ABSENT MEMBERS FROM
LAST TIME [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
ROTH.
ALL EYES TWENTY FOUR KNOW THE
LOVE AND THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON MEMBERS NOW TO FILE
ITEM.
ONE OH THREE SOONER HUESO ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THAT
ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
[inaudible]
SOONER HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT OF
COLLEAGUES SO I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AS BEFORE TO TO THIS IS.
A OF A GREAT BILL THAT.
AIMS TO REMOVE A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY --
HE INTO SOCIETY.
BY YOUNG EX OFFENDERS.
IN RECENT DECADES.
THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS WHO COME
INTO CONTACT WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS INCREASED
EXPONENTIALLY BETWEEN NINETEEN
EIGHTY AND TWO THOUSAND NINE
CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS POPULATION.
HAS INCREASED 510083%. FOR MANY
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS.
A THREE YEAR SENTENCE A FIVE
YEAR SENTENCE A TEN YEAR
SENTENCE IS A LIFE SENTENCE.
MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS CAN'T
SUCCESSFULLY RE INTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY EVEN IF THEY ARE.
GO TO SCHOOL EVEN IF THEY GET A
DEGREE.
THERE ARE -- THERE.
THERE IF THERE THE PAST STAYS
WITH THEM FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES A RECENT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION REPORT INDICATED.
THAT YOUNGER FELONS RECIDIVISTS
EIGHT AT THE HIGHEST RATES
BECAUSE OF THIS INMATES RELEASED
AT AGE TWENTY FOUR YOUNGER
RETURN TO PRISON AT A RATE OF
SIXTY SEVEN POINT 2%.
SB FOUR TWO TWO CREATES AN
EMPLOYER TAX CREDIT WHICH WILL
ALLOW A QUALIFIED EMPLOYER WHO
HIRES A FORMERLY INCARCERATED
USE.
UP A AS FULL AND GIVES A FULL
TIME JOB.
IT GIVES THEM A CREDIT IN AN
EQUAL OF AN AMOUNT EQUAL 250% OF
QUALIFIED WAGES PAID BY THE
TAXPAYER.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT IT COST
APPROXIMATELY. SIXTY THOUSAND A
YEAR TO INCARCERATE A PRISONER
IN STATE OF OF CALIFORNIA.
IF THIS PROGRAM KEEPS.
TWELVE YOUNG EX OFFENDERS FROM
RE OFFENDING THEN THIS PROGRAM
COST STATE.
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
GIVEN THE SOCIAL BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH AN EX OFFENDER
NOT GOING BACK TO PRISON
ULTIMATELY THE SAVINGS WOULD BE
EVEN GREATER.
I I US FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS.
A COURSE AND HAS BROUGHT A BROAD
COALITION OF SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MADAM SECRETARY.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING AN OUNCE ROLL CALL WE
HAVE WE HAVE AN OBJECTION SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES.
I WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ERA [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THEIR OSEM [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I'VE SKINNER [inaudible] FIVE
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WOULD CASTING [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
JACKSON. FIVE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI.
I WAS THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP FOLLOWING ITEM ONE OH
FOUR SENATOR JACKSON YOU'RE
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
I WILL FINISH SENATE BILL FOR
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR JACKSON
AND ACTUALLY DID TOBACCO
PRODUCTS THE NEW JACKSON THANK
YOU MISS PRESS AND COLLEAGUES
ONE OF THE IF NOT THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF LITTER.
IN OUR BEACHES IN OUR STREETS IN
OUR STATE IN OUR COUNTRY TODAY
COMES FROM CIGARETTE ****.
IF YOU'VE EVER DONE A BEACH
CLEAN UP OR COMMUNITY CLEAN UP.
THE NUMBER OF CIGARETTE **** IS
ASTONISHING.
THAT ARE LEFT ON THE STREETS
MANY OF WHICH COMPRISE PLASTIC
MATERIALS THAT ARE DANGEROUS.
TODAY WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT WATER QUALITY.
THE CIGARETTE **** ARE A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE WHEN IT
COMES TO TRYING TO CLEAN UP OUR
WATER.
AND INDEED THE COST OF THIS
CLEAN UP THE COST OF THE
CIGARETTE **** THAT THE GRADE
RIGHT THERE ON THE STREET IN IN
OUR WATER SOURCES COSTS ARE
COMMUNITIES MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR.
AND THE IMPACT OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS CANNOT BE THE MINIMIZED
THEY LEACH INTO OUR OF THESE
TOXIC CHEMICALS LEACH INTO OUR
WATERWAYS OUR MARINE.
ENVIRONMENT AFFECTING WATER
QUALITY AND ARE CREATING A
SIGNIFICANT HAZARD TO WILDLIFE.
SO THERE ARE ALSO.
NEW CATEGORIES OF PLASTIC
ELECTRONIC WASTE RESULTING FROM
NEW TOBACCO PRODUCTS SUCH AS E.
CIGARETTES AND VAPORIZERS.
WHICH CARRY THEIR OWN HARM TO
WILDLIFE.
THE ENVIRONMENT AND OUR WATER
SUPPLY.
AND WITHOUT SETTING UP A PROGRAM
FOR THE COLLECTION OF THESE NEW
WASTE TYPES IN COORDINATION WITH
THE MANUFACTURERS OF THESE
PRODUCTS.
ARE LOCAL AGENCIES WILL HAVE AN
EVEN COSTLIER WASTE STREAM ON
THEIR HANDS MEANING THAT YOU AND
I AS TAXPAYERS WILL BE PICKING
UP.
THE BILL FOR THIS CLEANUP.
SO SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR ADDRESSES
THE PROBLEM OF TOBACCO WASTE
THROUGH A TWO FOLD APPROACH
FIRST THE BILL BANS THE SALE OF
SPECIFIED SINGLE USE TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SECOND THIS BILL REQUIRES
THAT ALL MULTI USE TOBACCO
PRODUCTS BE RECYCLABLE BY EITHER
A LOCAL OR STATE RECYCLING
PROGRAM.
IF A COMPONENT IS NOT ORDINARILY
RULES RECYCLABLE THEN THE
MANUFACTURER OF THE PRODUCT MUST
EITHER SET UP A COLLECTION OR
MAIL TAKE BACK PROGRAM FOR THEIR
COMPONENT.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY OR E. P.
R..
THESE PROGRAMS ALREADY EXISTING
CALIFORNIA FOR SEVERAL DIFFICULT
TO DISPOSE PRODUCTS.
THERE RUN BY THE MANUFACTURER.
THEIR OVERSEEN BY OUR STATE
AGENCIES THESE PROGRAMS WORK FOR
OUR TOUGHEST TYPES OF WASTE TO
SAFELY DISPOSE OF THEM.
AND WE CAN MAKE THAT WORK HERE
AS WELL AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABRERA [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
I THEIR OTHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I Y. CASKEY [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK.
NO.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
OR JUST.
OR JUST I DON'T KNOW. TWENTY
FIVE DAYS TWENTY FIVE KNOWS NINE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON DOWN TO
FILE ITEM -- ONE FLYKNIT.
BY SENATOR WHITE KASKI MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
SOONER ACOSTA.
ISN'T THIS IS C. STUDENT LOAN
TAX CREDIT THAT WOULD -- THAT
WOULD ALLOW A PERSON -- TO THE
DOCTOR TO GET TAX CREDIT ON THE
AMOUNT OF INTEREST THAT THEY
PAID ON THE STUDENT LOAN NO IT'S
NOT WITHOUT LIMITS ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR INDIVIDUALS IN.
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS -- FOR
JOINTLY FILING -- COUPLE.
THIS DEBT THE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
IS WE'VE DONE MORE RESEARCH ON
IT.
IS DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE BY
WOMEN IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
BORNE BY STUDENTS OF LOW INCOME
FAMILIES DISPROPORTIONATELY ONE
BY STUDENTS OF COLOR AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE.
BY FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN PROVIDING A TAX
CREDIT.
THIS BILL AS BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN
RECOGNIZES THE COST CALIFORNIANS
HAVE OCCURRED.
I RECOGNIZE THE COST EVEN
CURTAIN THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION
AND ALSO OFFERS THEM AND EIGHTY
PRETTY LITTLE AMOUNT OF RELIEF
AND I REGION I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE SIDE OF MORLOCKS SENATOR
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES SAID TAX DEDUCTION
REDUCES.
YOUR INCOME TAX BY THE
APPLICABLE TAX RATE SO.
A ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR DEDUCTION
WILL REDUCE YOUR TAXES BY SIXTY
DOLLARS IF YOUR TAX RATE IS 6%.
BUT A TAX CREDIT.
IS A ONE FOR ONE THE SAME ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS REDUCES YOUR
INCOME TAX BY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THAT'S A RATHER DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OUT OF THE STATE TREASURY VERSUS.
SIXTY DOLLARS.
AND I BELIEVE SB FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN IS IS IS A VERY VERY
GENEROUS TAX EXPENDITURE AND SO
THE TAX PREPARERS SIDE OF ME
COMES OUT THE BUDGET CONCERNS.
COME OUT AND I WOULD SAY THAT
WITH A POOR BALANCE SHEET THAT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY HAS AND YOU'LL SEE
THAT ONCE IT'S RELEASED SOME.
AFTER MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND.
BUT WE'VE STILL GOT PENSION AND
BOND PAYMENTS TO MAKE SO
COLLEAGUES I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE.
ON SP [inaudible]
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN ANY.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM.
HERE NINETY NINES CENTER WHY
BECAUSE HE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES I WOULD -- IT AT THE
THAT.
MY COLLEAGUE -- RAISES A GOOD.
POINT BUT YOU KNOW [inaudible]
NOT MEMBERS [inaudible]
TAXPAYERS HAVE -- ARE GIVEN A
CAP ON THE CREDIT THAT WE HAVE
WE WERE GOING TO HAVE AN
UNLIMITED IN IT WOULD HAVE HAD A
BIG A LARGER EFFECT ON IT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IT A ONE THOUSAND
DOLLAR CREDIT.
AND IT'S ALSO LIMITED TO PEOPLE
WHO DON'T EARN MORE NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND COUPLES
WITH TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO WE'VE TIGHTENING UP A
LITTLE BIT WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE TOOK AN APPROPRIATION.
AND I STILL THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE SPY -- SHINE A SPOTLIGHT
ON THE STUDENTS WHO ARE ARE YOU
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT THAT'S GOING ON NOW
AND NOBODY'S PROVIDING THEM WITH
ANY RELIEF IN THIS.
pIS BIG MY GOOD COLLEAGUE KNOWS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY THIS MONEY
WILL BE TURNED BACK INTO THE
ECONOMY AT WITH OTHER -- THE
EXPENSES THAT ARE -- USE
NITROGEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
I BRADFORD HI I COVER ADAM
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
I THE TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WIENER
[inaudible]
I WILK.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
I BURROW [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PRICE THIRTY SIX KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS.
FILE ITEM ONE OH SIX SENATOR
CAFIERO ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP THIS ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER RESOURCES
SENATOR FLOORS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS -- I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
WHICH TAKES A PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT HAS BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
THE PAST SIX YEARS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
TOGETHER WITH WATER AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT GROUPS AND THEY OP
THEY CONDUCTED IN A PLAIN MOUNT
MOUNTED ARIEL SNOW SURVEY.
KNOWN AS LIGHT ARE IN A PORTION
OF THIS YEAR IN NEVADA MOUNTAINS
THE RESULTS OF THIS TESTING ARE
IMPRESSIVE AND PROMISING AND THE
ACCURACY OF THE WATER VOLUME IN
THE SNOW PACK INCREASED BY TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND TIMES.
MORE THAN OUR EXISTING SNOW
SURVEY METHODS YOU'LL RECALL
THAT THAT SURVEY METHOD INVOLVES
SOMEONE GOING OUT WITH THAT.
WITH THAT A POLL AND MEASURING
HOW DEEP THAT THE SNOW IS WHICH
IS ONLY 60% ACCURATE THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY IS 98% ACCURATE --
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THIS
SURVEY TO INCLUDE THE REST OF
THIS YEAR NEVADA'S WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO REORGANIZE WATER
RELEASES FROM OUR EXISTING DAM
SITE.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
ON SEEING HEARING ON THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEE NO OBJECTION OZ THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ONE ELEVEN SENATOR DR GRANT ARE
YOU READY HE'S NOT AT HIS BEST.
OKAY ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT WE'RE
HOLDING MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY BY SENATOR
PAN AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS PRESEASON INTELLIGENCE --
CAMPUS COUNSELING SERVICES ARE
NOT MEETING THE GROWING STUDENT
DEMAND AND AS AMENDED SB SIX
SIXTY REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO ESTABLISH
A GOAL OF HAVING ONE MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELOR. TO EVERY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS AND
ROLE THAT EACH OF THE RESPECTIVE
CAMPUSES.
THIS RATIOS RECOMMENDED BY THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COUNSELING SERVICES TO ADDRESS.
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
SB SIX SIXTY ALSO HOPES TO
REMEDY THE GENERAL LACK OF
CONSISTENT REPORTING THROUGHOUT
EACH SYSTEM BY REQUIRING EACH
CAMPUS TO REPORT THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY THREE YEARS.
WE KNOW THERE'S A GROWING NEED
FOR THESE SERVICES AND SB SIX
SIXTY ADDRESSES THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS FACING
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WHILE ALSO GIVING US THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO CONTINUE
PROVIDE THE CARE OUR STUDENTS
DESERVE WE KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
FROM FREQUENT REASONS FOR
STUDENTS EITHER NOT SUCCEEDING
OR EVEN DROPPING OUT.
IS BECAUSE OF THE STRESSES OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN THE
ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION SB SIX
SIXTY AS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO FORMAL OPPOSITION I STRICTLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
TINA IT'S THE A CANNABIS FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THIRTY
EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS IS STILL OUT THOSE LAST
SIDE WE'RE TAKING UP TO DATE NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THIS TIME IS THERE
ANY.
ITEM THAT'S GOING TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL 636-686-1371
381-515-4160 1-651-791-9190
619-920-9211 216-228-23950
326-428-2872 892-929-4302
304-312-3153 213-406-3633
653-753-85390 541-242-4405.
452-453-4574 594-624-63460
547-149-5015 004-507-5195
353-855-4560 256-358-8580
959-260-6607 608-609-6116
1-862-662-8630 363-463-7640
765-651-6636 676-869-7067
257-367-38760. THREE SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN NINETY ONE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SEVENTY TWO AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
EIGHTY THREE MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USE IN OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SIX C. NINE
EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO LOOK TO
CALL WILL BE AT THAT ISSUE
SHORTLY
CLEAN OUT OUR LIST RIGHT
NOW WILL BE RIGHT BACK AT YOU
SHORTLY
.
OUR MEMBERS WERE GONNA LOOK TO
CALL FIRST ITEM IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI.
I JUST THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM SEC.
SEVENTY EIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
ATKINS ALLEN AYE ATKINS.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NOW.
ICE THIRTY KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT TIME IS FILE ITEM.
SIXTY MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
WELL. FIVE THERE ARE SO
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
HI HI.
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY ONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
HI.
ALL EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
EXXON WAS FILE ITEM.
ONE OH NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO OF
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT NEXUS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO.
ICE THIRTY FIVE KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
OUR FINAL ITEM MEMBERS IS FILE
ITEM.
EIGHTY FOUR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE.
NO -- TADA.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO.
ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS RETURN EMOTIONS AROSE
RESOLUTIONS [inaudible]
SENATOR ALAN.
I LIKE TO MOVE SCA TO TO THE
INACTIVE FILE PLEASE.
THIS WILL NOTE.
ITEM.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION. FOR ALL THE I'M SORRY
WITHOUT OBJECTION FALLING BILLS
WOULD FOR MEMBERS WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDED.
MINUTES ADOPTED -- FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO AND FILE I IT FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY SIX MADAM PRO TEM THE
DISS CLEAR.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH SEVENTY THREE
BILLS TODAY AND EIGHTY FIVE
BILLS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
BILLS.
WE ARE IN GREAT SHAPE.
I WOULD SAY MEMBERS IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY.
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
LONG LONG TIME.
BEFORE WE HEAR THIS KIND OF JIVE
TALKING AGAIN [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
WE WILL RECONVENE TOMORROW
MORNING FRIDAY MAY TWENTY FOURTH
AT NINE AM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
SENATOR GO JOGGING FOR WHAT
PURPOSE.
YEAH BUT THE AVENUE.
THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED AND
WE'LL RECONVENE TOMORROW FRIDAY
AT NINE AM THIS CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR THE DAY